I think I'm more comfortable on Starlord.
I don't know.
I'm fine.
I'm fine with whatever, to be honest.
What map have we been?
Hello, everyone.
I am very nervous.
I'm very nervous.
Hello, guys.
We're ripping it.
I don't think it matters too much.
I'm very anxious and nervous right now.
Also, I don't know the sound guys here because...
I don't know.
uh no i felt really bad because i think it was on our last
game during streams and then i got i got like yeah sure
let's ban the chat was not nice to me so i got really sad
i got really sad because the chat wasn't nice to me um and
so i was just like because i was like i needed I told them I
need to be microed because I'm not very used to this type of
environment.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, like.
Call for domination.
So I was just like, don't cry.
Don't cry.
Don't let yourself get rage pated very quickly.
Okay, knock.
I felt really bad because I was not doing so well during the
last the last this war of obscript and then people were
laughing at me like roasting me in chat being like this
person's not real why did you invite her to the team and i
was just like the i was just like it says custom visibility
or something when i was looking at it earlier i think that's
not they've been burning I'm gonna burn him with his burn
husk and it should be fine.
It's just warm up!
It's it's okay!
It's okay!
Yeah.
Um, but I will do my best.
I will do my best.
I don't wanna be the Sasa!
I'm a playhouse.
yeah yeah i'm i'm really thankful that they they let me on
the team so i will do my best i
i'll do my best
bands yeah in the lobby in the lobby he wants the he wants
the golden flag wait how do i do i want the best i can also
i don't know sound guys here let me know if i have to adjust
anybody's sound are you level 76 67 capo yeah yeah i'm 67
capo do our best we could do this we could do this no i was
doing really bad though like i will be accountable i played
really poorly because yeah i need to be micromanaged I'm
here.
All right.
Yeah, we're all there then.
I'm gonna put it right here.
Like I need to be micromanaged in the high screen
environment because I have the least the least experience
out of everybody.
And but I but then like they're treating me as if I know
what I'm doing.
So then I was just chucking because I was just like go NW.
I'm just like when do I chuck my all and then I was just
chucking my rocket all rat like whatever like whenever I
feel like like in my gut feeling was right but it was not
right well the last seven days i played how many games i
played internet because i was like i don't know where to put
my own no one's telling me where to put my own okay here's
my own 120.
this is like here it is this is i did i do okay and then and
then i felt apparent i did not it was it was it was not an
okay uh save gambit i guess teammates are a bit loud i don't
know what sound guy is here i do believe you're back but i
will turn them down i think you make i'll turn everybody
down see if they're gonna play i'm just making like little
mistakes but this is very in my head i don't know no they
are these are all like yeah it's decision making i think you
need to shoot the enemy back they play every day i think you
should the enemy tank so much so i shouldn't get any
background more at the enemy angles like the phoenix the
starlord because once more i'm very important we shoot the
people outside of the healing range because then they need
to ask for healing like duck right and then the people turn
yeah which makes the emma lose hp in main you know i've been
more mindful of that i'm checking right now i don't think
any of my mods are online right now I just But I don't know
Ban Mantis or Loki I'm turning everybody down He would have
been Invalid this map But I'm not turning down Discord
Because like I have all my other friends Set up correctly So
I worry about that I don't think we need to ban it We have
Invis safe I'm just saying I don't think we need to ban it
right now Yeah I DMed my head mod But I think he's asleep
too Pretty easy
But it's awkward.
I think this is anarchy tab.
We have no mods.
This might be anarchy.
We have no mods online.
Or a ban.
Just look at that pool.
Oh, my head mod's alive.
Okay.
Can you type in chat for me?
Because I can't look at the screen.
I have to look at my screen.
If they don't save a support, I think I'm just taking all
the support.
i'm banning brook oh yeah that too i think you do phoenix
maybe this is a lot of pressure on me yeah this is the most
intense term i've ever been i've ever done i think brooket
ban is good cloak band is good cloak band is good yeah i
think cloak band is really good yeah it's fine crook a
little lower okay i'm like what adam luna okay we could have
also banned not adam what am i saying could have also banned
uh mac instead of cloak to get rid of the bubble when cloak
holds uh where do i play uh in this okay yeah in this in
this gambit yeah if they have angela make sure you keep the
okay charge i'll try my best i'm not sure if they want to
play it or not agu we can flank together okay okay i'll try
my best is he named she agu I'm better than yet.
Oh, wait.
Mods are here.
Okay, nice.
Okay, my mods are here.
Okay.
I jump back.
Mods are here now.
Yeah.
So trust me, you think I mag over Venom here?
I think Venom.
Okay, bad, bad.
Nah.
Nah, yeah, he did it.
Loki.
Why not?
Yeah, why not?
It's fine.
I think again, Doc plays with Doki on the right side and
it's left side actually.
Okay, left side and I go right side with trust and ugly.
Yeah.
but i don't i hate you wait how many games are we playing
for each round four three oh no no i meant like for each
team we're first seeing oh fighting fighting three to one
you're on top or do you want to go all the way all the way
all the way play main with you check what they have they go
to price guys they go to Don't hit them yet.
I'm ready to hit back then.
Yeah, yeah.
Bucky one, Bucky one.
Bucky no hook.
Mag one.
I pulled somebody there, but I don't know who I pulled.
I'm happy.
Live, live, live, live.
Live, live, live.
We kept, we kept.
We kept.
We can hit back then.
Yeah, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Like you're by yourself?
I have aggro.
Yeah, yeah.
There's two chasing me.
Luna, Luna, Luna.
I'm on point.
I can't.
I'm going back.
I'm on point.
I have pulled.
I put Luna.
Push Luna.
I'm on the back.
Nice.
Emma one.
Stabilize.
No worries.
I have my E.
Hit me.
Push the Mac.
Okay.
Two.
One.
Mac.
I pulled back.
Bucky.
I'm pushing back to him Bucky Huff push forward kill the Mac
kill the Mac kill the Mac kill the Mac Mac one Mac one Mac
one come set up with your style on left Mac Huff ever here
again.
We can't kill him.
I'll get back guys.
This is our kill box.
This is our kill box Right back.
Yeah, I'm ready for it.
We don't have to peek on don't make steps
Let them walk still let them walk.
Yeah, I am let that thanks for me One, I'm taking
unnecessary damage, bro.
That one's one.
We can hit.
Yeah, yeah.
I got you.
That one.
That one in the back.
I tried to get...
I pulled back.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma.
Just wait, just wait.
Go back.
Play in neutral.
I think we can get in star and we get through, okay?
We can kill through the narratives.
We need to be quite focused on that guy.
We can dial it all.
Can we start all?
Game it all?
One, let's go.
Going.
Manus, mantis, mantis, mantis, mantis.
One is two.
Nice.
Losable guys.
Can't, can't, can't, can't.
Can't.
I pushed him.
Okay, you can't touch.
Yeah.
Don't have touch.
Nice.
This is good.
They use both support, man.
Yeah.
They use Deadpool2.
I mean, they have a new one, but they will have a new one, I
mean.
I don't think so.
Wait, maybe Bucky is fixed?
No, I lose my deck.
They saw Bucky out, right?
Yeah, I always lose it between rounds.
Did they use Bucky?
Oh, that's weird.
I don't think they did.
They're Bucky, they're Bucky ammo only this fight.
We just have a free Venomult, okay?
Uh, listen.
We go above them.
Star, we go top left.
With me, with me.
I go there too.
Wait, who do I go with?
You just play, man.
Okay, okay, okay.
just follow dog sorry but your one-eyed warrior isn't even
playable yeah we could also tp bomb if you want ah you just
want to go and win i don't want to use him with this fight
yeah we can anyone should just wipe them yeah if they bucky
out i'll just use it just venom for damage they're gonna
they're gonna amma bucky probably because you gotta be
careful break the wall inside i'm going top don't go too
early just setting up still i can't call the hit.
Do you see them guys?
They're going main.
I don't...
Maybe pump, maybe TP, maybe TP.
No, they're on Namor.
Namor, Namor with Truffle.
I can drop on them, Adam.
I can drop on them.
Ready?
Three, two, one, go again.
Back climb on.
Don't even need Venom or anything.
All of them.
That's fine, it's fine.
I pulled some people back.
Luna one, Luna one.
Let me take a picture.
Come in.
Take it with me.
Kill them.
kill them oh yeah that's you guys got to get in the picture
next time okay that's not gonna get a team photo hey let me
know if you like get low so i can okay okay yeah yeah just
let me know if they're like hard hard focusing i'll try to
play safer let them walk let them walk you want to phoenix
on the on the roof yeah just walking man let them walk it's
fine let them walk still Let them walk.
Give the space.
Yeah, I can hit after.
I have my ult.
I can hit.
Three, two, one.
Got him all grass.
No more.
I pull back through.
Leave the ammo.
Oh, my bad, my bad.
Guys, let's get used to staggering as well, okay?
Guys, leave and...
Don't kill him.
Guys, also leave and give me last hit, okay?
Because I need it for a picture.
Map will change.
Oh, okay.
I can heal.
Map changes are 60.
There's a 50.
It's 50.
It is 50.
Yeah, map changing.
Watch out.
You just get ready to soft hit again.
This time they have support.
The map is changing here.
Yeah.
This is how I make it.
I'm just walking the Groot out.
Yeah.
Oh, shoot on point already.
You can even shoot on point to live.
Okay.
I can hit back then.
I'm gonna slam.
Two, one.
Luna, Luna, Luna.
And Titan.
Ah, we get flip.
It's okay.
I altered us.
I don't want Luna.
Look Luna, Luna 1.
They're all out.
I'm chasing them.
I'm going to get ready.
Wait, Groo 1.
Groo 1.
Get into me.
I'll kill all.
Two, one.
Walking up.
Kill through.
They're all out.
They're all out here.
Oh.
I'm okay.
Emma, Emma.
They will TP.
They have TP.
I can cancel.
Yeah, just go cancel.
Go kill it.
He's the only guy who can touch.
They're not starting TP yet.
Yeah.
Julie's TP.
No, he's not.
They didn't do it.
I guess they just gave up.
Oh, they did.
TP now.
Break the group for it.
I got it.
I can take the TP too.
Take it.
Oh, yay.
Nice.
GG.
Oh my god, I know my screen was fucked up, but I couldn't do
anything about it.
Oh, it was so zoomed in.
I'm sorry.
Oh my God.
I was, I tried to do full screen.
Oh wait.
I think the sharks now you just arrived.
Let me fix it.
I don't know how to fix it.
Give me a sec.
No, but I need to wash it first.
I can't get in there.
See, I can fix it.
Oh my God.
I just so zoomed in.
I knew it was super zoomed in.
But I was just like, oh, I need to play a game.
Me can't focus.
Why is it at home?
Holy shit, why the fuck was it there?
How many teams do we play per round?
Just one team.
Yeah.
All right, now it's better.
I don't know why it was like that.
I don't know.
Did my thing reset or some shit?
That's weird.
Imperator's team is playing against a pretty good team, too.
It's actually crazy.
They have Coach Cuffy.
All right.
I'm fixing everything.
I was so locked in.
I was very nervous.
no it's because like my res was for some reason at 2560
instead of 1920 the bite of 1920 so that's why i zoomed in
but like i was like i have to like start staggering yeah i
was shaking i'm just nervous especially when they have
static tanks within like 20 seconds with one stagger like
this is that this is literally like the most intense term
i've ever participated didn't so i'm like all over i'm like
oh it's literally my mood right now i'm gonna replay that
i'm just like yeah we did one thing oh god oh smith wait is
this the you're right thank you i'm glad i'm glad you guys
think i'm doing okay the other way confused.
I won't think it's some way.
Mid-tone.
Yeah.
Like, I'm literally the baby in this team.
I'm literally like, please come baby, I'm sorry.
Yeah, I want to be micromanaged.
I want to be micromanaged so bad right now.
Yeah, I'm literally the little sister.
And like, it was so for me because we were screaming against
like the the best teams for this tournament and then the all
the teams knew i was the baby and then they're like get her
stop stop dying because they all like i didn't know what to
do that's like guys they're all trying to kill me and
they're like yeah because they knew you're the you're the
weakest out of all of us so they strategically are diving
you purpose because they know they could kill you very
easily.
I'm like, ah!
I'm just like, ah!
So, so, yeah, no, like, look at me, the Grandmaster one and
everybody's to just you on eternity.
The Amazon driver was very confused.
I want to know, well, I'll turn out, trust me, a little bit,
yeah.
Doki Snake Case.
Oh, yeah.
i'm here i'm here yeah we're waiting on on them okay then i
guess i'm gonna use the bathroom all right i go pee real
quick i'll be right back what is the better word allowed or
granted both words are good i think i think granted might be
better allowed is like oh no just sounds weird
Trust me, come over here on Spider-Man in practice.
Bro, you lose it.
No, I don't.
I was on ping.
Now that I'm not on ping, you're going to lose.
I was on ping last time, too.
Yeah, it was like 180 last time.
Who has permission put on friendly fire?
It was me.
Do you want it?
Yeah, yeah.
I turned it on.
I'm in, like, the bottom.
this match is interesting you said yeah that's it they're
losing
i'm okay i'm back hey what kind of trickery is dead i'm i'm
i'm just no i i i nervous peed a snake is still the kid are
you kidding me i'm nervous peeing what is that i'm i'm so
i'm actually i'm so i'm all over the place emotionally right
now let's go i'm beating the stress out right now okay i'll
say it i'm not allowed to say that i had the nervous p i
don't grant you permission for that there's oh my god it was
like top 500 number one top five top 500 number one and then
i'm just little old me little old doggy the diversity pick
on the scene
the mascot slash diversity pick
i know you're talking about yeah the boxes we're gonna play
against a full diver we'll be fine yeah You could just like
dive as well.
No, these are like world champions slash top 500.
Never stopped getting top 500.
I'm the make a wish kid.
I am.
Would you like to make my wishes to play at this tournament?
And then monkey paw curl.
You guys like Celsius's, the energy drink?
Doesn't exist in this continent, I think.
talk about i'm not allowed to talk about energy drinks only
about red bull all right oh wait we can do this oh true i
could only talk about uh g fuel wait trust me we gotta play
bro we gotta what we gotta fight is that so we gotta fight
for a bottle of the caffeine it's not even my i was the vows
i even say i'm vibing i can't i'm just a little stress ball
right now i'm a little ball of stress
i'm a little ball of stress right now i can't even vibe if i
want to all robin they got me it's time for cap cap and uh
that pool
kept that pool angle now they ban phoenix i could go back
all right here you go i think you should do it though okay i
can do this first point we can play something different but
i would still play it or cap angela it's also fine whoa whoa
whoa whoa oh they protected vanguard dead pool they might be
cooking i'm back ah she's hit support phoenix i think it's
okay i'm guaranteed finals because i get to be on the show
match i don't win any money though but like i get to show up
okay look they're talking they're disgusting picks right now
i don't need it input anything i have zero input on this oh
okay i feel like they might be phoenix oh is that support
okay oh yeah it is support they just lose group matches if
they band up i can't tell i can never figure out the no
that's his tank yeah oh wait no that's strategist it is i i
don't know icons clearly
oh more attack right wait what are you at yeah yeah yeah i
can i think luna in this it's really just in this okay let
me think yeah i think this is fine do you want to tp behind
them or just on the high ground i think it's It's not bad if
you play that pool.
Or do you want to rotate all the way on the bottom left?
I mean, the problem is as long as I don't have my big E, I
can't really risk anything.
So I don't know if TPing behind is that good yet.
It doesn't have to be you TPing.
It could be a star.
Yeah.
You want me to?
Yeah, I think you do.
I think you do.
any input on this because they're much more knowledgeable
than me and i just listen a good soldier listens you want me
to do it like on top of the patch but it's okay but soldier
takes it don't swap you don't swap yeah i'll wait i won't
i'll wait Looks good.
Good.
Okay, I'm swapping.
Those bullets are not.
Snake is you push the Naimore, okay?
And Glitter Scrits.
Nemore and Helm.
I'm going to push the Invis, I'm going to push the Invis,
guys.
I'm shooting emmores, Emma one.
Yeah, Emma and Emma have?
Is that?
Where is that?
Is that in there?
I'm lapping everyone.
Clapping everyone.
Chill.
Chill, chill, just live.
Just live.
Okay.
I bought you.
I pulled the Emma half.
Emma low too.
I killed Luna.
kill point kill point Emma 1 kill point kill point they're
going to TP they're not TP they don't even need some help
they don't have time they're both their DPS just like ran at
our spawn yeah they just ran at me and duck I want to use
all the carry you walk up a bit for me yeah I'm not there
though I got a far spawn let me take top let me take top
wait a second I'm with you trust me Just don't peek right
now.
Just carry me out.
I can hit a little snake.
I'm going to fight right now.
I'm with you.
Trust me.
Okay, you can hit.
3, 2, 1.
Invis, Invis, Invis, Invis, invis, invis.
I'm in diamond.
Luna again.
I can't hit a shot.
I'm one, I'm one.
I'm dead.
Little one, little one.
We got Luna.
Emma no diamond on top.
Got you.
I have one and one open.
I have Phoenix.
She's all here.
I'm back soon.
It's right then.
Hello here.
You first or me, pro?
Never one.
Dead, dead, dead.
I pulled Mac off.
I pulled off.
Buick, be careful.
Be careful.
Shoot the Luna, shoot the Luna.
Shoot the Luna.
Oh, that's okay.
Push hella.
Push him up.
Shielding him up.
Shield him.
He can maybe kill him.
Walk up, walk up, walk up, walk up.
Finish them.
Never dead.
We're close.
You want to help us all here?
Yeah, we're getting too close.
Really?
Three, two, one.
I pulled him back!
Hell Yeah.
Hell yeah, I mean hell yeah.
.
Get him a point.
I can get him a point.
He's on point.
Just leaps.
I wish I was like, we got here.
Nice.
Nice push, nice push.
Nice push.
Can we hit by...
Kill, Mack, Mack going too deep.
Mack dying, Mack dying.
Emma, Emma on point.
Emma on point.
Turn Emma, turn.
I pulled him back.
Take a picture.
Smile!
Okay.
Walk up, walk up Doki.
Take the swing.
Can I get flake?
Yeah.
I'm going far right.
I'm gonna Phoenix saw here this fight.
I think just start that full loop.
Yeah, I can walk in the flap closed here.
I'm waiting for it.
Yeah, let them walk first.
Of course.
Yeah, yeah.
When they walk through the choke, okay?
It's like you wait until they walk through the choke, then I
can hit the back line.
I'm getting marked by Mag.
Oh, I couldn't get to you.
I pushed to him.
Ready?
That's fine.
I'm going.
I get a hammer.
Luma, Luma.
Alone in the back.
I am.
Mag one as well.
I need kill.
Oh, he just fucking rocked in and out of here.
I'm not here.
I got a chance here.
I'm going to go.
Yeah, let's swim.
Oh, bro.
I need a lift on one side.
Just wait.
Wait, just wait.
Stop poking.
You already have one.
Just wait.
Wait, go wait.
Okay.
I'm just not changing.
Trust me, I'm with me.
I can open the map from right.
I'm coming with you guys.
I'm going left right now.
I can walk, Snake.
Walk up.
The ammo's inside you guys, you shot.
I go behind.
Hello, one.
Hello.
I'm going to go.
Got her.
Mac, Mac, Mac.
Walk forward.
On the ammo, ammo.
I'm on ammo 1.
Got your back.
Emma's solo.
Okay, take a picture, okay?
Here, here, here, here.
Yeah, I'm with you.
Oh, I did it the wrong way.
It's mine.
I did it the wrong way.
I didn't get it.
I need to hear.
I love that right.
Yeah.
Oh, I knew it too.
I forgot he flips it.
Oh, it is the first game.
The games will get progressively harder because it's open
div rules.
Open division rules from Overwatch.
So you guys remember, it's like the more wins you get,
you're facing as other teams with the same record.
so like first game everyone has like blank record but then
it gets progressively harder and that's why I'm like oh yeah
so yeah it's Overwatch open div rules for like how the
format is yeah go back into the lot and screenshot it now
yeah Swiss system yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't know what the
I just know it's that that one yeah and I used I played an
open div before so I remember the reroll is for it maybe i
should bring out my own snuggie brand 30 seconds before yeah
so i'm like trying to lock in as much as i can i've never
been as stressed out in a tournament before because it feels
like i'm competing again when i used to do tier two i feel
like i'm back in tier two hell this is why i left and became
a streamer i was like never again never again
depends how much you want to spend on it i guess you have to
stop them from securing the mission area but he's running on
it and i tried it i think it was good you're ready yeah
probably on our backline yeah oh yeah oh yeah i can clap in
okay we have we have slow confidence i'm signing up on the
right i'm signing up on the right don't allow that don't
allow their dps to angle though just wait just wait kind of
see where they're going i'm not doing anything yet they're
portal closed i pushed the name more there's like there's
someone in the front i need care i need care look at me i
can't there's everybody was so we need tp back we need tp
back everyone was very a little bit of place i'm coming
inside i got luna i got luna oh i could i got luna tp on
imbiz tp on imbiz yeah i can i'm doing it now ready to one
Emma, Emma, Emma instead.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Namur top, half HP behind.
Namur, half HP behind.
We'll leave one healer camp.
I'll kill him.
I'm trying to play out of it.
I'm gonna help our lining up.
I'm trying to lie on everything.
Oh, the Emma blocked us off.
Yeah.
We must have Invis all.
I must have Invis.
Yeah, 94, 95.
Playing on the pillar here.
I got grabbed.
That mag is half mag.
Just play your life, play your life.
Oh, I can bubble.
I'm dead here.
I have ult after this, just show.
I'm gonna die.
I'm dead here.
I'm going for you.
I have ult.
I can damage.
Damage.
Nice.
We could win.
I have Phoenix all next.
now.
Yeah, Bob?
I play on shit.
Nice.
I'm gonna just save all of her.
I might let Emma.
I literally saw Emma's leading the back.
I'm one in the left.
I just got back.
I got you.
Emma, I got you.
QMAC, QMAC blocking hills.
Wait, hello.
I'm dead.
Trust me, it's Mike.
Got cut out?
Yeah.
so yeah i can hear him take top left take this room here
helo is playing really far let's walk up walk up walk up
walk up walking to the number one fellow it was really close
i got pulled down oh i'm just gonna die again trying to keep
you out i'm trying to kill magdito they're down to support
look at this one right I'm dead.
Are they going to hard push us?
Group up, group up, group up.
Yeah.
They're going to stay alive.
As they're, yeah, I don't know.
They're going to flank top left.
They're top right right.
They're pushing us.
We have to leave.
Emma is trolling.
No more, no bubble.
Hello on the right, so.
Emma one.
We're going main.
How do you care?
You can even miss it.
Did I miss it?
Yeah, I missed it.
We have to get on point, point, point, point.
Hop in this, hop in this, no.
Oh, they got point.
Oh, hello.
It's not okay.
I mean, ooh.
We're good.
We just let them get so much space on cart.
I think there's also...
Prestonie's mic is not working too.
I was just behind them.
I was worried.
Amore is so up.
He's dead.
Nice.
I got you.
Let's just play made normal.
Like,
should stop card here.
Yeah.
Hella's going far right.
There we go.
Come back guys.
Still up.
Priscilla.
I kill.
Okay, nice.
No more but I'm right.
Wait, no more.
No more.
No more buying.
I got him.
There we go.
fixing it just play the just play you're still down in we
don't we don't have a deadpool hello hello hello oh yeah we
can hear you this is so bad i'm sorry they're all going left
they're It's okay, it's okay.
Upper Luna, how are you?
No diamond, Emma.
Hella's going left.
Hella's going far left.
I'm gonna match.
I can match him too.
They're all going left.
They're all going.
I hit from behind.
They're all...
Three, two, one.
Back, left.
Hella, no bird.
Can we break?
Stop being a little bit.
I'm gonna try and break.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm reloading.
I pulled her back.
Oh, we can't get to you guys over there.
Leave the mag.
Don't kill the mag.
Okay.
Leave the make.
Says the guy that killed him.
Just keep holding the choke.
We don't have to play super kills.
I'm going to go for a flank ult, okay?
I've got upgrades.
Just let them take the long rotation.
I can hit them with my sword ult here.
Actually, I'm gonna go with gun bolt.
Don't go too early, not set up.
Yeah, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You can do first.
I have ult too.
I'm gonna go for a flank ult, okay?
Can we go?
Yeah, I'm going.
Two, one.
Baffling.
I'm altering her.
Keep up all.
Guide it guys.
You can immemoral watch.
I'm, I think I'm dead here.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
Gonna use my arm.
Oh, I'm out.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Oh, actually I should have wasted that.
Shoot her.
E'M, M-I-Emm, Emma, Emma, Emma.
Oh, she's dead.
She's dead.
Nice statement.Like, mech-mech, Mac, Mac, maybe?
I'm not going inside.
Okay, then we can handle.
Not image.
Match image?
Mach image.
I'm actually.
Ky'ke behind.
We can fight them, now.
I'm clapping backline here.
I pulled Neymar back.
In this one HP.
Clearly you needed some help.
Oh, how about Luna?
Neymar, Neymar, Neymar.
Oh, I got Neymar all dead.
Oh, they're out.
They're 1 HP, no wings right now.
No support.
She had no supplies.
Just live, just live.
Just get out.
Yeah.
Don't need to fight it.
Thought you wouldn't see me again?
They don't have any support right now.
Trust me.
You get all mean you can combo.
Yeah, just wait.
I'm one.
you need to keep believing i'm behind them right now i need
to get healed up first i walk up ready so i'm acting look at
their supports trust me look at their supports on the right
both of them look at the hela look at the head okay i will i
will i will i can't help i hear someone I hear someone above
me.
Yeah, yeah.
Just chill.
Yeah, guys.
I want to hold above them with trust me.
You guys can stay main.
Come above trust.
Yeah, I will.
I'll drop from behind.
I'll drop from.
We can clap from behind as well.
I have my sword.
We should be able to kill you.
Ready?
They go right.
I'm trying to.
I'm trying to get you.
They're not TP.
They're not.
didn't we where's like where's it it's just on high ground
oh i'm gonna die in this in this yeah i need to kill hella i
kill hella i'm gonna be behind them here i have ults soon I
can hit backland.
I can hit backland.
Get ready.
Yeah, I'm with you.
Shield me here.
Show me here.
I'm touching.
Stepping them.
We gotta be careful.
Hello's coming back.
I don't know.
I'm going.
I'm alting this.
I'm going for supports.
Okay, lift.
Strange is low.
Strange one.
I'm back soon.
Look at your Phoenix.
I'm got you.
I got you.
I'm the AIS to die.
touch touch touch i'm back in two oh what the i purchased i
probably do a bubble i need to touch i'm one keep me up i
can make maybe don't die for it don't die for it no touch no
touch there's still down one yeah can you bubble captain's
back oh i'm on cap yeah it's okay that's my bad i just like
the seats i don't know why this is a thing though by the eye
of agamoto has to be like a loose cable
we are up a lot of time yeah we just got to be careful with
the tp cheese we got to play together you'll need a time to
win this one i'm not the type who fades quietly into the
background yeah i positioned badly there i was on high
ground because i wanted to do a cheeky push and then fucked
up and then the hell like got to me i could have dropped
down in time it's okay it's okay
i mean i don't know how to prevent the issue though like i
had this issue like three months ago and then it stopped
like you can just be a loose cable in your wire yeah i
should talk about dp yeah how do we want to hold i don't
want to give the name our top right i'll match it but i need
help the hell is gonna stay back in main by the way and
flank he's not gonna take tp
i can stay in this uh in this tower i'm gonna stay hidden oh
yeah you can scald if they tp you just play invisible and
okay i can try to cancel you can you can try to cancel oh
you're going up oh hit them one you have to stop you have to
stop during the mission area Just give it up.
Set up, guys.
Did they get it?
We're gonna TP on you, maybe.
Please be careful.
I will jump off.
They're not, they're not.
I'll help you.
I have good angle on high.
Let them walk up, guys.
Don't peek them, guys.
Don't peek them.
Just chill, just chill.
I'll get them.
I'm still on point.
I'm trying to see where the hell is.
Name or no bubble.
Hell is late.
Late main.
I'm looking at him.
I'm gonna take that.
Three, two, one.
I think this is risky as fuck.
Yeah, I'm dead.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Oh
You have a name where I split on you.
Don't need more kill a name or on high There's a mag coming
to center me And we're so height Mag one like one Might need
help fighting until we have a winner might need help just to
realize it's just to be less thank you and we're touching
nice nice nice the current score is three two three time to
switch things up including which side you're on no i'm just
super hyper locked in you would push from behind i'm like
just really locked in right now locked in don't you sound so
I'm just reminded I was like I love competitive I love
tournaments and I played this I was like I remember why I
stopped playing tier two now I remembered why I like like I
got I got like PT is like oh I remember why I stopped
playing tier two I was so stressed out
Do you want to TP?
I was so straight.
I was like, I love tournaments.
I want to do more of them.
And then I did this.
I was like, you know, I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do my do this.
I'm gonna try still.
I'm gonna try this.
I haven't done these types of tournaments in showdown.
It's just like back in my Overwatch days.
And now I'm like, oh, I think this would be the last time I
do a very competitive tournament.
I'm just so stressed out.
I can go DD, trust me.
And you should be TPing though.
And you should be TPing, I think.
uh and go phoenix studio like that's why i like stopped here
too i was just it was just too much okay the tp don't let
him cancel same same tp all right yeah yeah yeah yeah what
they did right which means it's probably not right everybody
hello i'm fighting the mag you guys can Luna no snowball.
Walking on the back.
Meghawk.
Waited, waited.
I hit top 2.
Or I'm pushing the Neymor.
I can't help you there.
Neymor 1.
Neymor dead.
Nice.
Live, live, live, live.
I've already got Snake.
I'm trying to reload.
I have to reload.
I got you.
I need to have Snake She's like, I need to have Snake for
it.
I can push backline and kill one second.
Wait a second.
We need a move.
I'm back one, I'm back one, I'm back one.
Little one.
Oh, there's like three people coming from the top here.
Just what's the point guys?
What's the point?
MLO, MLO.
Oh.
Nemo behind, Nemo behind.
Run, run, run, run.
Yeah, I got it.
Nice.
Yeah.
Final score.
Four, two, three.
So it's best of three, right?
That's GG's.
Yeah, SGGs.
Three aliens, didn't we?
Uh...
Do you guys recognize those names?
I think they're...
They're definitely Asia.
I think they're all EU.
Oh, Asia.
No, they're Asia.
Really?
It's probably Asia.
Yeah, but the pain wise it's Asia.
I'll be right back on it.
It's definitely...
Oh my god.
That was...
brazil oh someone said brazil yeah that makes sense too okay
yeah but it gets harder it gets progressively harder and
harder the more teams we fight you need to wait you need to
wait until we drop on backline so how it works is basically
we're fighting teams with the same record as us as we go up
so the more games we win the harder to type of thing you
don't want to trade resources too early you know so i'm like
okay all right yeah i gotta wait for them to verify but i'd
like second point on defense when i got pulled down i don't
i don't really know where i'm supposed to play there do you
remember that i don't know which which situation i can watch
it apparently we fought uh it was a brazil team uh let me
find it let's see i'm looking at what next match i wear like
uh 12 or 13 minutes like protein like the commercial thing
yeah next like there i feel so awkward i don't know oh i'm
so when is your last 13 minutes when second point but okay
our next match is in 13 13 is in 20 minutes okay yeah let me
see it's in 20 minutes okay you walk main not okay you're
going to hop is fine like all forcing down top is good you
know i think it's important that you shoot up the hell out
first though and uh and shoot off the walkout because you
want to avoid that we take a lot of damage right if i should
shoot in the walkout should instantly do that because now
they got a lot of coupons in which caused our formation to
crumble so we can't line up for invasiles right then next up
when we walk you know you want to take above them here
because how many teams up you should just go in the on the
edge of the corner of the thing or more it could be more
honestly that's kind of okay i want to like honestly i want
to obviously need to keep i want to not play on full stream
before you might get most frames but because of the the fact
that you didn't shield out and walking like our team
couldn't peek and then they peeked but not rapidly if you
already super chat thank you yeah so yeah because we can put
oh yeah 600 teams yeah oh no no it's it's recommended but
it's not recommended but it's not required so we can we
don't need that have stream delay everything we should do
that more often it's like what was our end goal for going up
here like just like jump on them or i don't know i pay on
yeah it kind of felt it kind of Normally you would want
Pella or Neymar on the high ground, right?
Or Phoenix.
But I guess we could have also...
We could have had like a split, you know, Krook and Pella on
top and you were playing with someone else.
1440p monitor.
Because they obviously stuffed it.
And we need to calculate whether we can fight the stuff or
not.
And fighting into the emerald diamond here is pretty risky.
So going main would have probably been the better play.
We're learning a lot.
Yeah.
Like I feel like we do a lot of these plays where we go off.
I don't know.
I feel awkward in this play.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
when there's like i mean last last point and example is a
good example right you have to touch point at least that's
what you feel like to do and into emma it kind of feels
rough right so you have to wait until me and duck develop on
the backline that's when you walk on the point because once
the backline is contested you will win the resource trade
against emma yeah before you lose the resource trade so if
you give them 600 teams no beam charge before that's bad for
us or bad for you in the end because you have to touch point
against full beam emma so if you don't give him beam and
then you touch the point last seconds he will be having
learning right now because he yeah charges people i'm
learning today i'm processing information i'm processing
yeah but other than that i mean it's it's just also my bad
my mic just cut out it probably is a vocal contacts oh what
is that in english you need to do it's eight rounds actually
not seven it's eight rounds and um if the record seven one
you get an automatic access into uh into the finals
basically because that bro i just say nothing i mean i just
say like what i have to say for this but i don't i
definitely i think i think i'm very much more suited for
creator tournaments oh the next match is at 12 15.
well pst for me oh it's like 15 minutes so it's yeah so for
est that is at 3 15.
your pst okay yeah i'm pst oh you're in california no i'm
canadian what the where like british columbia oh that's the
secret that's the secret i'm somewhere in canada yeah oh
okay i didn't know you're canadian i thought you were uh oh
yeah yeah my american my very american accent i mean it's
like i yeah i'm very american coded i know yeah the the
quebec was yeah yeah no i'm not i'm not from there i'm not
from the east side of canada i see uh my family loves canada
they've been traveling there a lot i have never been to
canada though they always love me because it's like long
travel and i was too young oh wait they still don't do they
still travel there no not anymore uh i mean it's pretty cat
canna's very nice it's like very lots of nature stuff
basically i think that yeah yeah it's similar to norway i
mean every norway country is kind of cool i mean it isn't
like norway is like one of the happiest countries in the
world or are they depressed because it's always snowing i
don't remember yeah but they also take incredible amounts of
snooze so i would also be happy when i was there not that i
take it but i'm just saying they have infinite amount of
drugs there so i don't know if that accounts that makes them
happier maybe i don't know i don't know if they they write
that off in the stats i don't know That's crazy.
I wonder if it's like cheaper.
That's crazy.
There's a...
They're just so happy because they're just fully drugged up.
Like...
There's the... It's not a correlation.
Okay, I have confirmation.
Apparently it's not true what I said.
No, no, it's not Norway.
Wait, then which country is it?
Oh, it's like Netherlands, right?
It's Denmark.
Oh, it's Denmark.
Yeah.
I feel like Denmark would be very stoic though, aren't they?
The Danish?
I don't know.
They're weird.
They have incredibly tall guys there.
I know they're all super tall and they all take snooze.
Is that what it's called?
I think so.
What the fuck is snooze?
Oh, it's popular.
in Scandinavia and it's less harmful than I thought.
Yeah.
He's like, I'm good.
Oh, it's called Zin.
What the fuck?
I don't know.
I think it's just a lot when there's just so many different
types.
Oh.
Man, it was all about that, Zin.
i'm like learning i'm like what the is then i'm learning so
much is it just like you know you know what zen is what is
it sure you know zen it's the nicotine pouches oh put it in
your lips no i mean is it health it's healthier than smoking
right i mean it's still like nicotine though it's still
nicotine yesterday you know uh thing you can act uh oh no
wait what's it called oh no i mean regardless it's it's not
healthy but it's healthy you're a question probably it's so
bad it's less bad sorry that should rephrase this it's less
bad than smoking is it i don't know anything about this i
don't smoke you wait you can get mouth cans cancer from it
still no we gotta wait for every oh it's more concentrated
oh it'll take a while oh every matter can it's actually
pretty bad definitely not there is way to over overload just
do you want lung cancer or mouth cancer bro that's crazy i
was just thinking like i mean if it's a patch because
usually like those who are like addicted to the smoking they
get nicotine patches oh who which team did they verse
because if they burst a hard i need kukui asylum blaze um
it's just ranked players oh like eu ranked players or na
ranked players and they and they ah yeah i don't recognize
It's okay.
Everyone gets one loss.
That means that means their team gets to fight Easier teams
now you want to lose early so you fight easier teams Yep,
but it's probably a via contact issue my mic.
I'm back.
Muzo is playing as well.
Trust me Muzo's what?
He's playing as well with which players is with Knazin bro
Oh man Muzo they lost
they and Imperator's team are 1-1 right now oh it's 1-1 I
think so it's tiebreaker did they lose I don't know yeah
it's 1-1 you're right I thought I saw 1-1 I saw a lot of
like oh you're right you're right I saw a lot of Overwatch
ring players in this tournament too yeah they play because
they they're not pros in this game yeah makes sense they
have like the game sense a name I also have the name yeah
let's pick apart and we also thought about picking up some
horse players back then
oh if you stand back early you get easier games I mean
that's how it goes but then you don't really want to risk it
because you don't know if you're like you know it's all RNG
to who you match up with it's like MRC like some teams
gotten easier some teams got easier into top 16 for mrc or
mri because of the the group state the matchups and stuff
like oh my god it's really it's like will you get good rng
for your matchup because like some of the best like at one
point yeah like like at one point like i remember for this
year's mrc uh some of the two someone like one of the top 10
teams got matched up And then it fucked them over.
And they got knocked out.
Because they got matched up to the best teams.
Like twice.
Yeah.
So it's like.
It's either.
So it's like RNG.
If you're going to get a freebie team.
Or a hard team.
I live in Scandinavia.
Just got.
No.
Don't.
I don't endorse it guys.
I.
Guys.
I am not endorsing.
Any use of nicotine.
Guys.
Guys, I was just asking a question to be more knowledgeable
of the subject, which is very different from anything, from
endorsing anything.
Thank you for the super chat.
Really, thank you, thank you.
Blackfire, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
It was for educational purposes as a new region I can
confirm.
I didn't, no, no, no.
I said, oh, is it?
healthier than smoking i i phrased it in a questioning tone
if
it was it was a it was a question not not a statement
hello already bought 600 patches thanks toky thanks for the
recommendation
oh yeah i'm just oh my gosh okay i want i'll talk about this
on the zombie thing but like so many of my tweets and
comments are going like out of um like what's it called out
of the community oh breaching what's it called when like
stuff goes out out of the uh circle uh what's it called
no like when it goes outside of your circle is it that's
that was called reaching containment or going outside of my
circle should be on the thing it's on the website but it's
not really a bracket because but i made a joke tweet about
you know how i always tweet about like i don't see it's not
a joke like you know the office joke and i always make that
joke every time because i just think it's funny and then um
so i made that for hightail uh yeah i left left my target
audience yeah yeah yeah it left my target audience and i got
so many people angry at me being like just because you're a
streamer you think you deserve special treatment or like um
what if someone used to had dokeybird before i think you
took their name and i was like i will let you guys know
dokeybird was not like a thing like nope no one took
dokeybird that's why i am dokey bird literally like when i
made dokey bird um like no one ever had the name dokey bird
before and that's why i was able to use dokey bird and it
was only and then it was like a free for uh because you
don't have to trade resources and you can't just but then it
was crazy people were like um just because she did a
trademark it has she has no claim to dokey bird so anyone
could And it's like, if if Hytale gives her, gives her
dokeybird, then that game is dead to me in my eyes because
then they should give special treatment to everybody, not
stream, just streamers.
And I'm just like, what the?
I was just trying to make a ha ha ha funny tweet.
Like I was just referencing the office.
I was just like, I'm just making an office reference.
I think it's office.
It's office too retro now.
Is the office old school?
No, no one can recognize an office reference.
Of course.
No drama from.
It's crazy.
just like probably been a wolf maybe yeah that that will be
a ben i can agree with oh my god i was just like what the
fuck is going on no but think about the opportunities make
it you're thinking different the office is officially of his
status our video yeah i think twitter honestly oh my god
this venom i can't honestly the worst part is that i will
agree twitter is like meeting the so negative now like
anytime you try to make a funny twitter comment or like a 20
funny tweet like people uh please people would like uh just
go insane i'd like just go like like just find something
wrong with something because i was like i did not expect
people to be like so mad about the hightail tweet and also
when i was like hey guys i want some fps gaming suggestions
because like i want to play more fps games again because
like um you know i do love shooter games but haven't been
really playing because there hasn't been a really good
recent releases and people took that tweet yeah and like
twisted it so out of context and shit and mean like oh like
oh numbers and shit like that i was just like no i just
realized like you know i do miss shooters and like i
realized like you know that was what i started with and
people were like literally twisting my words for the fucking
uh the the for that tweet because i all i was trying to say
is like hey guys can you suggest me some games because i
know that hit game is arc raiders and i just don't i can't
fucking with arc raiders because like it just doesn't click
with me because i'm not an extraction shooter player so like
i just want more suggestions and then and the people twisted
that i mean and shit i'm like it's just all engagement
baiting
yeah it's oh so you just hit all video game you should suck
it up and just play art creators god they're like just
because you're not good at art you're just bad at shooters
that's why i'm like i just gotta take forever suggestions
you're just opposing you're just everyone always ask me i've
seen so many people from your stream snake come to me and
say what do i think about your venom i think i like waffles
you so you hate i get a lot of people asking about you yeah
it's normal right it's normal yeah it's like part of the
game i would of course say i'm better but i just i have to
say that too okay but the high tower was also crazy too i
was just like like just because you were a streamer you
think you could just demand special privilege and i'm like
you want to get better i'm just making an office reference i
each one each day it was just a funny tweet because i
literally instant quote retweeted not don't keep me i do you
are the best at attack as well i think oh that animation
cancel yeah i think you're the best i literally right after
i was like not don't keep me really yeah i do i do i do it
all the I'm not one dead guy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Well 70% of Twitter is currently bots a lot
engagement rage bait commoners and the AI for the bots is
pretty well trained But it's like people who don't have
enough real problems and they give the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Like I just got a new mouse and mouse pad like a
week ago.
What'd you go two weeks ago?
I guess a few weeks ago now uh hit skin and uh artisan
raiden.
It was crazy though.
I was not expecting I was not i was not expecting like the
backlash of that tweet in general that's what it has like
almost a million views and i'm like it's like a viper v3 is
the office truly retro now no i can't make the office jokes
no boy it's now oak status oh i don't let it get no i don't
i don't let it get to me i just thought it was like really
funny pretty good but yeah i'm using that one the new one
from logitech obviously we're sponsored so i need to use
logitech here the g pro too um i switched between the super
light two and i switched between the the new one i don't
know what's the super light strike I think it's called oh is
it ergo or is it just uh it's it's mechanical like there's
no click I meant like is it like a right-handed mouse or is
it like for both hands yeah you have day stream open the
enemy team comp is crazy they don't like triple tank rogue
time for day
yeah i mean i don't know i don't think this matchup is good
cringe alarm on storm wait are you watching are you watching
the day game it looks like a full health angle to me i can't
deny that i can't believe days 14 spider-man triple thanks
so there's no chance this comp is winning this is hard
losing yeah i'm just listening to their conversation i'm
like a little fly on the wall they has to put on the perform
the only way to make this winning is days only kills anyway
wait i forgot that's such an unbelievable step wait guys we
got it i forgot they included a very important update i just
realized bro i love spider-man i swear i want to learn that
hero more that hero is so i think it's the i think it's the
funnest character to play in the game it is the most fun
character right next to dead level i think wait where is it
that is what i Emma's just dead.
How do you get there?
Or like, he should have died, right?
Where's the club?
I don't know how to get to the club.
Charles, I need directions.
Where's the club at?
He just creates an entry pick like that.
Just because Spider-Man is just so impressive.
Where the fuck is the club?
He is so strong.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Let's go!
on her shirt but why would they be the one to stop i see
cringe alarm zero four almost zaza stats okay i hear oh my
god look at this matchup like punish her into double in
result is also so bad how do i no i want to do my own dance
i don't even have an ult to support do i not have my own
dance but they have no tank to farm cloacal so cloacal are
you serious no mac but What's the point if I can't...
I'm sad.
I thought I could...
I thought I could twerk.
Oh, that's...
What's the point if I can't twerk though?
What's...
Guys, I think I have to shut down Club Doki.
He can't...
No cake here.
Oh, see, that is what I mean.
The heroes will be.
I hope I don't get DMCA the last time when they did the
anniversary stuff.
I heard like Ultron looks so slay when you look at him.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'll tell you guys.
Now the real question is, you know, Snakes.
Who's the better Venom?
You or Andrew?
This is this dance.
I'm not touching that with a...
I'm trying to remember which dance it was.
That was like super...
You were afraid to answer.
Is it this one?
Oh, yeah.
Go Ultra!
Go!
Slay, girl!
Slay!
Like, I think your macro is way better than mine, obviously.
Like, yeah.
Oh, I mean, Andrew.
I don't mean me.
I mean, obviously.
You're better.
Come on.
I go off, Cleen!
I never won in this game.
Go off!
He's got the waist, I don't.
I've only seen your venom in actual pro matches.
Yeah, it's true.
Like, yeah, I just think your macro is...
You won.
Not gonna lie, he got the game.
I don't have that many hours on it on the account, but I
have infinite hours and streams, right?
I mean, we stream three hours a day, six hours a day.
Just two hours a day.
At least three hours of that is venom.
You can see the hours in the career that you see in the
game.
He has the waist though.
He really does.
Oh, they are not happy.
He has the waist.
The vibe's so off.
Show me the stats day.
What else?
It would be good.
I mean, like, oh, maybe what does Punisher look like with
the swimsuit?
Oh, you can't see shades of gray.
he knows what he has he is let's go i mean do they know the
penny team up is not existing anymore they're so good man
look at look at punisher go yeah i think so probably oh my
god the disrespect is also crazy wait day's team is just
cooked no zero pros that is so crazy oh my god look at
rocket oh my god the hip slap on rocket though
everyone is always so ruthless all right let's oh magneto
you want to see magneto i don't know what skin oh i have
default skin
you're so mad she still got this
also play against this old man still got this gold old man
go because you get worse opponents next all right oh i do
not have any magneto skins you you fight against yeah but
think about it in that way eventually you're gonna win when
you would lose you know so that would i think the i think
the luna one is the best for sure you know what i mean i
explained it bad but i think the luna best dancer ever.
I wish you could, but I honestly wish you could.
Oh my god, look at Oh my god, bro.
Oh my god, wait.
And the team that loses at 5 wins, this actually
accentuates.
Oh my god.
Look at, okay, but look at Torch.
Look at... The only difference is when you lose in the first
round, look at Torch though.
He's got the legs for it for sure.
He's got... You see that?
He's got the legs for it.
There's no...
Oh my...
No!
It can also be unfair though.
Like in Overwatch and Xamarin, there are a lot of cases in
Open Division where you would just like have a...
Like bad teams could face bad teams even at seven wins.
Wait, how do I...
Can I...
No!
I can't do this as hard!
What's the point?
Wait, oh wait, you can't!
You can face a team that Terra beat.
So it can be very two strong teams to face when there's
infinite other teams to face who are just on paper wars.
Yeah!
That's just the system how it is.
it it's on average though it gives you let's go get it
bruised okay like it's the first system
all right let's see where it's double elimination and you in
the group with or like in the first two slots with teams
that are very high seated or very good all right well dance
well dance while i use the back throw up your back i gotta
do another nervous p up your back need to get better
oh they're arguing oh it is bad are you watching are you
watching day trust me yeah it's also not worth to like over
like i'm sorry to say but it's not that super much money of
course there's money on the line and like reputation more
than money in this kind of tournament but there's so many
teams
too early on.
I mean, I can see his points, but at the same time, I can
also see the other's points.
You know?
Imperators and idiots?
Nah, don't say that.
It's just a classic moment of everyone being super
individual and everyone wants to be that guy, you know?
Snobble.
You got both cloak and dagger.
But even in pro play, we always argue with each other too.
like all a job to do i want back i wish i wish we could do
our own wait wait i could twerk up here right there's his
vibes yeah i mean that is that is actually oh my god wait
how did how did he do it yeah oh my god you can only twerk
here oh my that's crazy You can only twerk up here.
Don't worry, Venom's.
Wait, I got cheek up with him.
Cheek by cheek.
Yeah, cheek to cheek.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Oh my god, what the...
I have Coach Kofi.
I can't, Krook.
Oh my god.
Jeff, Jeff, the lead singer.
Luna, the DJ.
I don't know.
i'm telling you starlord the backup dancer and then the
venom the backup backup dancer like we eating goods and that
crooks defen but that's funny what is the funny
this is the most joy you'll see from me today chat is there
a reason why he's everywhere so should we should we leave
day spider-man open that should we leave what funny we can't
even play them actually
exactly but back then you could also play teams that lost my
favorite part of the stream the one the one thing that gives
me the most joy and life so if you like six old and like
let's say there's four teams who are still people playing
who have fuck is still playing cannot play each other so
they have to play like one division below them so that can
that can happen if it's like uneven other than that like
it's like it's only 94 completed oh my i only like 10
minutes late and we are just to face down because like
infinite teams playing this game no like this this game no
my venom like i wonder how long they left me yeah waiting
for every team to finish playing
they left me what's oh my god wait we have our own personal
dancer here wait give me a sec good look oh that's my i
can't have everyone compliment me i think it was in this
yeah so comfy i can only recommend it today
Bill, I can't play in that.
Guys, I'm in my own personal showroom now.
Yeah, I live in the basement right now, so it's very safe.
I don't live there, but I will play here.
This is a good, a good break.
It has sleeves too, right?
Very comfy and cozy.
Yeah, like, uh...
The VIP lounge, exactly.
Oh, really?
My people.
But actually, I'm gonna go get more cop dress.
I'll be right back, guys.
Okay, I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna get the cop jobs real quick and we're wider.
He also wanted that pool.
I'm onto something.
I'm telling you guys that.
I've always been a heavy hitter.
I mean, I don't want to destroy his delusion, but I don't
think they did that well, to be honest, last game.
But I don't think anyone in this team did well, besides
that.
If you really break it down, what happened in that game?
Otherwise, you don't get full health, especially not in this
kind of like competition the enemy isn't fully responsive to
every perfect play you can set up if one guy makes one good
play it's very hard to stop it yeah i mean a lot of people
will drama farm i don't know if that's the case right now
though i think this is a very common misconception on losing
the very first game that you play it's okay yeah i think
they're also similar level those
people are not snake we know
snake is just yearning for the day the venom spider-man
t-lovers coming back he's waiting he's so hungry for that
moment you don't even know
oh my this is a vip vrp out now you know spider-man
that's crazy let's go now i'm in the exclusive exclusive
lounge obviously works i got my own show yeah so but like i
told him that you should be able to oh no he got too excited
he got There were too many ladies.
You got too excited.
Oh shit!
Yeah girl?
What do you want?
For the days.
It is you I knew it.
Shush.
Oh.
What is Tokiba doing?
she's in the club my own personal show let's go um i'm
getting my own exclusive show right now just got called i
wonder how long wait what time is it for you trust me i got
my own exclusive no but think about it i got my own lab
dance anyway i am a professional gamer so i can't have a
good speed cricket I'm not even trying to hide it.
It's not caught in 4K if I ain't even trying to hide.
Wait, wait.
Turn your ass closer to me.
You're not giving Jeff a show.
This is my own personal show.
Turn around.
Tilt it.
Tilt that ass.
Yeah, yeah, that's right.
Tilt it.
Yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Yeah.
Oh.
It's not caught in 4K.
if I'm if I'm never hiding it this game was made for me
there we go I'm also I'm also slouching out my chair just
like invisible women right now sadly the make it rain was a
battle pass and I could I didn't buy the battle pass
unfortunately but this is the second best thing
that clapping sound that's me appreciating the fine arts
i've always been a heavy hitter uh an artist crafted that
ass himself molded with love that twerky moat was animated
by a person with love
that's right
nice i didn't say to stop
all right nice i mean they also leaned me down i i was
asking him before i'll go no that's that's mantis but that's
like way longer ago oh say that again i don't know like i
asked you so oh you also leaned down i wanted to play
full-time spider-man they mmo capped it Maybe for the
dances.
Honestly, I will not be surprised if this was motion
captured.
That's nice animation right there.
I'm here to appreciate...
I love animation.
And I am a appreciator of a nice modeled, animated ass.
I mean, of course.
Then I don't have to play Spider-Man and jump off the map.
I am part of the consumer base of Marvel Rival.
My pool game is pretty good.
My law and my mission game is pretty good.
I am a...
I thought he was like, but he's European.
So I was like, okay, I don't think he...
I don't think he knew what he was trying to say.
I was like, um, trust me.
I am the target audience.
Exactly.
Oh my God, that's so tiny.
Tiny Venom.
Come over here
Now dance
No, you can't He's just short guys
Nice I'm just a boat Now I need a venom in the middle A
little venom in my dream come true dude this is truly
paradise I take it back club dokey was the best thing I've
ever started short king he's just a short king guys he's 5.9
he's only he's 5 foot 9 yeah 5 foot 9 and 6 feet Third
venom!
Third venom!
Stand in the middle.
Get in the middle.
Oh yes!
Yes!
do you know if the next round is soon
i didn't see you just watching all of this yes my own
personal venom shell i just need a poor venom on my back and
then we'll be and then it's perfect
this is some gooner behavior first time
this is beautiful this is truly paradise in heaven now just
think of the unlimited potential and then this one oh john
john get over here a dragon get over here and be at the
backside that's right get here yes yes
unlimited venom
that's right oh my god that's a tanya it's jeff right there
the 360 cheat coverage guys i got my coverage i got
insurance this is my biblical level of greed
get that matches out of here this is a venom only spot you
can't dance near me unless you're venom you cannot dance
near me unless this is venom only that's red venoms only
here this is a venom only spot
that that's red all right yes yes what's the The body's
back!
Let's go!
The body's back!
The OG!
The OG dance crew!
Let's go!
Alright, I don't know.
Nice.
You can't even see me no more.
It's just all... It's just all Venom's ass.
It's just all the cheeks.
So much cake.
This is how Joki charges up for the next match.
Unlimited power
Simple-minded They give a super chat Thank you, thank you Oh
my god, there's more There's more It doesn't stop Oh my god,
it doesn't stop There is more Yes!
High ground!
Shake that!
Yes!
High ground, Fiddle!
All the angles!
Every angle possible!
oh my god look at the hell she's just stuck between all the
fucking venom but she ain't complaining she's not
complaining yes yes
let's go now we just need where photo mode wait i don't know
how that works is that oh oh my god i'm too worried to take
foot i mean i don't really need to take a photo here oh my
god wait there's a ton under toddy venom yes yes
this is truly my paradise oh wait is the first round done
simple manner thank you this is my venom harem who's dancing
over okay that's fine that they're not actually there this
is my paradise just look at my little cult i established my
venom cult my people my people are here all it takes my
people fighting a race car my venom people you gotta be the
change you want to be guys oh my god that's perfect nice
that is good the website loads really slow you gotta be the
change nobody wanted to nobody wanted to start it and i i
started it super tastic i started the venom cult it truly is
i have venom on all angles truly is perfect bro this
tournament delay is too much i will say though this this
tournament could be i don't like that we have to wait for
every team to finish but they have to make it fair though
they do we do have to make it fair so that uh oh my god that
is a glossy ass right there so that like the matchup stuff
is i'm truly a trailblazer i know we have we have venoms of
all shapes and colors, all the shapes and sizes.
We have tiny venom.
We have tinier venom.
We have normal size venom.
We just need big, oh, and we have big venom.
We have giant venom.
We have venom of all shapes and sizes.
Oh my god.
This is truly beautiful.
11 per venom's twerking making me act up this is my venom
harem
you can only dance yo let's go guys for playing energy you
can only dance in this what yeah let's get in lobby
what we gotta lock in on this one guys god we got matched up
with energies oh my god are you fucking kidding me that's oh
my god that's crazy we got we got such bad and our and our
rng that's the super try hard team too are you Are you
kidding me?
I think a wall ban here is guaranteed now.
Oh my god.
That's one of the super stack teams.
That's crazy.
It's a pretty fantastic.
Are you serious?
I need an inventory.
That's crazy.
Right off the bat we get a hard team.
Yeah, bad RNG.
Yeah, it's better having him on Wolf than on Heather, I'm
gonna be honest.
out god damn it i got lucky and i was having a good time
thank you venoms for her thank you to my venom's for
comforting me at least i got this at least thank you venom's
thank you venoms i shall go now oh so i was in the i was in
the club i'm getting out of the club now oh okay parting
before this match yeah no i i had a lot of venom surrounding
me no and i'm relaxed you know i gotta let the stress out
you know i gotta let the stress out the dance so the vibes
are the vibes are up yeah now now i'm super locked in
because i'm not stressed no more there's nothing to stress
about Born to be whimsical, forced to lock in.
Ah!
I don't think we banned Wolf.
If anything, we banned Phoenix to get rid of the Wolf team
up.
All right.
Everyone.
There we go.
That's two bans.
Oh my God.
Really?
Right off the bat, we get the try hard team.
Second, there's 600 teams.
teams there's 600 teams in round two oh my god against the
gator that's crazy or some would call that's crazy rng what
the hell i guess lives in that's insane i mean that's not
really that low 600 teams and you know what i get cook Usaya
seed I legit have no clue let's check oh my god I gotta
check in I almost forgot oh my god out of 600 I know and
like half 300 teams have doesn't show the ceiling the thing
is 300 teams have the one oh and the fact that our second
match is against this team no it's it's Swiss format
that's the price i got too greedy i got too greedy in the
club i got too fucking greedy in the club guys god has
punished me how's this fox guy a lot to play by the way when
he's top on mrc he's just a coach apparently so he's fat
yeah so it's fine as long like coaches are fine but not
substitutes Hmm.
Interesting.
So you just bring the full MRC roster then.
And who's this FE guy?
That's Iron.
He's from Overwatch.
I know him.
Yeah.
He doesn't play this Iron Age.
He's a...
No, that's not Iron Age.
There's a tank player from Overwatch that plays Diva.
That's it.
Mm-hmm.
for who's lower seed i don't know oh it doesn't show
anywhere oh my god i messed up stand my biblical greed comes
for biblical punishment let's see trust the process we are
seed 577 so we're definitely not first seed what is this
team called race car 577 no it's no it's the same seed for
them
see 277 okay let's see the 296 so i guess the highest seed
577 out of 606 teams guys that we're never gonna be the
highest seed
oh the god punished me for all the cake i received
Oh, he really did punish me.
Bro, I'm so happy I have.
Like, later I have best food ever.
Spaghetti, bolognese.
You mean, bolognese?
Do I correct him?
No, I think he meant bolognese.
Yeah, bolognese.
I'm American.
Okay.
I'm American, please.
Bolognese.
oh okay i'm down seven is everyone ready yeah yeah i'm ready
yeah yeah looks good let's look in all right here we go
thanks i do have a right because i got corrected i am
telling me i got I got corrected so that means there's no
way he's yeah yeah I'm pretty sure let's focus on our game
inspirator
oh my like what are these matchups or is my RNG face the
diamond case navi arm sleeve it's time to put it on for this
match you feel comfortable in the arm sleeve what do you
feel comfortable in the arm sleeve yeah very sure it's like
the opposite i always go in all right let's go into bands oh
okay i'm locked in locked in
which hero do you think you want to beat him i forgot what
these guys save i'm bending gambit for sure they're gonna
play angela probably and wolf yeah gator on yeah gator
angela is really good It's kind of handless of Angela.
I think it's possible that we pause too if my mic should not
work at one point.
Okay.
Yeah, so remember to do that as well.
I'm banning, I'm saving Invis because you know what, Angela.
Which heroes will get my cosmic favor today?
Yeah, I think so.
He's the Gators, yeah, he's the Overwatch League guy and
also the coach of Envy.
It's also a good map for Wolf, to be honest too.
So it's like...
or so i can go angela giving mantis yeah you can maybe play
triple if they don't burn it yeah i think they're really
good they're analyzing this is meant to take all supports
with cloak i think we do that and they go raccoon mantis and
they're safe yeah take mantis i think and so i'm banning now
questions mantis and phoenix yeah i think mantis phoenix is
good ban yeah i don't mind playing into loki i think snake
can play into loki quite well i want to play mantis in
mantis in this to be honest for us and that it's good into
loki they have to ban venom most likely we can always go
phoenix i'm just it doesn't work uh bakuna means and ban
phoenix yeah it's just v ban yeah yeah nothing has to do
you're theorizing i think it's i'm gonna do it i don't think
it's that scary we have we have uh venom i think venom is
pretty good into it oh i can always go back and just control
the phoenix yeah yeah if they're studying anyone they're not
studying maybe angela yeah angela bad is not too bad if
they're trying to study someone it's not me guys i'm the
mascot i think diversity higher i would feel it's a name or
ban not hella i think just hella actually hella is maybe
better you're right i i i think a hella ban it's not bad
hella because that guy's you could have also been mech but
it's it leads to the same thing yeah i think mech is not as
scary very calculable with damage save venom is it venom it
looks good no the bucky loki in this yeah but it's our best
uh opportunity i think it's a good creator for they don't
need to analyze me to know how to kill me i'm literally a
headless like he knows when to go out he knows his limits
it's not bad snake is pretty good oh there's tournament only
in tournament mode it's like maybe a band cap okay man we
play in this mantis rock and burn this is not good man i'm
not judging we need to play luna in this oh i'm not the type
who fades quietly into the background are they beyond
questions do i go deadpool or do i go mac we should star
phoenix or star hella i mean phoenix cellar it's a
domination map i kind of want a deadpool i mean you can try
yeah you just have to stay on it then for the upgrades yeah
like first map's gonna be a bit cooked but yeah beyond the
angela map yeah be careful i'll try i don't want me to play
you the more i can actually because i don't know what's up
okay okay they're gonna be diving yeah yeah because like
last map was last round we were split up i actually think
they're gonna go Groot if they do then we need to thank if
they play you need to play uh above them no i didn't say i
have to play rank i was i had too much stuff going on in my
life right now i tried to play i played rank in the morning
last night i think it's not last yesterday and then i had
like work well self-healing besides me hey let's all go high
ground very main in the first fight and then i'll jump back
then with you guys
i can come top in a minute we'll see them yet they're main
angela angela full full full full care yeah yeah we'll go
with bottom i'm shooting him out i mean what you guys are
ready for slam wolf half wolf half no screen no screen i got
you i got your head three two yeah let's go for back then go
and loki i can clap i'm laughing help me help me farm help
me farm help me farm i need to get cool on yeah i'm setting
up top left i'm trying to keep i need another walk i can
they're on bucky they're on They're awful.
I got touched forever, okay, guys.
I got touched forever.
Don't trust anything.
Shoot Angela.
Angela's rolling.
Shoot Sandra.
Oh, I can't pull you.
I can't pull you.
I miss one.
No, he's out.
He's out.
I'm trying to help you over there.
I got you.
I got you guys.
I have Phoenix assault.
I can look for all of you.
We miss with two.
I want a one on Insta that.
You need a touch, I think.
Yeah, one on one.
I got it.
Backline, backline, backline.
Backline, backline.
Backline one.
Nice winnable, winnable, winnable.
He can die.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I bought a terrible, I bought you.
Oh my god, I got boot into this.
I got boot into this out.
Lift, lift, lift, lift, lift.
I can hit after.
I'm dead here.
I'm hitting, ready?
Two, one.
I die.
I'm so, so, so.
Yeah, we need a group.
I think you might have to go, Emma.
Trust.
I really think my hero is really good in this.
It's a really nice matchup.
Really really thank that.
We're going top left again?
Yeah.
What did they use?
They used both invids.
Both invids.
Yeah, I'm coming right.
I have a forever free open.
Yeah, we can push back.
I got push.
Watch out.
Slow, slow, slow.
We're even ready.
Slow, slow.
I already.
Go back.
I got hook.
Go back, go back.
Go back.
Go back, just go back.
Just go back.
42 feet.
I eat.
Angeranos.
It's one, it's one, it's one.
Heel, I'm back.
I'm back, I'm back.
Can you frost point snake?
Yeah, some corners.
Yeah, I'm going to frost high.
2, 1, walking high.
Mac half.
I think I get all that.
She's 1.
I can push up.
Ready?
2, 1.
I'm autoing this.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Adam 1, Adam 1, Adam 1, Adam 1.
I'm actually at the lower.
2, 1.
I can go deep snake in one.
I can go deep.
We can combo.
We have five seconds.
We do it.
I can't.
Stay.
Angela.
I need to get the point.
I can't get you.
I'm the support.
I don't vote.
I need more help earlier.
It's okay though.
Next fight.
We can just go so deep.
Would you like to touch here?
Yeah.
I think so.
I think we walk.
It should be enough time.
Oh wait.
The angel that sees me.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I can walk.
I have a touch.
Can you touch?
Ange is deeply.
One, one, one, one.
Angela, I alter.
i have it angela angela angela angela angela nice angela
there shoot angela angela poe
i'm dead that's fine we need to swap it up i'm nothing no
it's fine believe i'm telling you if i go anything else here
It will not be easier.
You just need to cycle it better.
I really think that.
Matchup is good.
I think the matchup is good.
I think I'm going to go Bucky.
Bucky just farms us really hard.
Yeah, but if I go Emma, he will farm more.
Trust.
Really, really believe that.
I need you to believe that.
I'm going to go Bucky then.
I literally can't go Emma here.
I'll just not make any progress.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm trying to lock in.
Do I go Bucky?
No, he is really good at Angela.
No, no, no.
Venom is fine.
I really think that.
It's just very hard to...
He knows how to dodge shit.
We had good moments.
We just need to pressure a bit more in the neutral.
We need to set up more.
Now we don't.
Now we just play in neutral in the main.
It's fine.
But I do think...
We're never gonna have enough room to back into that.
But why not?
We have insane resources.
We just don't have Ulster vibe then.
Ulster vibe then.
But we have good Ulster vibe.
We have really good combos.
We have Phoenix.
old we have venom old we have my old good old just play it
again break the break the wall i'm taking top right i'm
ready i can drop from behind with your old snake case we can
we can problem all right can we go again three two one one
i'm trying to help you there's a group i can't I missed
that.
I missed that.
Keep pushing.
Yeah.
Looking at Loki.
No lambs.
I pushed someone out.
I'm ready to push.
Miss, miss, miss, miss, miss.
I'm gonna hold point.
Good, good, good, good.
Good, good, good.
No more, no more, no more.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Bucky, Bucky.
Good side right.
Nice one, my one.
She needed some help.
Good points.
Okay, chill now, chill now.
I have ult.
Wait for my ult, guys.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I push off my ult, okay?
Guys, listen, push off my ult here.
Wait, what did you say, Gru?
Just don't use it too early, okay.
They're too deep.
Save it for.
Yeah, I'm waiting.
Just wait, just wait.
I push off my ult here soon, though, ready.
Three.
They're walking up.
No, no, no, no, no, not yet.
Okay, just wait.
Just keep running.
Now you can.
I hit soon.
Three, two, two.
Hello, Gru, Gru.
There we go.
I'm going.
I break them.
I'm halting this.
Go in, go in.
I'm landing in back lane.
I'm gonna die You're gonna miss this point then?
I die, died!
Play it, Hsticks, clayditch, claydig.
You're gonna kill Bucky, Bucky, Bucky!
Bucky, Bucky!
I can't kill Bucky.
Bucky won.
I'm gonna reload, I have to reload!
I E.mittel one, crude one, crude one, crude one, crude one!
I'm dead for it.
Next fight.
I got a little bit of my hooks.
I'm hitting big hooks.
Got a look in our backs.
backline and everyone just focus them on calling it.
I'm gonna die here.
I was just focusing backline.
He was just getting so much healing.
Try to stun them if I hook if you have.
Go behind them, go behind them.
I can walk up soon.
Backline I'm Groot.
Did you slam backline and I just kill Groot here in main?
Wait a slam, wait a slam, wait a slam.
Need to wait, need to wait.
Oh, it's over.
Take one time.
Good one.
Good one, good one.
Good, good, good.
Next one, next one.
They linked, they linked it, they linked it.
Yeah.
Need to group up.
We're gonna go around then.
I'm gonna have to mark Adam on this fight.
Take for our left.
Our left.
Yeah.
can walk up soon i don't need to settle behind you need to
slam from behind you need to go all the way around i got mag
look at it yeah he wall is i'm gonna say all the way around
i'm going all the I'm out, now.
Yeah, I'm looking at him.
I'm looking at him.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Mag, him, madden, madden, mad, mad, mad.
I pulled back.
Yeah, I pull back.
Mag, mag, mag.
Right now.
Loki, Loki, Loki 1.
Woke on the crew.
Walk on the crew.
Kill the crew.
Locke is what is being pris.
No more.
We'll be back.
I let you heal Loki.
Okay, I think he can.
We need a early.
We need early, deep Luna holding thing.
They have no squaddles right now.
They need...
Don't peek them.
Don't shoot them.
Don't shoot them, please.
You can't really do a peek.
Come top, come top.
I'll go.
I need flank from behind.
They can't do anything.
Flank from behind, drop from behind.
We want to backline.
We should play from main, okay.
When they walk up.
Okay, okay.
Don't make sounds.
They go left side and now they main them in.
When are they going?
They're still sitting.
Can we go into them?
Three, two, one.
Laughing.
They walked us up here.
Oh, one, one, one.
No link.
I can go deep.
I can already.
I need to go.
Yeah, we can go.
I couldn't.
I'll push him back then.
You have to do.
No, we don't.
We have to do here.
I have to do here.
Run out.
I ult this.
Lift, lift guys.
Let me touch.
Oh, I didn't.
I'm your Phoenix.
Lift.
Lift up.
I'm shooting from behind.
I'm trying to lift.
They want me off.
But I'm trying to live right now.
No, it's fine.
Back on, back on.
I'm close to the ring.
Live it, live it, live it, live it, live it, live it.
I'm trying to live.
I'm living, I'm living, I'm living.
Can we touch?
I'm one, I'm one, I need care.
I'm trying to.
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on, I'm on.
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on.
I just got it.
It's fine.
Play slow.
I bubble.
i bubble plane bubble plane okay i'm okay i'm okay i'm okay
i'm okay nice i'm just low can you finish like this and we
push up phoenix off i can i can three two one one they soft
they soft i do tp as well i can clap three Group one, group
one, group one.
Group one, group one.
I'm pushing my ult.
Chill, chill, chill, don't die.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
I need care, I need care.
I need help, I need help.
I'm pushing with you.
I'm in this already now.
We only have solo invis here.
Strange one, strange one.
We're dead Luna.
Angela's coming for me, Angela's coming for me.
I'm dead.
Oh.
Yeah, it's fine.
A lot of fights was winnable.
It's fine.
We got a match triple, I think.
I don't think so.
I think we had a decent enough matchup.
Yeah, we could have won that.
That was really close.
Yeah, we could have won.
There was too many mistakes there.
It's okay.
I think this was the matchup where you should go Daredevil,
though.
Don't see how they defended.
I don't think so.
did i think so oh i couldn't see crook i didn't know where
he was i was just playing main i mean i'm telling you if i
go emma there i don't think anything will change i think we
got to start comboing matt or venom and phoenix all that's
just insta wipe every time we're using we're using we're
using venom law on yeah like solo and we can't even like get
trades with the you got you got some good venom laws we
could get picks but why don't i don't know they're the pros
yeah was unlucky the angela saw me and i was like i tried to
like i was gonna die oh the last time yeah i could have
comboed you right the very last one i yeah i had to like
dodge the group walls everywhere like we we get picks and
we're up but we're getting nothing off it after we're up in
fights yeah i mean we gotta develop on backhand better we
had really good flank we need that more from you i go if you
have flake you can't just play in main and afk you need to
take them more often so we get opportunities to hit with the
venom slam if you can only stun from front that's very bad
for us especially if you already have a buggy you have to
develop more on the map sure we gotta start looking for my
hooks more number one i wish i knew where he was i don't
know if i if i positioned ron or not there we gotta start we
gotta start looking at my hooks more like there's like three
different times we're no but like we also have no one that
They have Loki lamb for it.
So the best thing we can get out of it is lamb for sure But
if I have to burn every cooldown for forcing out that that
hook that's kind of kind of hard a lot of the times We're
still in rotation, so you even need to put them way deeper
in the back line or we need to like you need to wait a bit
more I think Like a lot of the times we had no kill
pressure.
We have no one there can one shot them I also think we
should have saved the cocoon in hindsight Because it opens
up the map way better the ult is just more pressure and luna
hold you don't think matching triple is good because when
we're doing triple against tara's team we were doing really
well yeah but we had uh a different kind of triple we had
mantis triple triple without mantis is kind of bad i think
what they're playing is pretty bad yeah this is the one that
there's like all that it was just unlucky that rng was we
got matched against one of the harder teams but it's just
rng was it's over Like, I can't believe there's 300 teams
that are the same rank as us.
They won one game.
And out of 300, there's like five good teams in this
tournament.
There's like four to five good teams in this tournament.
And we match with one of them here.
Like, four to five teams out of 300 teams are really good
teams.
And this was one of them.
It says actually crazy.
Yeah.
That was actually crazy.
RNG, the monkey paw curl.
I just had too good of a time at the club.
I think the match itself is okay.
I don't know if the hell up end is necessary though.
It feels like a very easy carry to dive and punish.
Another, is this, oh no, this is not a convoy.
What is this?
Yeah, this is a convoy.
I used all my love.
on the twerking the other than other than hello you mean
okay could be in this last maybe and this is so close they
saved it my bad then let me think
maybe mac i don't know maybe mac is the next best because
then they can't play cloak they can't play mac gold is a
problem as well the mac bubble is annoying but it wasn't
like this the carry for them so i don't think that either i
think i mean iron does only plays mag so if you want to like
just save raccoon now in the same band theory
crook i think it's mandatory who am i gonna banish from this
match maybe we should even think about saving it first the
next time ben mantis ben phoenix again i think that's good
um in tournament ban um when you're banning a character
you're banning for the enemy team so you're not banning for
yourself so when you ban something you get to play the
character so both teams has to ban gambit so the both teams
can't play gambit yeah if we want i don't mind that now now
we should win same with saving when you're saving a
character you're saving for your own team so because this is
like heavy tournament yeah
ban maybe it's different from rank but i don't know maybe
that crude is kind of yeah i will do mag burn maybe mag but
hella is so good here though yeah or hella i lost right it
has to be hella again i think it's one of it's just too good
on this map yeah i think save raccoon so we at least get to
have the option to play life we can still it's a ban crude
we can still go triple with that should be still be good i
probably should think triple would be good in my opinion
guys but um i do like when we're playing mag though the mag
phoenix combo yeah for sure
phoenix okay that's all right we can play hella no more here
hella no more make that in this rocket oh yeah i just oh
crook i just need to talk someone off then yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're pretty good on deadpool yeah i can try the pool
again i think cap's good for support although too
technically it's a triple support yeah but normally we
should have so much map presence that we shouldn't even be
forced to cycle supporters like if they're jumping enough
damage it should be fine give us jumpax let me jumpax yeah
oh i mean i'll put it here i think our problem is is
sustaining through their support us since they're on triple
30 seconds before you attack get ready you can even go top
right i'm not sure if anyone can i think they play for top
left all of us yeah i think so too just shoot clones unless
they're on triple if they're on triple then you can take top
right on hella do you want me to go left they're gonna go
bucky yeah yeah oh wow yeah they're Triple with buckyin.
Just play normal.
I killed Adam.
You can go top right, dude!
He might have used soft res.
Yeah, he used self res.
Adam has no self res.
Yeah, he's the wrong one just.
ideologically.
Don't throw right in.
Venom, Venom, Venom.
This is good, this is good.
I'm farming.
You want me to go right side?
OCGO.
Took off left, guys.
Go to flabbs.
Okay.
Go to left.
Okay, yeah, yeah, we need to go.
I need so more flanking though, guys.
Yeah, I don't know.
I'm going.
They saw me already, so I just care.
I know it's far right.
Can you go on him?
No, wait a second.
I'm still setting up.
I want to get pulled up.
I mean, one to go.
Venom low cooldowns.
I have my E.
We can walk on my E here.
Walk three, two, one.
E-ing up.
Push or push or pull.
Are we going down for him?
I got you.
Nice.
I am dropping.
I'm dropping.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Venom, Venom.
No problem.
He's with him.
Nice.
Mag watching.
I'm pushing Loki.
No Link.
I got Adam.
I got him.
Mag, Mag.
Mag.
I got him.
Kill the backline, guys.
I need care.
Adam flies the backline.
I'm Alting.
Can you boop this stranger here?
Invis outside.
She can die.
She's not in.
Both of them.
The other Invis is far.
I'm dropping.
You got it.
Push in the...
Adam!
Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam!
I'll take it, okay.
I do not have anything.
This is real fireball.
Venom is gonna burn.
Oh, I'm dead.
Venom below.
Venom one, Venom one, Venom one.
They have no lands.
Push him back, man.
Loki one.
I don't care.
I'm trying to destroy your doors.
Venom one, top right.
Look top right.
Look at Venom.
He's literally one.
Now Adam, now Adam is at risk.
Look Venom, look Venom!
He has no E!
I don't know about what's in this!
Venom!
I can't get for him.
Need to lift, need to regroup, need to regroup.
They're on 3-3.
Yeah, yeah.
You need to group up.
Need to go next fight.
I'm old again.
I'm pushing Adam, okay?
You need to have a neutral fight and we push Adam.
Wait it, wait it, wait it, wait it.
I'm back soon.
You're welcome.
I'm still waiting.
Why would I need healing?
Go inside right, go on a strange old.
They're gonna have that in prison.
Someone's on top right.
We can walk with an old tier on the back line.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go left, go left.
Okay, we go left.
Okay, trust me, you're solo.
Yeah, I know, I know.
I go behind them.
I mean, oh, strange is marking me.
Oh, I'm one, I'm one.
Oh, nobody is here.
I'm dead.
I'm dead here.
I can't.
There's no hot clap.
Oh, we're down.
Yeah, we're down.
We need to group.
We're going to reset.
Don't go in now.
We actually...
Oh, I couldn't.
Yeah.
Oh, we die.
I couldn't live through that.
I don't want, but I'm just saying.
Go full Riku.
Full lift.
Just wait and group up.
Luke, please stand for it, right?
Just go on the rocks.
Yeah, just wait.
I'm waiting for it.
On the rocks and the rest of us go main.
They literally have nothing to sustain the engagement.
Yeah, you can't show earlier.
I should go backline.
They're marking me.
We're going right?
Yeah, yeah.
We're still walking.
Wait, wait, wait.
Strange is top right.
Watch for all.
Strange was top right.
I'll tell you.
Any help here?
I got you.
I got him.
One, two, one.
Might be.
Open up.
Come on.
They should be okay though.
Help Rocky.
Look, trust me.
Yeah, strange one.
Strange one.
Adam dies.
Walk, walk, walk.
I'm touching, I'm touching, don't worry, don't worry, I'm
touching.
I have my own in this one, in this one.
Live, live, live, live it, live it, live it, live it.
We almost have rocket wood.
Get your rocket wood out of the top left here.
I stack with you guys.
I got a guy.
Go use, go.
Yeah.
I push back line.
I do not have bubble.
You have to touch, you have to touch.
No, I touch, I touch.
I'm not.
Rock up, walk inside, walk inside.
I want to end this way.
Okay, okay, I'm here.
I need care, I need care on top.
Yeah, we got hit.
Strange, strange.
It's fine.
It's a big one.
Yeah.
Break it up, please.
I'm...
Okay.
You need to push back then.
Have your love.
Two, one.
Run up, run up.
I'm pushing from behind.
You have to touch.
I need to touch.
Take his touching.
I need care top.
I got you.
I'm dead.
On the top.
I have Rez.
Venom on our backline.
He could die though.
I'm dead.
that I need.
I got you.
I have TP.
I can block the heals after.
Yeah, I need to live.
Wonderful.
Winnable.
I do not bubble.
I'm trying to die.
I need help.
One point.
I'm going to die.
I'm going to block.
Oh.
No.
We need to play good heroes that can push backline because
we need to have some development on the map that walks into
the backline.
They have no one to deny it.
need to walk you think Emma's better here than Magneto I
don't know it's just difficult I think like I think we have
no target calling here yeah go triple tank triple support
bunker I think you should have played Luna crook and you
should have flanked with me to open the map or at least give
me flake so I can do more on the backline before dying i
think i'm doing my job i i mean i've said that go triple
support triple tank i go i don't know i feel like i was
doing my job thanks go you got luck oh okay dokey go cloak
okay yeah or mantis raccoon cloak mantis that's fine cloak
mantis i don't i don't know i think so go go go go root
though go root duck go root Watch out for a penny mine.
Yeah, he's got a penny mine.
It's here.
I'll break them.
I'll go to the right side.
I think this was, yeah.
What we have right now is fine.
We just need a bunker under.
They're going to take above us.
I can contest it though.
Can you keep me damage boosted, Crook?
I farm E.
We need to be very careful against Venomult.
Don't miss your dome.
Always use the defensive.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't want him dead.
Starlords gonna spin from behind.
I'm gonna mark him.
Keep me.
Keep me up.
There you go.
I hear it.
Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom,
Venom.
Help dark, help dark for you.
Hey, res, res, res.
He's res, he's res.
Star load on me.
ULTRA, back LAN.
We can walk.
Adam can die, Adam can die.
Oh, I'm going to body blocking tock you.
Grino, just body blocking you.
He should be by him.
I need care, I need care.
I need to fight.
We can win, we can win, we can win.
We have ult here.
I'm a ult.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
I'm ulting.
Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna.
Luna, Luna, Luna.
They're gonna have Venom off.
I'm blinded, I'm blinded, I'm blinded.
I don't have mine yet, I don't mind.
I have res, I have res.
I'm losing, I almost have it.
Shoot him, shoot him, shoot him, kill him.
Kill the cellar.
Venom one, Venom one, turn it low.
Live, live, live, come back, come back, come back.
They still have Adam res, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, they do.
Starload is on top.
You need to live there in this world.
Venom going in.
We shoot the Venom down the street.
Shoot the Venom at the start.
Live, live, live, live.
We need only a kind of ult here.
Oh god.
I've faded, I've faded.
They're dead.
Maybe even a blue.
I have to be black.
I brutal.
I TP.
That's one, enough time.
That's okay.
yeah we burned too many oils in the fight before it's kind
of sad it's okay though maybe Invis would have been better
group but I think it was fine it's fine I think it was
another if we go any characters that can dive inside the
room or we take behind them there's no way they can stop it
if you had given me flake I could have done that but I
couldn't do it I think it could have faded earlier I
definitely could have faded earlier they should never kill
you do it so fast i think we had a decent enough matchup
okay maybe rng wise rng wise maybe we have to not save in
this first all easiest teams now all them first i think
we're getting better though all the easy teams now for sure
i think this is a good team this was super winnable just
need to play against this team we're 50 50 on them i just
think like they definitely better chemistry for sure yeah
guys we were just sandbagging guys i don't know if crook
likes me i don't think he likes me which is understandable i
am the weakest player i'm sorry i feel bad
i feel bad
No, this is the actual tournament.
All right, we know how to be happy, the one place.
No, he's just European.
No, he said that, he was saying that to, trust me, he was
saying that Crook, he should have played something else.
But then everybody is like, everybody is like...
I think he could have played Dead Evil 2, honestly.
There's a good matchup for it again.
Doug does not by the way inside story Doug does not want to
play daredevil I guess every time we play daredevil we got
absolute shit on so Doug is like very insistent that we
should not be playing daredevil wait is this a private room
wait what is there also no disadvantage out of losing early
it was a good team we faced early on so we're gonna face
easier wait oh they opened the subway can face day and
imperator if they're not out of the tournament for the Oh,
shit, wait, this is new.
I didn't know that.
Oh, that's cool.
Subway's open now.
Oh, that's how you know.
Oh, it's through the subway to get to the...
To get to the disco.
Oh my god, there's so many people dancing there.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
I could have played that better, even.
I feel like...
Or at least we kept...
Yeah, but that's our...
We can only have one loss.
So we have to win every game here now.
Yeah.
That's the risky part.
Because we already...
We already lost our...
Trust me, or not really.
I think they were good.
I mean, I don't think they were that good.
They were super beatable.
will come we just need to take around them more efficiently
like that's too much too early you try to one shot them from
500 meter range without any hit from us you expose yourself
therefore they know where you're shooting from so cooper is
repositioning because he's not stupid this is already top
left marking me before like i mean then it should be value
for us to walk up but no you definitely shot from 500 meter
range and just expose yourself early so a hit hits less hard
it's just normal it's just how it works and then we have
timing yeah trust me you need to take it you know there's no
downside of taking it but yeah no this is a much more
serious situation where on namer we stopped developing and
just kept shooting from them and we tried to turn water into
water from them into a triple tank which just doesn't work
they have free pockets behind them so we need to take behind
them it's the only way to make a winner
if no dance shoes i want to dance with legit 9 hp in the
middle of point like no one shooting him where are my venom
oh the last map that's it i'll start the venom party he was
non-hp for so long i was like screaming i'll start my dance
party wait no don't worry after a venom when one venom joins
more venom will show up but i don't know this isn't yeah
this is open to everybody i also haven't done like a super
competitive tournament a long ass time so i was like i'm
gonna give it a shot i'm gonna give it a shot because it's
like it's like open it's like overwatch open dude and i was
like i want to you know what i want to try that again good
team there was minimal against them Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Maybe he should have stayed.
Venom in the first match.
He's coming over.
Hello, my fellow Venom.
Hello.
Venom combo for to kill through.
You know, oh yeah.
Eye to eye.
Yeah, it was the same thing on the first round, by the way.
I'll go.
The role play.
You just need to be smarter around taking behind them.
Yeah.
I told you all it takes is one pet venom to start the pie I
noticed I did way more when I was like behind them or like
yeah the bogey ones definitely more relaxed this one is like
super tri-up because it's open to everybody so like the only
restriction is that it's two pros only so you can just
literally stack your team up with top 500 players and I feel
really bad because I asked them if I could join their team
and I feel like I am the weakest link and like I am trying
my best though but they could have got a better player.
So I do feel bad.
I feel a little bad.
And so I hope that, you know, you're not too mad at me.
Serious Tournament proceeds to twerk.
I don't know.
This is my way of relaxing.
Bring you hard on yourself.
It's just that...
Uh...
I saw some of the comments that the viewers were saying
about me and I got really sad.
I was like, I'm sorry.
But it was during scrims.
It was during scrims.
So I was just like, I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm trying not to...
get it to me that's why i'm trying my best i know i'm like
making some because like i don't know if i'm ulting
correctly though i'm like second guessing myself as well but
i asked them to micromanage me for ults because i'm worried
that i'm not ulting correctly in like a tournament
environment um so like i hope i'm doing better
yeah but i'm i'm i'm learning support with crude i think i'm
learning a lot i'm learning a lot though i think the madness
was very good i mean i'm i'm learning from uh yeah i think
we have madness there i get so many like there i'm not even
kidding there's so many instances where like people are one
hp like one more to get damage and it just changes the whole
fight every single time Yeah.
I think it was triple.
We're not making the bad work.
I don't think so.
I think the dive has been working against Terra's team,
against a lot of teams.
When we play triple against Terra, I think we did really
good.
Yeah, I'm also fine playing triple when we have Mantis.
I don't want to play triple without Mantis though, to be
honest.
On the city.
yeah and also like i'm also like not not very familiar with
tournament dive when i first play tournament dive with them
i was getting absolutely on because like um i had no idea
how to how i've never played because like no one does
tournament dive in rank so i was so I look like NA players
also don't know how to do any players don't play dive as
well Any players do not play dive at all.
It's all it's like a European cop games finish and And what
Yeah, it's scheduled at 4 30 and what time is it?
It's 4 30 pressure imperators game like is still going.
Oh my god.
All right guys.
Let's play a ranked game
they haven't even played a game yet i'm gonna play a game
we're just gonna take a while that is stupid that is dumb
this is a little organized just a little poorly to the point
where we have to there's so many teams to the point where
the in-between isn't lying yeah i queue a few games so i
might as well yeah i'll play some wink I never I'm trying to
like I'm here.
I know I know I just can't be a negative negative negative
person, but I'm learning now.
I'm trying my best At least at least I'm trying my best
Yeah, that's why like the European players are hard pushing
dive Uh, wait Yo, are hard pushing dive because to them they
play dive a lot, but and they it's so difficult
What's up?
oh message i don't i feel bad i don't want to talk like
because they're all like silent
oh no who's who's doing the loud sigh oh it's doug he's not
happy
oh chan's seeing the super chat thank you thank you i wish i
was good as you thank you thank you thank you thank you
Can you always tell me like, how many games do you think I
can do?
Maybe two ranked games.
Oh, he's not here.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
Oh, this is my ranked team off the bat.
This is my ranked team.
After the next game, if you want, I can run with you the
game as well to show what I mean.
Maybe that would also help.
oh i got whisper what did i get only if you want of course
we should just oh that's aggro yeah yeah that would help
after the next game after the next game take a break take a
break take a breather before the next game and then after
that game we can focus on the on the what we can get a
better head foot all right bounce out of it
Yeah, but every time we try to do D, like, Daredevil in
Scrims, we get absolutely shit on.
And Doug was like, please, I do not want to play Dini.
Because Dini is, I guess, Rocket.
Oh, I'll practice Rocket more, I guess.
Or Cloak?
I'll practice Cloak more.
I do not play Cloak way often for this new season.
All right, but if they have Mag, I'll swap.
They'll most likely have Mag, right?
It's GM.
I feel like there's not a lot.
Oh, I don't know.
I'll swap off when...
If they have Mag.
No, I'm not...
I'm not on Jeff, where...
Most likely.
Oh, fuck it.
I feel like I should play Clube just to get my practice in.
I feel like Rocket, I don't need as much practice in.
But I know I'm, like, too slow on my shifts.
Fight daggers and your soul sword.
We can handle anything they throw our way.
Our foes would be wise not to underestimate us.
Get in here, y'all.
I'm definitely way too slow reacting for my chips.
They're on Spider-Man.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
Oh, that's gonna be me.
I'm gonna get pulled.
he's looking for it we need people on card there he has
spider-man's on card what oh I don't see a mag oh I see a
mag look at me oh what the fuck there I blinded him oh he's
blinded I'm a little scared because they do have a spider
spuder man right now okay well good luck I'm trying my best
All right, I got this off at least Yes, yeah
There's the guy right here trust me
All right No, he's like bitch you plan temporarily Hello,
hello Okay.
Yo, yo, yo.
You want a queue?
Yeah, I'm in three minute queue already.
Bro, I'm not re-queuing.
Seriously.
If there's only like 20 minutes between the games, I want to
play.
But after the game, after the game, after the game.
I'll go.
Okay, let's hope.
Oh, I tried.
I need to catch up to Spark Chief.
You know how it is.
There's too many games.
There we go.
Now he did.
There you go.
I mean, he gets on the Z2 leaderboard website, you get
the...
points for how many games you played oh oh okay that's my
bad
where the was my hook oh my my bad
oopsie it was not blind i are we fighting this oh my god
these guys we just lose because no one tp
Oh, I forgot to swap.
I was going to swap off.
No, I got hit by the mag thingy.
We also don't have like a Hishgan.
We double ulted.
How did we double ulted?
Ooh, double.
Our cloak ulted at like before mine ended so that we can
save life.
Oh.
you know how this the battle is over yeah i really think
yeah i think we can get goaded we're getting like way better
w noted yeah all right w comms
yesterday is history tomorrow is a mystery oh here we go
that's why it's called presence no these are all walls yeah
we have nothing to shoot the walls that's also an issue oh
my god if he fucking lives this
all right guys come to my little spear oh they have grid up
though
there's no loser breakers no i guess there's seven I thought
it's a Swiss all the way.
I'm going to lose your bracket and the next stage.
I'm sorry, buddy.
Right?
I don't know.
It was like stages, yeah.
The people with the most points qualified.
I mean, losing against good teams gives you more points, I'm
pretty sure, at any sort of stage.
I didn't.
get all wins now now we don't have support oh I missed it I
missed my blind I did something I did something guys okay
we're gonna stay this is a little scary Oh yeah, no, we're
fucking dead.
Yeah, no, we wasted a lot.
We have no others.
Yeah, no, that was bad.
Oh, what the fuck?
Come on.
I'm over here.
I already used my dome.
Guys, please someone.
Oh wait, I can play this now.
No.
Oh, why did he go...
No!
Yeah, please.
It's slippery.
Alright, I'll go in this.
I don't know.
Our team is like, our comp is so weird, but it is ranked
though.
Yeah.
Alright.
I'll put the mag closer.
I don't know if that's bad.
I leave because I know spider Spooner Man has all and I'm
worried.
I'm scared Get away from me Oh, there we go now.
We just slowly move forward
Oh my god, we're please please please no
My shield was God My shield was gone It's clear I'm still
needed here I fucking knew I knew that the thing is if I put
my I didn't alt my alt there because the mag was alting too
So that's why I got scared Are you fucking please please are
you fucking kidding me?
He alting me out of my own alt How did that?
Oh my god why
He ulted me out of my fucking ult.
That's crazy.
I even pushed him too.
There's nothing I could do.
All right, he just doesn't want to win.
Like we could have TP'd both times.
What is he talking about?
Okay but it's not up to one guy to TP like anybody can.
can tp guys like it's not a one man's job to tp guys i don't
know if they know that and also watch this the the
starlight's gonna be like gonna up soon and then oh my god
oh my oh art luna our poor luna he did not deserve that i i
can't do anything i'm literally I have shield.
That's all I can do.
Oh, um, we are waiting for the next matchup right now.
Tournament's not over yet.
It's not over.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god.
There's nothing!
Nothing can protect me!
I had to do...
Oh my...
We had no shield, nothing.
All right.
Wait, apparently Day's team fought someone with the top 16
coach.
And that's the drama.
But didn't we fight someone with the top 16 coach as well?
I mean, we fought not even top 16, he was signed on envy.
Is it that against the rules, guy?
I don't know.
It's not against the rules.
As long as your coaches are fine.
I mean, I'm sorry to disappoint you.
It was also quite shit.
But it's okay.
It's not against the rules, though.
Coaches are fine.
Oh, okay, okay.
I'm good friends with K there.
Just saying.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Not that anyone takes his two suitors.
Okay, okay.
That's what the day's drama is about.
Or the Imperator team.
drama I guess I don't know I mean yeah of course Imperator
is gonna farm the drug the current score is zero bad coaches
don't get I see a zero time to switch things up including
which side you're on so what do you think we changed like
you play triple instead instead of I think I think triple
like against really good teams I think triple is like really
good because we played really well against Terra's team with
triple and Terra's teams like one of the better teams you
know what i mean all right kirk said i should practice we
still lost but we still did the best but like i don't need
either it is it is a situation against i will do it i don't
want to get sarah's energy right i was like i would if i
want to win i play loki but if i want to play i play loki or
invis but kirk wants me to practice so no i don't think we
won a map for sarah at all yeah i don't think we won against
sarah but we did we did win against energy and i don't think
we played dive in that either let me see what's up i just
never yeah we did no it's not it is right now only because
um only because um cloak is not meta but apparently she is
in tournament it's crazy Because rank meta is different from
tournament meta.
Because no one fucking plays Cloak if they have a mag.
So it's very hard.
It's very hard to get practice on Cloak.
Just because she's not meta in rank meta.
But she's meta in tournament.
Which is...
Like right now I'm wasting this.
Because I'm used to...
They still haven't played a game by the way.
Yeah I think they're...
Java farming.
No, thank you.
That is so stupid.
So we wait like another out, like 40 minutes for them.
I'm gonna go fast with my own.
Yeah, they should just start their game.
Oh my god.
Are they at a different pool than us?
Because if so, we don't have to wait for them.
We're gonna go fast later and walk him back.
Walk him back.
Otherwise, they're gonna get blue in the pool when I hit.
I'll be back.
Oh my god.
Well, at least I'm mad at you, never.
You know, that's a good part.
Whoa, oh, goodbye, everybody.
You guys are so dead.
Oh, they're running triple support.
I can never avoid that.
Like, what are we waiting for?
I'm so confused.
Oh, someone is mad right now.
like right now i'm i'm technically wasting my i'm wasting my
um my util resources with how i'm playing the dome because
i'm supposed to use it more defensively but i'm not using it
very
defensively and then i should lie more i think i yeah i
blinded people oh shit Oh.
Oh.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I need a time.
It's so hard to time that.
Because if you do it too...
I feel like I do it too early.
I do it too early every time.
I need to be more patient.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, that's pretty funny.
I'm gonna grab this guy out of the way.
No clones allowed.
There you go.
I'm gonna save my life defensively.
I'll do double.
Like right now, I guess this would...
Alright, there we go.
Oh, I hope he lives.
I guess not.
I did say I hope he lives.
I did.
It was unlucky that he did not live.
But, look, unfortunately, what I want might not be it.
I mean, I can't DPS this.
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry, buddy.
I'm sorry I was...
That's fine.
Oh shit, that low key was so low.
I think I blinded somebody in there.
Can I...
Actually...
What the fucking miss?
Oh yeah.
Jesus Christ, fuck this.
No longer fuck this.
Please, please.
Oh my god.
Am I?
No longer.
Oh god, we're dead.
You're dead.
Yeah, that's strange.
Clutched it.
Can you swap, bro?
Like you're actually doing nothing.
Don't you put all eyes over here?
Wait, who is he saying?
to swap.
Oh, I'm fist.
That's unlucky.
I didn't even want to be over there, too.
Oh, my God.
Fiercely typing right now.
I don't know if you hear Trust Me and just typing his heart
out.
Motherfucking blind.
Dying!
Oh, my God, it worked.
It actually worked.
He's in for the vibe.
He is.
He definitely is vibing.
oh is he oh wait oh he's playing bro he's like he's so
locked in he's definitely incredibly locked in right now
trust me
bro he is locked the in right now all right the clicky
clacky
all right I might Maybe I don't want death in case I miss
Might as well just end of the day Whoa I got you defensively
See I'm learning I know that That He wants to up Right now
He really wants to up
Oh god Oh god No Why is it only I was trying to float over i
was trying to float over i'm coming back
it's fine it's fine you're fine you're so healthy there you
go sure there you go
Come on.
I blinded him.
That's the best blind I've ever done.
Oh, never mind.
No longer the best blind of my life.
No longer.
Maybe I can get out of here?
Can I?
Yay!
I cannot, I cannot, I cannot.
Oh my god.
I was gonna say maybe I can get out and I'm like I don't
know anymore.
Oh my god, please hit.
Yes Defensively defensively right here
I'm trying to I'm trying to I'm trying to no, I try I
literally was I was left clicking so hard Okay, that can't
be blamed on me.
I literally never stopped.
I literally never stopped left clicking.
That's fun.
It was just, you know.
I don't know.
I left clicked.
How much more can I left click for you?
Okay, storage, yo.
Yay, not me.
Yeah, not me.
hippie
not not toky though
yeah no i did a lot of heals there 57 that's what i'm saying
i was like what more can i do i heal so much
there was oh yeah i should actually i keep forgetting to
avoid people usually Yeah, I don't avoid people.
I mean, I do avoid people, but...
Wait, no, we had two melee characters.
Like...
Yeah, I don't know if this white wasn't it either.
Like, I don't mind if we had two...
If we had a melee character, we just have two melee
characters.
Yeah, I didn't throw.
That's the good part.
I tried my heart out.
That's all that matters.
Oh, people are deafening.
I should deafen then.
Sorry.
You had the little ASMR, the try-hard ASMR from my teammates
when they were playing Rink.
Oh, next game is going to be a while.
Because apparently one team is not even fucking starting
their game because they're complaining about how they played
against the coach.
to play so um I don't they're just drama farming right now
apparently um
which hero do you think you want to be today they're drama
farming this tournament at the moment so they're refusing to
play the game because um because they don't want to play
against the top 16 coach subs aren't yeah subs aren't
allowed but coaches can play because the reasoning is that
coaches aren't actually playing in the game they're not
screaming or like they're not actually playing oh my god
like i
it's just people
are just farming drama now after the kingsman stuff just
understand what happened you have hard bullied by his team
but now everyone is like you're seeing that as like i can
use this to engagement bait now so like everyone is like
every tournament is now getting drama farmed
because they're like oh they worked for kingsman it's gonna
work for me too but like the kingsman situation was like its
own little bubble type deal it was like
the coattails it's like its own little um unique thing that
happened like a once in a light time not once but like you
know it's like its own little event that you can't really
like replicate
it's like when like you just tweet any mention about
kingsman and then and then it's like you will get like
thousands of likes comments and like reaction comments too
But like now, yeah, it was organic, but now everybody is
priming drama for like, like, like any tournament now.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
Oh my god.
I'm spoja.
Poja.
i really oh my god this poor jeff
all right goodbye i have to bro what is my team comp though
like seriously like actually what the fuck am i like holy
shit well i don't even know if i'm getting a second stream
today with like We have like we still have two more games to
play.
I thought
I have two more games to play guys
Oh, oh, oh, oh, go run away from my dome.
Okay, I made this dome for you.
I Actually made that dome for our daredevil and he just he
actually ran away from it
I'm sad
Oh shit, that's very unlucky.
That shit.
Not fuck it.
There we go.
Yeah!
Yo!
Oh, if we had to...
Oh, guys.
We should have had...
We should have two people pushing it.
Here we go again!
Alright.
We still have Jeff up.
I bumped into like a player that animated, um, that like
animated, uh, icons for all their support.
And I was like, Jesus, fuck, but he was like, she was like,
she or he was like the same rank as me.
so i'm just like thinking like do you did you like i don't
know did you like farm all of that in like fucking like like
and quickly because like how though that's like that's like
crazy in general like she had it i think she had it on like
four like four to five supports i'm like oh my god
Lord farm?
What is Lord farming?
I always see that.
Apparently, there's like, people do, like, there's, like,
illegal Lord farming rings.
I don't know what that is.
Like, what the fuck you can...
Because, like, it's so illegal that the devs actually made a
statement about it and was like, yeah, we're gonna shut that
down because you're not supposed to actually do that.
I'm like, what the fuck?
People are doing illegal Lord farming?
Like, what?
What does that even mean?
I'm so confused.
Like, how do you illegal lord fight?
The best part about playing cloak is that I don't have to
actually focus.
Watch this, the namer's gonna fucking ult me.
Oh, nope.
Okay, that's fine.
I'm not fine with that.
What the fuck?
Does nobody die?
Like, okay, I assume that...
Like, he's just standing there.
He's actually an NPC.
Right here.
There is no way we're...
We're fucking sending this shit.
There is no way we're letting this...
There is no way we're letting this NPC win.
That's actually NPC behavior, what I just saw.
Holy shit.
All right, bro, what the fuck is this E though?
I don't play Rink for a while and this is the shit I see.
Bro, that, I'm sorry.
That Namer is actually an NPC.
I feel like I'm seeing the whole universe.
Just in this web.
Uh, I want to let...
I personally just wanted to cap the point.
but
me blonde now oh I mean hey at least the neighbor didn't
keep it all for me that's fine oh hey save me like what am I
bro that guy bro that that's actually oh my god bro like
that neighbor's literally just standing there it's crazy
That's actually insane What I'm looking at right now
There you go, he's blinded You can't see You can't see no
more But you see that we heal each other As long as we heal
each other We should be fine
There we go Bro, this guy is actually as fuck I will oh my
god hello there's no way I was a lot I am there
you have to kill this guy at least please oh my I don't care
we just push up I don't care
here now we got the point like what oh my god like what bro
okay okay bro bro okay okay okay like no fucking way am i
watching this angel like like they're literally even five
and six but they have an angel from a stall no okay the fact
that we let oh my god We should not let this this name or
should not even be playing the fucking game at this point
Like legally speaking He definitely should not be playing
this game
There we go, I don't care
All right
Bro, this Elo, this Elo is so interesting.
This Elo is so interesting.
Yeah, the Neymar, not gonna- no, he is right though.
He's- Oh, wait, I should have avoided the magic as well.
Why the fuck did I only avoid the Iron Fist?
I just realized I still have- I have the same fucking magic
on my team.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Oh, we're all playing ranked because we have to...
We're just waiting.
It's like the tournament hasn't started yet.
I mean, it started, but we're waiting for the next game.
I don't know, honestly.
I don't know if the other team's still doing their shit.
Yeah, like, our thing hasn't, like, come up yet on, like,
who we're firsting next.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Nah.
Not in the Elo that we're in.
We can't play in the same.
We can't stack.
In fact, we're closer than ever.
It's actually a bit more complicated than that.
Bum bum bum bum.
two one i think if i play i honestly think if i play um
other another invas or anything this would be more winnable
oh my god that's my bad i can miss that and my blind is here
what the fuck like kill him Kill this guy, bro.
Kill this.
Fuck it.
There we go.
Okay, my team tag.
I'm playing quick play.
This is quick play, honestly.
This is fucking quick play shit right now.
I feel like I am playing quick play.
there you go like i'm not playing a real game honestly
this does not feel like a real fucking game
i don't even know if i'm getting good practice
Well, I wanted to play the zombie game.
Like, I don't know if we're making good progress right now.
Get out of here, man.
Probably double support, that'll do it.
I'm lucky.
Yeah.
Jesus.
Fucking crap.
that's crazy the amount of damage I just fucking encountered
oh I I wanted to shift out and that's unlucky I couldn't
shift out in time I was fine my team won
I didn't react I don't know I feel like there's a delay
whenever I do the shifting with cloak
oh there he's doing that thing is he coming to us he's
coming to us isn't he because you see you see
maybe i should heal sorry that was my bad
i couldn't feel them
how can we get like teams like this
I should love you yeah bro I feel like I'm playing quickly
this is the most quick play coded game I've ever played yet
this is somehow rank like this is the most quick play coded
game I've ever played like what the fuck is going on you're
Oh, no.
Like, what is happening?
Like, actually, what the fuck is going on?
Namework, come on.
I'm avoiding the namework.
Like, what the fuck was that namework?
Oh, my God, there's not enough of it.
already avoiding or supports and oh thank god she she's
avoiding me thank fucking god yeah no saves me a slot like
i'm like what the fuck did i do fucking that's great because
i was gonna avoid you i was like man who do i avoid thank
god nice save the slot Lucky.
All right, bet.
Yeah, it takes for the free avoid.
I actually needed that.
Oh, wait.
Oh, man.
I got to lead time square so I can queue up a rinkerooney
game.
are they... Is it...
Oh, my God.
Let me check.
Let me check if we can play a game yet.
I swear to God.
I'm refreshing.
What round are we at?
The third round has not started.
What percentage is it?
Alright, event.
Like, what percent?
Oh my god.
What percentage are they at for round two?
Can you even check?
Oh, it's 99%.
Oh, wait, it's 99%.
I should stop you.
Alright, 99%.
Alright, I'm unmuted.
deafening everyone else has undefined bro he gets you gotta
get the youtube video matches played is 32 on the website
what a bullshit was dumb the website's down 32 percent what
i can't believe we got i don't even know why i can't believe
we played energy steam second round it's low-key crazy
there's like 600 teams yeah what do you mean they'll told me
I didn't think that many teams would sign up to this.
Is it this more than the MRC and NA?
It's probably because of last season.
Oh, hey.
Hawkeye's coming on January 26th.
All right.
That's cool.
I feel like it's a lot more.
Here we'll share an in-depth look at Haigard full game.
Oh, hey, look.
Haigard released.
Oh, it's in two days.
Oh, no, I meant the amount of teams participating.
Wait, what?
Oh, yeah, of course.
Yeah, yeah.
I feel like it's a lot more for this.
Okay, launch showcase.
Even like the lower teams, they get top 60.
okay two days guys we're finally gonna get in-depth look
it's actually a lot so it's like worth to participate in
some sense true and we get nothing we only get money i'm
gonna use i'm gonna nervous pee again or what do you mean
bro if we place like top six we get like 500 bucks each oh
no i man in MRC but oh oh never mind I mean in the of course
it's a lot of money but like I'm saying for the more 500
bucks not that super insane for professionals I see yeah
it's a lot of games it's also not that fun you know because
the thing is like in MRC with like a full protein you just
stomp through the games like there's until the top eight
there's no interesting game for someone like us so it's like
yeah four weeks or three weeks of not interesting games and
just like such a heavy time in list for no progress in
competition right because we always want to play to get
better right so it's like yeah it's why we always scream
only good teams too right this is like not ego or anything
but it's just like pointless to scream we get teams you know
because you don't get anything out of it as hard as it
sounds so it's like kind of the same case have to play like
three weeks of stomping teams they can't do anything about
it either like they just want to have fun and then they face
like us we just troll and go whatever we want and still win
because we're just like individually so much better which
makes sense you know it's like normal i'm like when are so
sure not fun for the enemy teams too when do we play it's
not good for the vibes but that's why when we play mrc teams
are banned from ignite i'm okay you can't play mrc at the
same time only yeah every time that server is no so mrc's
kind of like tier two almost yeah during ignited tier two
i'm not sure i i would that came out of your soul i just i
thought i was like i haven't even lunch yet either uh so if
you qualify to learn because they're like the last game
would start at kind of like that i'm too gullible otherwise
you can have like like let's see how many regions are there
like i'm way too gullible i saw like oh it's fine um to be
called tier one i think i was like oh the schedule says that
the tournament ends at at 3 30 p.m
how's that oh that seems that's cool it was just 3 30.
i can make that work
every time she fell for it again i should order food i'm
order food right now i don't know she fell for it again i
don't always fall for it
I have fell for it again, a horde.
I'm gonna risk it.
I'm gonna play a fucking game.
I'm gonna...
I'm looking for food right now.
Alright.
I'm doing it.
I'm gonna fucking do it.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it!
I did it.
Sorry, I ordered food.
I ordered something.
Alright.
One of the others are you have to move the other stream to a
different game.
I just, I wanted to play the zombie game.
I really wanted to play the zombie game.
No!
Please, can I play cloak?
I need to practice it.
We're at the J3 tournament right now.
Please, I'm on my knees.
I'm on my knees.
Yeah.
I'm too desperate.
I have no shame anymore.
There's no more shame here.
Shame is gone.
All you.
Oh, the other team's playing Cloak as well.
Yeah!
Well, rivals players are actually nice for once it's
like it's like a rare it's like a rare event thank you
it's like the one percent when a when a rival's player
doesn't slur at you the one the one percent when it happens
it's a rare moment in life When the Ravals player does not
slur.
We have Zaza 2.2.
I
said thank you!
He didn't get DP.
He's just here for the vibes.
practice the tournament tournament is more important yeah
he's getting dp that's crazy right live
that's insane oh wait someone already left someone already
rage quit
oh he's playing scarlet that's already like uh oh wait never
mind oh okay We picked Oh my god, you are a whore
Don't worry, I got you.
I saved you defensively
I mean, they're not throwing or they're playing the game
Doesn't look like they're throwing me the guy I mean the guy
didn't pick for a while so maybe that's what it was but
it's fine you're all fine you're so healthy
what the is that oh that's the that's the dead school i was
like what is that sound
oh um it's okay oh what the fuck okay he fucking doubled us
in me that's on him that's on him that's on him That's on
him.
I don't know why Adobo supported that.
Yeah, I was like, why?
I was like, okay, even though there was a Groot Wall in
front of me, I could have, I was gonna walk beside the Groot
Wall.
Yeah, no, that Groot knows how to Groot for sure.
Bro, okay, here.
Fucking have a dome, I guess.
like just have the dome i guess
what the fuck is going on in my team like where is my team
in general too to be fair i don't think my team is okay in
general like i'm i'm trying to heal i'm trying to heal like
so oh my God he is not happy he is not happy in general like
what is my team doing and if only he everybody is so
separated this is war
yeah he turned his mic on just to just decide that means
being happy hey guys there's a thing here oh yeah oh watch
this we'll grab it that oh well i i didn't know that there
was all right they cannot look how the fuck was i there was
like 20 people still alive you cannot blame me into thinking
like oh literally when i elton like four people were alive
he's like we didn't need it okay how the fuck was i supposed
to know we didn't need it when i saw four people alive i'm
getting over here
all right all right here i live in this bubble now i guess i
live in this bubble this is bubble that's my life let's
shoot me at this yep
oh my god you actually jumped through it break him guys
break him get rockies on group there he's landed
There we go.
We did it.
Alright, here we go.
My vibes persevered.
We're doing it.
The power of vibes.
I just vibe here and then try later.
That's how it goes.
Vibe here, try later.
Wee.
The rules of comp.
I need to get better at blinds.
For real.
At least like thank god nobody's playing mag on the enemy
team.
That's also why I don't like playing cloak.
It's just because like the enemy team will always have a mag
in rank because every fucking tank in the goddamn world
plays mag.
Well, like, apparently in tournament, no one fucking plays
mag, apparently, because everyone just plays dive.
That's crazy.
Get in that circle.
Get in my circle!
What the fuck?
Invis, I made... Oh my... I made the circle for you.
Holy shit.
I literally made...
that circle for him too that's crazy and he fucking ran away
from the circle
yeah i made i gave you the dome please respond oh no okay
yeah all the games should be done oh this is bad i'm still
here that's all right it's fine i'm almost done anyway i
don't see our match though i
hit it i hit those all right bro everybody is so fucking
there i'm fucking i'm playing geometry right now i'm
literally hitting it against walls and everything oh not for
him though oh not for this guy though oh not for him too
we're good we just worked here oh yeah no she's fucking good
yeah like no i'm not living that how the am i still alive
okay there you
Control lost!
Alright.
Come on, please.
I have to go to round three.
Oh, yeah, please.
I didn't... No!
It's not... I will still be playing...
I'll still be waiting for, like, 20 more years.
No res beacon, by the way.
Alright, here we go.
I mean, that's cool.
Oh, that's cool, I guess.
Do we like just, we just don't like fucking...
We just don't...
Wait, Kirk, do you have a lobby?
He's not here.
Alright, I'm out of here.
Alright.
Aha.
Alright, how about...
I might have found something that cooked my internet.
Maybe.
Oh, bye spotty man.
I'm just gonna let my invis you.
But I don't need to be here.
What?
Where did my invis go?
I was like, I swear to God.
Okay, goodbye.
You're so dead.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
I can't wait to lay down.
I'm actually so tired.
I can imagine what time is for you, trust me.
Okay, there's nothing I could do there.
You fucking fucked me up.
That guy fucked me up.
Really got a couple more hours.
Just two more games, right?
This is the last game.
This game has been Roman.
Yeah, it's your game.
Yes.
And then another four tomorrow.
And then...
I think it's... I don't know how many on Sunday, I'm not
sure.
I'll try that.
Maybe not.
Just the internet.
yeah i want to help him but yeah only two more games today
you're a stupid idiot thank god bro i'm waiting 30 minutes
for a game i can't get it emperators the emperator stall bro
okay i would like i'm about to start an end bro okay okay
buddies you want to raise snakers you can be angry and
cursed I haven't played Outer Ring in like a while.
This is not good.
I tried keeping it in me.
For the second time.
But I had a lot of health for the run, so...
I see, I see.
I still need to play the DLC.
Oh really?
I played like some of it.
I didn't beat it.
I need to beat it.
They're down one, by the way.
You'll have to keep fighting until we have a winner.
Bro,
I did double.
Oh my god, there's nothing I could do.
I was literally 4%.
No, please!
Oh my god, get me out!
I need to get to the other game!
Light doesn't dispel darkness.
It helps me see the darkness and face it
It tied?
That's crazy 30 seconds before you attack get ready
We thought you were gone after the vampire oh my god I don't
care if we win or lose honestly
Oh, it's just best to us three basically Basically, I'm not
best for three, it's just like win lot, you know.
Alright.
I'm just waiting for Lobby.
Just so you know guys.
Okay, waiting for Lobby.
Okay, that's fine.
What has Victor gotten us into this time?
Yeah, invite me.
Oh wait.
Oh my god, I'm on the wrong account.
I can't.
Okay, here you go.
This guy is not smart.
I need to change most, but I think I'll play with the...
Like, I need us to, like, bro, fuck this.
Oh my god, I thought I was gonna fall.
There we go.
Oh, that's embarrassing.
Guys, I don't think we're winning this now.
Oh, wait, unless...
Unless...
Just use every ult possible.
Never mind, it is still winnable.
You should have asked for both.
The big one and the small one.
Those finals tastes strange.
You gotta be greedy bro.
I almost fell off.
Yeah, I need one too.
I almost fell off the fuck's a cliff.
Maybe we should design our own, we should make a venom rose
pet.
$1 venom rose pet.
That'd be pretty cool.
It can be $1 though.
It needs to be 100.
The official snake is over here.
This is fine.
Say it in the- Say it in the- Oh my god, oh my god, that's-
I'm-
Oh, I watched this.
The moon!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Guys, guys, port, port.
Nice, get- get it.
Other teams are gonna drop out.
Because like it's so late.
Rocket legit one.
Okay.
We don't want to claim anymore.
No, probably not.
Never mind.
All right.
No more.
We still need to claim the price for MRC, by the way.
There's no lobby yet.
We're waiting on them.
There's a lower seat again.
I want to know, is Crook depressed?
Did they attack you back?
They're like, is he okay?
Are you in contact with him?
No, not yet.
He sounds very sad.
He's not answering on Discord.
Oh my god, he sounds very, very depressed.
You can only answer.
So I'm just, you know, it's just an honest question.
Like, is he okay?
5G.
That's fine.
That's huge.
I'm just tired because of the long waits.
This stage is so exhausting.
There we go.
Chavez.
He's just European.
Is he European or depressed?
He's like, is he gay or European?
But he's just like, is he depressed or European?
The better.
Same.
It could be both.
They are born in the pressure.
They're just born with it.
Yeah, they gave... let me practice cloak.
Yippee.
Are we against the diamond team, by the way?
oh nice why did everyone someone's on console so I just saw
the discord group damn
depression is just pre-installed what which European country
is he from is it common
Hungary and Austria oh that's like the double combo
it's hungary in austria that's a wild combo lame day for us
two pro teams gg for them that's a bummer it's just how it
goes sometimes i guess it's how it goes unfortunately but
the same for us apparently yeah kind of wants to similar
thoughts no that's crazy that we play energies team out of
600 teams in the second round the team that we stripped as i
said we'd lose nothing from it so just focus on next it's
good yeah the only thing that can happen we face terror but
i don't think they would happen we have to place top either
then we can win thank we can win any game we could have won
against him too i think it was very close we could have won
like i can show you how we can win like if you if you want
like after this as i said so there's waiting time in between
yeah there's 600 teams yeah something to gain out of it you
know wait they're actually tweeting now the high guard
twitter is actually tweeting now oh my god wait i just
realized they started tweeting i thought they were like
three days in three days you can play high guard yeah
thinking about bands they literally tweeted again in an hour
oh my god guys hey who's playing i won't be like guys who's
playing high guard next to me
Yeah, I'm here.
Redding up.
Wait, what is a couple though?
Ago, are you here?
Yeah, I'm in Valorant Deathmatch.
You could just start whenever.
I'll leave.
That's Ashley crazy.
Go, who's hopping on high guard?
What are you waiting?
Is it high or low?
Oops.
Oh, no.
Can you help me play after?
I need to get high rank.
Okay, Loki wanted to take a nap after this match, but you
can play.
What?
There's one more?
I think so.
Is there not?
In between?
On stream?
No, no.
Not on stream.
Okay.
I'm not napping on stream.
You're taking a nap at midnight.
Bro, it's late.
Yeah, I don't know.
I'm just so bored from waiting.
I'm so bored.
I believe you do, bro.
Drink a...
Drink an energy drink.
Well, we can't say the name of whatever one.
You don't understand Krook, Snake Case.
Krook is the kind of guy that wakes up in the morning,
30-minute meditation session, you know.
He listens to how to get mushy, mushy and something, like
protein all day.
Only eats chicken and rice, nothing else.
Like the Kiga chat meme in itself, kind of.
Like, actually, and then he wakes up at 6 a.m.
That's him.
I see, I see.
that oh my food i'm so he's an actual giga chad i was gonna
go back guys yeah he is he is i've seen it he has muscles
it's true more than me but it's okay you know i have the
brain it's a complication yeah the steam plays dive by the
way i'm pretty sure i think the steam played against terra's
team right i think the diamond no i think surely i just
banned standard things should we just go widow for the vibe
i mean no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no we can
do is we can practice our dive or we can practice our triple
tank yeah we can build it like this triple tank really i
think we practice i don't want to give up on the dive i
don't want to i don't want to I'll show you after.
I'll show you after.
Like Deadpool Venom Dive?
I don't know about Venom Cap though.
I like- Let it go!
I like Dive with a frontline tank.
And then one dive tank.
Let it go.
Bro, bro, he's forcing dive.
I have to like nine- Like- All of us can't trust me please.
We can't- yeah we just spent lucky we were to try four dive
triple triple triple triple we're gonna play triple mantis
mantis in this they've been bucky as well wait mantis in his
what i'm not the type mantis in this triple with loki no
wolf i think wolf no or name or solo whatever yeah name was
fine wolf is also fine I think wolf is better to be honest
for punish options Like i i ironically think in this case
crook.
It's better if i go What's called deadpool?
I'm fine playing this too Gotta gotta hit some Groot shit
Good jump back playing triple Yeah, of course I am happy to
see you too Can I go have Angela, they're gonna have Wolf,
most likely.
I think we go high on first fight.
Yeah, stop from high.
Against Angela, Doki Bird, you need to lock in.
You need to try to keep your shift and keep your pull.
So when the Angela's above us, just shift inside of us, kind
of, so we don't get grabbed.
Cancel this.
Got it?
It's very hard for him to move there.
Come top, come top.
Go top, go top.
DP careful.
Yeah, maybe.
Very likely actually.
These guys look like they want to chase.
Not DP.
They're triple DPS, BP Moon Knights.
Play the hype.
Wait a second.
We can walk forward soon.
Yeah, take all the map.
There's a roof.
There's a roof here.
Roof here.
I pulled him back.
Roof.
You're passive.
Rock forward.
Just walk forward.
I got you.
I'm one.
I'm dying.
Look on the left, look on the left on me.
No fade.
I'm floating back.
There's a BP on me.
Try to keep me damage boosted at all times, by the way.
I do a lot of damage then.
Yeah, I'm trying.
Just wait right now.
Build slowly to our point.
Guys, look at the wolf, okay, a lot.
It's our primary focus to look at the wolf.
Doki can look at the wolf and I can look at the wolf if it's
necessary.
Enemy wolf.
Guys, rock forward on the mag.
I pulled him back, I pulled Groot back.
We kill him, we kill him, we kill him.
Good pull.
Nice pull.
Play Lamps.
Yeah, we can keep walking.
I can ult this if- I double damage we should do.
I think just back.
I pulled him!
I pulled him.
Just wait, just wait.
Come back.
Play pointed.
It's fine to play slow and play pointed.
Yeah, go back, go back, go back.
We should play out our advantage.
We're going to have Cloak ult.
When they're Cloak ult, we need to kite it, I think.
try to we can kill it snake case we can damage boost snake
case for killing cloacold okay when they're cloacold two
points i could grab them here yeah just wait just chill just
to roll
it's okay i still want to play the win i'm gonna copy man
okay we can switch it off that one went out of it yeah
I'm on the butt.
I almost have my wall.
I'm trying to get you.
Can you lift?
Yeah, I will.
I can back.
I have my ult.
I pulled you.
I pulled your back.
Get ready.
Three, two, one.
It's thick.
Very big.
Wait, wait, wait.
What are you doing, bro?
I swear you what?
What happened?
He hit the wall.
I have one.
No, no, no.
No.
I don't know where that went.
I go Angela now.
I think I take them off the map here.
Yeah.
They only have two tanks.
You can give me damage boosts.
Yeah.
Wait, wait, wait.
I pushed the Hawkeye with you.
Yeah, I'm walking.
Let's see.
Yeah, I can go.
Ready?
Three, two.
I pulled him back.
Hold on.
I'm trying to give you a damage boost.
I pushed the moon net.
Pretty close.
Ready?
You want to push it with my altar or no?
Push your people points.
No, they're going to cloak wounds.
Okay.
I'll match them.
Can you left team?
oh big i think we tried life treated like a practice i think
we tried it like a practice i think as hard as it sounds
it's definitely gonna work i mean otherwise we have to wait
five years again but it's fine i mean we can also these
practice your soldiers
I mean, it's sad.
Super unlucky.
I mean, they're going to play they're going to end up
playing these teams anyways.
So it's like.
Yeah, it's super unlucky because normally they just wanted
to play a bit, you know, so it's like early these kind of
games are like annoying.
Thanks for the offer.
I mean, it's a fun tournament.
Like this is more of a fun tournament than a 40k tournament.
As hard as it sounds.
Less money on the mine is still money on the line,
We need the money, though.
I want the money.
We lock in.
Yeah, we do need the money.
Yeah.
Yeah, sir.
Play dice.
Yeah, Doki needs the money.
Doki needs it.
Yeah.
I'm going all the way left.
That's crazy.
They have Hulk.
On Hawk, they have Hulk.
Yeah.
I can push Hulk.
I could go in Moon Knight right now in Hawkeye.
Yeah, I can push Hulk.
here on i have pings right here oh they saw me two one
contesting backline you can walk oh i got in this yeah oh
play more to like i think a lot of the times you play to
full commit don't full commit always like you should always
prioritize living over dying like always i i could have
deflected it it's wonderful guys there's no clock look one
nice can you touch Yeah, wait, wait, wait.
Hooking, how's doing it?
Oh.
They're Venom behind us.
Sorry, you made this happen.
Oh, triple tank?
Venom.
Wait, what are you talking about?
No, they're like double.
Yeah, I kind of made the wrong call.
I have like an issue with that, honestly.
I have that a lot.
Oh, we're still on Moon Knight.
Okay, you all first or no?
Nah, I can first.
Oh.
Can I ult right here?
Or actually, I'll wait.
Okay, ready?
Three, two, one, I'm multi.
Got one.
They have Cloak, no fade.
I'm shooting Cloak.
I'm on Groot.
Groot, Groot, Groot.
I can't take the selfie.
I got it, I got it.
Oh, I did it.
He chased, he chased, he chased.
He's all the way on the left.
Right there.
He's one, he's one on the high.
Kill him, kill him, kill him quick.
He's primal rage.
He dies, he dies, he dies.
I can't kill him.
It's fine, it's fine.
Lift him.
I hit after, I hit after.
Can I get you?
You damage me before I go.
I'm going, I'm going.
I'm with you, I'm with you, trust me.
They're gonna cloak up, they're gonna cloak up.
Oh, I have fucking shit.
Ooh, he's one.
Wait, that team up is OP.
Holy shit.
They're not cocoa.
I think they had it earlier.
Just raid.
Coming up.
Just raid, just raid.
Come back.
Okay.
And then the spawn.
Yeah, I mean, you can push them.
Yeah, I'm pushing.
I never miss.
Clear the way.
I pulled somebody back.
Oh, good.
Oh, Doug is dead.
I'm with you.
You damage, Bruce.
He's trying to.
He's trying to cap.
Hulk's going to see nine, guys.
I pulled him back, but yet isn't.
Bro, DD is so OP.
What the fuck?
Yeah, they see you.
They just won.
They see you, Crook.
Can we kill Drew?
Do you have wood?
No, that's okay.
Three, two, one.
Oh, is it?
Focus on the view.
Oh shit, okay.
I can shoot him with you.
Duh.
Yeah, nice.
Invis?
I'm shooting Invis.
Wow, DD on me.
I'm on cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak.
On bottom right.
Can I see one?
I killed him though.
A chain.
One could go.
Good game.
Didn't have a leg yet.
Maybe it helped.
I didn't have a leg yet.
I changed, I prioritized my PC.
Maybe that would help with the rest.
I didn't try that yet.
I'm eating my chicken nuggets while I'm playing quick there.
Maybe it was an issue because I had the telephones
prioritized for some reason.
No.
It's really quick play right now.
Oh, you got them DD.
So, daredevil.
Hmm.
Bro.
don't get i was reading your chat and someone said how many
hours for the next game oh yeah get around some ads get
around some ads now stack it up yeah i'll bring it back but
you can start it the schedule was alive yeah i mean it is
what it is how many hours till the next game they said i
think it was just a round yeah yeah i think it's they didn't
add the nests if it's ggs then it's over ah yeah that's what
i'm liking i can't wait to lay down trust me spy on us i
just wish this tournament wasn't like so early yeah from the
hey guys if we play more game that would mean we if we play
one more game it would mean that we have played more games
in less time than the last tournament look at like that's a
win for me in the nami chat crook that is so disrespectful
he always comes up with the least people that could do that
no it's obviously it's obviously a troll but bro it he knows
it hits I don't think it's oh my god bro I swear to God how
apparently they Jeff didn't even get paid for the high guard
advertisement he's like he's like high guards number one fan
yeah sorry yes yes yes yes yes yeah just really I would it
would be so sad if the game fails After all the pushing.
See, this is the problem.
Someone said, go Spider-Man.
Honestly, not a bad idea.
It's not the map for...
Maybe it is the map for it.
I've been playing Spider-Man here.
I actually know a rollout.
Can I try it?
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Honestly, they're diamond players, so I think you can.
One of them's on controller.
Yeah, but don't let that disruptor.
The controller players, they are OP.
Yeah, I will be the name is actually open a diamond
controller console You don't know aim assist is a game hacks
they have hex Yeah, built to respect them.
Yeah Let's jump over their head they can't aim that they
can't aim that fast
I'm gonna play BP all right I play I've practiced clear Who
am I going to banish from this match?
Snake is a bench ult.
GG.
Yeah, we lost.
No, we lost.
Nothing to play anymore.
They paid for it, but not the ad.
I was on Jeff.
I'm not looking forward to it when it wasn't on my radar
before.
Definitely.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, they did pay for the ad.
Oh, not where the placement is.
But, like, even after he's been, like, talking about it.
about it hey why was there no vans because there's a creator
tournament it was a creator tournament a lot of one tricks
were invited to it so they didn't want people to get their
one tricks bad there's like no prize pool whenever they
invited people like me included the 40k was a surprise yeah
i forgot the scrim was against you right yeah i was in that
faded what did you place i didn't watch it uh tied for third
uh time yeah how does that well third and fourth get the
same money it was a single yeah third and fourth were the
same i see anyone doing boker bash i was gonna say how did
that work anyone get invited to boker bash too no i signed
up for it but you're invited trust me uh i mess okay uh this
is funny okay basically i messaged boker today right on the
toilet i messaged him and he said he said i i am i in
bogabash or nah and he said you are in you are i haven't
went through the list but i will invite you for sure good
vibes and i said w vibes so i think we and gluca are in uh i
think all of navi are in no the captains are content
creators because booger was like asking me if i want to be a
captain i was like no i see because i didn't really want to
do the cc i was scared of the cc drama so because i just
didn't want accountability for stuff so But he was like, no,
all the content creators are captains this time.
So it's like Flats is captain.
And what was it?
He gave me two people.
It was like Flats and someone else.
And he's like, so it'll be chill.
And he said like, he's going to assign two pros to like each
content creator.
And then the pros will draft the rest.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
So it is more pro-oriented.
So like each content creator gets two pros.
So it's like, yeah.
I think that's more balanced.
Yeah, I think that's...
So like, I'm technically a captain on the Bouguer Bash too.
Did you use the last turn yet as an example?
Yeah, yeah.
But I didn't play the last Bouguer Bash.
I was not invited in the Christmas Clash, I think.
No good.
That's...
No, the Christmas Clash was not...
It was like not the best.
It was really scuff.
It's on Thor.
I believe in your Spider-Man, trust me.
Oh,
I can hit him.
I can put someone in us.
Let's wait.
Get ready.
Can we kill Invis?
I blinded the two things.
What about magic?
Magic wanted.
I killed one.
But okay.
I really pushed by the door.
I got you.
Stay in the sphere.
Just wait, just wait, just wait.
I blinded the tank.
I blinded Thor.
Nice blind.
Second two.
I still have the lag right there.
I had it like earlier.
It's not good.
There's a magic.
Are you rubber banding?
No, like every 10 minutes I have like a DC.
That's not good.
Like one second DC.
Here you might.
Does it affect your stream at all?
I mean, it affects everything.
It affects my stream, my game.
But it like, the stream doesn't crash, but it's like...
Yeah, I know.
Like it's annoying.
Just chill, just chill.
4-1, 4-1.
Walk up, hold it.
I want triple now.
I want to hold it, I want to.
Okay, I can.
Need to hop in, need to hop in.
I'm cutting, I'm cutting.
I'm blinded.
Can we force in this?
I could all.
I can E again.
Two, one, one.
Let me try to shoot.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky behind, Bucky behind.
One.
Bucky behind.
I'm offering this.
Well, I think we win.
I think I'll die.
Mac on point, Mac on point.
Okay, can we push into them with Cloak ult here?
Yeah.
I think this is very good play early on.
You can heal.
They have nothing to respond.
They only have Invisal then we can kill through.
Yeah, I'm top left right now.
Call you.
Call you blind, okay, Doki?
I have my bubble for you.
You want me to do now?
We're going in right now.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
We can go.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
He said ready, so I thought that was it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, no, no, no.
Can you invest, invest, invest, invest.
I blinded them.
I blinded Thor again.
Yeah, click blind.
He has two blinds?
They have W blunts.
There's Adam on points instead, I think.
Stretch him on points.
Okay.
Or he's dead.
I need to know you.
Picture, picture, picture.
Where are you?
i think we're all ready i think i think someone was on okay
i'm gonna remember next time you do a countdown i just went
okay i'll do it i'll do it clear comes so much for a maximum
effort wait this guy dies nice i'm pushing the one hill that
picture times three two one oh they're trying to get in the
picture yeah they did they actually did i'm gonna i'm gonna
push uh i'm ready whatever you're fine oh you're going out
yeah i'm pushing on
i'm chill today like our penis moxie right now on hawkeye i
need some it's melt
i'll call them a dokey they're coming through yeah i'm with
you crook i'm gonna send a random sphere over maybe i'll get
to you guys I'm low.
I need kill.
I have cloak all right.
They should technically.
Okay.
I got cancelled it.
I'm gonna help this.
Fuck it.
At least they'll get an easier team after this.
Yeah, they get an easier team.
That's the Swiss system.
At least they can play which things up including which side
you're on you'll need a top-notch team to win this one we
are cloak and dagger we are hope and fear we're
gonna do the poll yeah i i am i need to do it i practiced it
as i said my pool game is good my the neutral game is the
problem i think especially on ping like the pool game is not
the problem very good at it yeah no yeah they're diamond
players literally like i said it was so crazy we got like
our second match was like one of the best teams in the
tournament that's how unlucky it was that we got that like
there's this system is like you can have like teams that
have the luckiest rng or like like they get freebie match
essentially so they'll play against all the bronze players
or some shit and then our team on the second match we played
a lot of people that do the one from here the five best
teams in this tournament on the second match like that's how
unlucky it was for us the fact that that was our second game
you need to look double up so you need to put it below
instead of like like we lost we lost the gotcha we actually
lost the gotcha oh did you get one no our team is not like
the super strongest there's like uh compared because like
for no reason he did it he's trying to live my thing there's
like the pro teams are all na so like for us uh trust me and
crook are are on pain so like obviously that for the vibes
so like we have a disadvantage for that too yeah my neutral
game is so bad i i went in there in the instant i Yeah,
Terra Steam is the strongest like Terra is like all It's
like all NA This guy's DPS eat I mean Invis DPS is not that
But we lost our we lost our one We lost our wood lost though
for that Because to be in the finals You have to have a 7-1
record I've seen Yeah, this is like a rage made Invis Oh
shit Oh no This hawk's half Oh shit, oh shit This fucking
stranger is just walking into us This guy is legit Nika, on
the left, on the left On the left
There is a random stranger Yeah, I'm on, where are you?
Okay I have like a stranger in front of me too No, he came
for me Come on, Duck.
No, I died.
There's no way.
Need to TP back.
We lost.
We actually don't have TP.
We almost have, I want to surrender.
I will bubble you.
I will tear after.
Are we out of here?
We can win.
I can take him off the map.
Oh, we die.
We die.
I take the hook off the map.
I take the hook.
I'm out on this.
We got a touch.
We almost have close.
I got it.
I just got it.
Luna one, Luna one.
In this one, in this one.
It wins the one.
I'm getting kidnapped by the fire.
Change low.
Oh my god, I got grabbed.
Women, women, women.
I got grabbed.
Tokyo just got bullied.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Like, I don't even think I could dodge that.
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man.
Oh, they used everything.
I got touched.
Do we have TP?
No, we don't have TP.
No, we don't.
Yeah, I'm swapping.
I just can't do anything.
Oh wait.
Did you get it?
It's over.
And he's question marking too.
Oh, you got question marked by a diamond player.
It's actually just my bad.
It's fine.
That's fine.
Okay, bro.
It's a creator tournament.
Not really.
It's a J3 tournament.
Oh, yeah.
It is a tournament by a creator that's different.
I'm blinded.
Daredevil?
J3X Marvel Rivals.
Hashtag ignite the battle.
Yeah, Hulk up top left.
Oh my god.
Full calf, full calf one.
Doctor Strange.
I like how I like how Kirk is there just AFK.
You know, he's not taking anyone seriously.
Yeah, we have one more game.
He's not taking this game seriously.
I don't know if I put an AO.
Saturday today?
No, it's only three days.
Oh my god.
Is it actually going to be three?
Yeah, it's only three rows.
Like today?
No, no.
It's four, it's four, it's four, it's four.
They changed the rows, they changed it.
Yeah, yeah, it's four.
It's four.
Because there's too many teams standing up.
Good back then.
Luna, Luna outside of it.
Get Luna.
Where'd she go?
is okay oh my god there's no way i lived through this
understood oh god i'm up in this winnable shooting that's
strange i actually thought this was the last round that is
sad uh no we we have to wait two more hours for round four
no no no did you not sleep though i slept like maybe you
like four hours oh i'm lying to him nice the guy's looking
like me on daredevil oh i'm sorry my multi-backlock trust me
right yeah
okay after this i want to watch the energy game if you guys
are down yeah you can show it on stream as well I'll make
sure that I don't leak any discord messages I mean it's not
like I have any crazy ones just don't don't don't show the
picture trust me files don't there is a Hulk right there
yeah wait was that guy a baby Hulk yeah he was I saw his
like yeah he was in this in this dice in this dice i can
shield up in two one wait i'll get it off
come on look picture picture picture picture go go go
always it's a selfie yeah but he turns weirdly around
there's a dredge over there's a dredge over Oh, he got it.
Oh, hell nah.
I have a free arm.
Whoops.
I thought Biggin would have stopped in my bed.
He can.
Next fight.
Yeah.
Sneakies, maybe you can snipe.
Go around.
That's it.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
They just wait us, wait us, wait us.
Don't push without me.
We can just cloak on a point.
They can't defend it.
They have nothing yet.
to nothing all right let's go now catch rangel catch rangel
catch the tp someone wait let me let me know i'm tp
yeah no they're already they're already tp they're already
tp i'm canceling i'm controlling the strange died last so we
can tp yep nice oh Yeah.
No, we finished this game too fast now.
Yeah.
This one is.
Oh, we beat them too fast.
We beat them too fast.
Is that B.M.
Mental attitude.
No, no, this is not B.A.
No, no, I actually mean that's positive.
They were not happy about it.
Yeah.
Oh.
that is just unlucky for them like going against tara and
going against us all right vod review time i'm not gonna
pull up his vod review because i don't trust myself in not
leaking anything so i'm just gonna we'll see how this half
goes jerky crook jerky sent me a picture of him being 76 win
rate on daredevil in celestial free w jerky He's Spidey only
though.
Spidey only.
Damn.
I mean, he's hit by the Spider-Man than me now.
He can play it.
I can't play it.
Alright.
Hey guys, no, I'm too young though.
I'm too young.
One second.
Alright, here we go.
There we go.
Let's watch.
Look in.
Alright.
I don't know how to...
I can only provide 720p.
Only.
I'm sorry.
No Nitro.
It's unlucky.
All right, well leave us on Club Doki while you listen to
education.
Mod Review Education.
What's that on the right of your screen?
All right, here we go.
That is a tool, a painting tool, for showing what I mean.
We're 2-1 right now.
Girls, what the fuck?
We have to disclose rotation.
We have to take this rotation.
We always start it.
You know?
That's what we start.
We always start the party.
What do you want about, I think, all of the Jala, I want to
quickly go over the attack.
The attack, so many situations, they are giving the map
space, but we need to take it.
Very important, and this is something that I need us to
understand.
Let me know if you guys are ready for it too.
I don't know how Doki, if Doki won't.
Don't have to stream, you can also play ranked Doki.
No, I'm watching.
If you think it's not good content for you.
you need to do this or whatever then you don't need to you
don't need to but professor e professor no we're in class
right now right regardless of if we are in class or not um
their matchup itself they heavily rely on two things they're
venom to clear angles with the mag and they are able to play
set angle right generally speaking if we all go top and we
all force main the opportunity will be created we have two
resources that are great for us we have Pierce healing with
Raccoon and Pierce healing with Invis both of the healings
we receive from them have aoe effect which means we get
double the value if we stack around the resources you know
if we split around the resources and we play angles right
now there's no real value in that so we right now and play
in maine we should be able to take away their resources in
maine by winning the trades in maine so that's why it's okay
to stack and go top all together right now once we walk out
very important is to put pressure on this yeah what's up can
we look at my penny mine kill later yeah i mean i saw it
it's it's earlier here thank you it's good he just he just
idled Wait, where did they land?
I want to see you again?
They landed like the first.
You could have seen it, but but he just like I think he just
AF played in the brain.
Now besides the point, right?
The point is still the same.
We had a good position.
We forced off the high ground.
They can't really hold it.
And then the question is how we take after.
Right?
Because now this is a position where the fight should
theoretically be unloosable.
They have no squids.
They have no protection.
All we need to do is Snakehase needs to walk there.
main.
A lot of the time, Snakehaves, you're very hesitant on
taking space.
Usually when we have Invis and Rocket, it's very hard for
them to put counter pressure on our backline, so it's okay
to walk into space once certain areas are cleared.
Like the Venom is cleared in the sense of him having no E
cooldown, so it's very hard for him to engage right now, and
we also clear this area.
So he can counter slam you, so you can't really lose
cooldowns in main.
I already want to go since I see my name or hit, but you're
lacking behind.
So this costs us two seconds of pressure and once more we're
in this situation where we have too many people that are
inactive in a sense of not doing enough pressure here it's a
similar thing with duck look at the position you take your
position is really bad because the only thing it does for us
is it forces either dokeybird or crook to look to the side
which we don't want right we want to use the aoe healing to
push down this line and by pushing down the line the
objective is that you can take Because then once we both
take the high ground, they can never take it back, which
puts immense pressure on the killbox over here, which we
need to have.
Eventually, we need to make sure, and this is whatever we
play, whenever we play, wherever we play, even if the enemy
plays inside the room, we need to have some kind of idea to
develop our entire team to this position or to develop the
damage from our team to this position to create
opportunities to wipe the fight.
So what do you want to play it?
on what resources we have right now.
Right now, there's no reason for you to play over here, and
it would be way more reason to play in main and just play
where Krook is on top, because you can't be contested.
There's no reason to not do it, because by playing it on off
angle, if you take damage, you would force the resources
away from us, which would prevent me and Snake Case to keep
closing the distance there, which ultimately leads to us
having more space on the map, which we want, right?
I'm learning.
So this end up happening, you end up being low, Krook has to
turn for you, so you like once more look at what happened
now they can take the map space back which the result of
that is the people that are hitting right now are going to
be isolated because none of us are putting pressure in this
area anymore so they can put their attention to clearing
this guy so our hit is going to be gone so it takes us
longer to once more set a new hit right and this is all
happening on the screen it happens it's okay you know we
still get a pick because the hit was really good the hit is
smart very good played by Argo here what happened afterwards
is illegal right because we this is a position where you
should never lose from right but you see what i mean right
because you keep fighting the venom in a position where we
don't have feelings to line up and snake is going for like
everyone shooting this guy we can never develop and clear
the fight quickly which we want right because obviously if
you stack with us here and everyone just walks down this
path they can't stop it even if the venom is there yeah we
can still kill him later, right?
And we forced point, he has to touch.
So now we kill him, but now we had zero development on the
map.
It's still fine.
Now we need to push main again, right?
It's okay to go bird on top here now, right?
They have nothing to stop it.
They have no people that can just fly up.
So it's okay to bird on top and for Krook to jump top too
and to create an opportunity where we can kill.
Unfortunately, we're not ready to do that, you know?
It's okay.
We have a decent enough hit, but you're not developing the
back line you're shooting the tanks right now which is not
the primarily win condition yeah i mean that you kill adam
would happen anyway look at what we have on the map there's
zero chance that we should lose here if you think about it
you know it right you you're a good player if you go top
here you have infinite opportunities you can get in the
shielded we get way more map control and the tp back is
going to be in a position where we have all angles to
control them with right additionally to that i don't like to
play high ground guys at the bare minimum you need to hit
the right people okay to be fair to be fair he's talking
about that or everybody but me right now and then when you
start talking about we all start crying position you need to
put them somewhere where they can hit them like over here
because you know where they're not judging me yet so the
people that are not bad they will pass inside repair myself
natural cover so when they have inside natural cover you
need to put them in a in a way that we can prevent them from
going into natural cover or you can pinch you gotta learn
not to cry
these are the two options that you can take right
it happens you know we clear the lamps unfortunately i have
to waste my entire ear to clean them and now this is the
position look at what happens here they have two people that
i contested there is zero chance if you don't drop here in
the backline that we kill these backlines look how long it
takes to kill the backline no one is shooting the backline
and this happened kind of every fight regardless of what
comp we're playing if we have phoenix there is a point in
the game where i need development on the backline duck
you're still in the same position shooting mate which isn't
too terrible because once more now you at least line up with
the of the players, but it's still not optimal.
The problem now arises, now that we don't have multiple
angles, they can just TP out for free, because our angle
game is gone.
Sad people in the back here are not dying, because we don't
play into them, right?
We need to drop here, SnakeHist needs to walk on them, which
definitely needed to happen, and you play too passive,
right?
Because there's no drawback.
There should be zero drawback to walk here.
We have infinite range healing with Reku's infinite range
healing.
And if you play Venom, you would always walk into that right
now.
So the general goal is to always cut the supply, right?
It's kind of illegal to lose this fight.
Are you guys thinking notes?
Because I'm not.
Yeah, I thought we were going to straight win.
Don't tell them that I'm not listening.
I'm listening.
Now my cooldowns are burned and I see that no one is pushing
with me.
So I need to wait.
I'm still waiting because I need to open fight them.
But now they get to copy.
And now they can turn the fight.
Now we have to wait.
right it's okay to i swear i'm listening but the most
definitely listening right we still gotta be able to hit
their backline properly and now i go i told you i told you i
literally like realize can i copy the notes off of you guys
later yeah it is it is kind of bad timing to go down now
regardless very important to shoot in this year right duck
takes a high ground position which makes you vulnerable but
like right now it makes you vulnerable because you use bird
for it if you had started on the high ground you can bird
away and bait attention to that now they can punish it by
flying up and showing you right so now we obviously want to
wait it's okay to play a bit slower now and waiting for an
opportunity but it's kind of sad that we end up dying
because we kind of are playing into the into the ult a bit
much and we lost all the the space for and all the pressure
we could have also played further up as i said like we
allowed the backline to kind of walk into open area when we
have like kella namo angle and we should always control them
so it's it's it happens you know we need to go next slide
because the fight is lost now this is the position and here
this is what troop meant he meant you should go these rocks
you should go over here they can't do anything against this
oh my god he's actually like drawing diagrams on me all the
time no one is drawing on the thing you know but very
important it's still on doug it's not on me yet do not let
yourself get poked out then we're still rotating this
happens to rank it happens too often in the sense of i'm
still this thing is on doug it's not even on me what i'm
always doing is too aggressive though you know i think yeah
you actually have a white point it just doesn't line up with
the ideology that we want to about the aoe even but it's not
like you're a hella and but he's still on dog it's obviously
the idea is to have the long ls which makes up for the fact
that you normally take poke to win right but now that we
have a lot of it's because uh i went here because crook
saying someone needed the flank so that i just like did it
he's learning he's learning right now but that's why like
energy was ready yeah because uh energy new because after i
like did it the first time he just knew what path thing i
could go i mean it's kind of on me for taking the same path
thing though i should have changed it up maybe i go bottom
it's also fine to start mainly i think it just i mean as i
said we need to abuse the fact that we play around our
resource as well regardless of what resources we have
because that's a primary thing duck if you once again like
if you play bottom here and we have inverse raccoon and
everyone wants to line up here to put pressure here you
can't play here because a force maybe he's going one by one
and then next is ago and then next is maybe i'd be less
resources and the lunar raccoon resources were distributed
which we needed to distribute on top but properly what would
we do in that situation then against sarah like we can't
just let him sit up there for free and just poke the best
way the best way to stop it would probably to have our necro
guys did you hear about lego crafts bro i won't actually and
have tokybird line up the rocketeers by looking slightly
upwards towards you so we put more pressure on terror it's
the next best thing we need to force on top so that would be
the solution to stopping that next fight going into the next
fight because this fight is okay he mentioned me i looked i
looked guys so much you know we still get a normal fight the
next fight and we get actually good entry picks and a good
position to win because we uh we have a good flank here
going on and a good right this is what i what i mean right
if you come from the logs they should have like zero chance
to contest you this still gets value now duck what i don't
like is the fact that you don't take high ground here i
think you this ultimate example is is good at everything but
i think it's just too forced you know what i mean it's just
too early you should just wait because if they go back
further you still get to late later because now you just die
for it i'm pretty sure though Yeah, you die for it.
So this is like a death that is like super avoidable if you
just play a bit slower because none of us were ready to
walk, right?
For sure, we could have walked earlier and everything, but
we definitely needed to play slower.
Regardless, position is okay, right?
It happens.
We gotta wait a bit, we gotta play slow.
Once we have a normal fight, we can walk up.
The rocket ult, in this situation, Tokibert, it needs to be
deeper.
They don't have a lot to counter it, so you need to try to
get the rocket ult.
over here because what we need to accomplish is we need to
put pressure in this area okay and if the rocket is that far
away it's very hard to put pressure in this area because
eventually snake case you want to be able to walk here right
because you want to cut supply to the tanks this is why once
again your position is just off right yeah yeah your idea
should be to cut the supply to the tanks because our
backline should sustain itself or at least be able to
sustain it with the namoy angle so it ends up happening like
this they would like this it's all good you know we end up
they want me to all my rocket all further very important is
i would want to have more pressure on this area see it's the
same oh cry you see your position i'm doing the same things
you said it would be all so many times because now crook
looking behind he can't deal damage in main not dealing
damage in main means me and snake is can't walk deep
regardless of if what we do even though he has all the
resources.
Remember, on tank, it's important for warning to take damage
during situations like this so we can get something out of
play in support.
We need to occupy our supports too.
We don't want them to AFK.
If we AFK on the map, our supports also AFK.
At least to some extent.
So we need our Invis, if we have Invis rocket pierce here,
we can walk all the way over here if we want.
There's no prevent to walk here if we have this lineup And
if we have this lineup here, we take all the resources
because we occupy the support position.
So the support has to re-rotate if they don't.
All the people playing outside of the support LOS will
eventually lose resources, lose HP and lose eventually cause
dying or cause to Indusworlds or cause any kind of like
reaction from there.
If we're not able to do that, regardless of what comp we're
playing, we're going to struggle against against good teams,
right?
We're talking about the good teams.
This team, obviously not the best.
same thing i would also say crooks ults here is pretty bad
it needs to be inside of the enemy backlight it's not on it
can't be on point it needs to be inside of the backlight he
could is able to develop crooks area why it is here i can't
know for sure i would have to watch a pov on why he would do
that but obviously eventually i think he wanted to put it
deeper i think he like went back automatically and then the
same thing happens that comes away energy is good because he
punishes you for playing a bad position.
So once again, I have two DPS that force resources away from
the pressure where we want to go.
And Snake has, you're not walking.
So all of this leads into never killing background.
You know what I mean?
This is what I mean with development on the map.
You guys take development in a way that it just forces too
many resources away.
Can you rewind?
I think I got res beacons.
I want to see if I instantly walked or if that's just the
timing from when I came back.
should take high ground here i think and just shoot the tank
some points i think or could walk instantly to the team to
stack with the heals good mechord though okay kind of said
we couldn't follow up on it and now we have the same
situation okay same situation i think crocus no crocus is
definite right now i don't even know he's streaming oh you
don't have blood actually now we need to do the same thing
you need to walk he went offline he was out he's out all the
pressure on point you need to walk there's no reason he's
like i'm done i'm like too scared like they had no damage i
mean everyone is not playing the game as hard as it sounds
we need to cut the supply these guys are not bad you know
now once their supply is cut we can actually end up killing
them you know and now you take the flank without bubble so
you end up dying for it very sad i mean energy punished you
very well this guy was doing so much on strange he just he
knows exactly when you're out of position so he punishes you
which is also the same thing when he's on phoenix he knows
how to play around his resources so he wins most of the
resource trades and it's the same thing with terra
unfortunately but that's what makes the difference right in
the end of the just normal right i'm not uh i don't want to
like um say anything other than that it's it's obviously
normal right this is why this is why they are pros right
this is why they play every single minute of their life
trying to remix everything everything around them right so
this was just the main thing that i noticed right here in
this position right uh crook said dokey bird you should
cloak fate um it's it's kind of like the fact that we burnt
all roots earlier so now we have no other wind conditions
but you lie on you don't you good but obviously this this is
very hard and it can't be it can't be on you like the
biggest problem here is the way how we play earlier right
the one big problem in an example is we see there's pressure
on our back line and we have resources i'm listening i'm
listening with cloak so you should stack at this edge of the
point here i'm listening but we're not doing that so you end
up causing more real issues because look at our healing
resources we don't have burst healing on brood so by you
isolating yourself duck and taking so much damage you just
force us to walk back out in a situation where we might not
necessarily want to walk right i would want you to stack
with us so you can get advantage out of my e because you get
damage reduction so you can farm the goky bird ult because
goky is a very big win condition in this game for us at
least in this matchup but you end up like playing too far
away from us away from your can't like do it you know we
obviously need to prevent them from committing deeper so
this is like one of the things and this is like one small it
all has to do with playing around the resources that we have
right we need to think about what kind of like resources do
we have do we have long range healing how good is the long
range healing we have a good aoe or more burst burst healing
and that's like a large contributor what happened on the
hell 7 map is is kind of insane all right there was kind of
like a lot of fights that were so many situations where we
can create a win condition by just being in pressure
position but not taking them the amount is like infinite a
good situation is this one right i want to play up i want to
farm my my book right obviously I need to farm my book.
A big problem for me is the fact that we just give up space
now.
One big problem is I say we want to play slow.
I have touch forever.
That doesn't mean that we need to sacrifice giving up space.
I would want our Starload to shoot the Angela here.
We need to shoot the development.
The enemy Angela was out of position infinite amount of
times and we need to punish him for doing that.
Like right here in example you poke here for almost zero
damage against AoE healers without any hits so if snake hit
slams in they know exactly the bucky knows exactly where he
needs to shift to one shot you because he knows where you're
coming from so you gave up your position for 10 damage
instead of shooting the angela from main and then developing
later these are like all small things that add into them
being able to i'll still be listening guys i'll still be
listening i swear regardless of what happens now you have to
give up which is okay but we need to play a bit slower i
need i need i need some more There's no reason to fly that
much here.
I need stimulation.
If you just have a safe position where no one can beat you
and shoot you, it's okay.
We hit right now.
I go back.
It's kind of too early.
I need stimulation.
You know, because once more I say I have touch.
I came to an empty.
I have touch forever.
That means that the enemy mag would have to walk in this
area for me to punish it.
And the same thing would apply.
If he walks in this area and you slam backline, I have the
decision to either one shot the mag or shoot the mag.
or have the decision to shoot the backline and help you
right and the same goes for everyone in the team my phoenix
has the decision to shoot the mag or to stand or to stun the
backline you should always send the backline or to develop
on the backline and the same for the starlord you can shoot
the mag or shoot the backline one of these things has to
happen but now it's a very early commit and the rubber band
out of that commit is always the same thing now that the
commit is now that the hit is gone right and this is why you
have to instantly disengage when you say like there's no
reason for me to do that no i die it's not only that you die
but the problem now is the rubber band is they get to take
space i hope he doesn't talk about me so they don't need to
fear that you slam when they walk so that gives them time to
take notes for me if he mentions me guys you know the enemy
doesn't have wolf crap so now you walk and now it's the same
case you know now they can just walk unpunished so we need
to reposition or we need to put equal amount of pressure
equal amount of pressure can arise by going in the back line
right now with can do the same kind of pressure, you know,
by preventing us to walk.
It's what Terra did, right?
Terra flanked a lot.
He offends a lot at the right time, at the right moment.
So he caused a lot of people to look at him, and then he's
smart enough to live or to decide to go deeper, right?
And that just makes the better player.
So now we eventually get pushed very deep, and we don't have
our hits, and all our resources are displayed far.
What they do right now is very smart.
This is a very good combo, right?
Because it punishes the positional or like the issue that we
have by not getting hit by putting even more pressure along
the point by sustaining the fact that we can't hit now
because if we had another opportunity to hit maybe they
would have to invisible like this which gives me the
opportunity to touch at the edge so they can really clear me
while i get healed and they mention me unfortunately we're
not able to do that once more dokey bird you could probably
line up with me here to get healing or you probably had to
re-rotate with crook into me yeah two things had to happen
just because we need to make sure that this development is
going to be a problem to us because they're going to cut the
supply to you guys to me right so that is very very
unfortunate and i just get one shot i can't even react so
it's like very unlucky but yeah i mean everyone plays about
that we could have also what we could have also done in the
in hindsight's right what i could have done better is i
should have said snake as you touch around the point and you
walk around the pillar because you're better at touching
than i am and we made out the invisible and after the
invisible is gone you e and hit backline with me and came
back just in time to say yeah right there's for sure
situations here where we where either of us could have i
came back just to be like yeah right and it's the same for
my dps right i mean my starlight was afk on the other side
of the map allowing them to take that's okay i'm getting
myself right when you should have shot the right person at
the right time which was the enemy loki right when you got
done yeah what enemy in this match one of the two things
like if you go from behind right now which you had a good
position to do and shoot the enemy loki earlier instead of
letting him walk this entire space into the Invisold, then
you would at least force land, which afterwards would create
a chance for our venom to hit without the risk of it being
lambed.
That was so cool.
When you said, yeah, it's okay.
Thank you.
The next fight is kind of sad because we end up getting
entry picked early.
They'll never know.
Truth said, we want to wait.
Very important is here we need someone to touch the point.
Even we make a decision to have someone get flaked because
it's very hard to be protested but in this situation it's
not favorable so it's okay if we all we're getting vaude
reveal but we need to do it a bit this is what vaude this is
what pro play is like i had vaude i used to do vaude reviews
too and overwatch and scrims and coaching it was very
exhausting and then i didn't even get paid i mean the team
paid for my coaching sessions but like it was so exhausting
we should be able to just literally like six hours of scrims
this coaching session the body reveal it's it's so
exhausting it's like four four to six hours of scrims but
it's in overwatch like every day it's high every other day
it's okay we go next fight here we could have maybe turned
the fight it's like not fun point is very important and it's
very good and like what you would do with kev always it just
i was like barely paid for it i mean they
has to come back to the point which gives you yeah because
like each scrims are like two hours each scrims are two
hours um like for each session and then they would like do
triple booking scrims sometimes it would be like four four
hours would be like two teams six hours would be three teams
right because look at what they did the entire very
exhausting the entire formation collapsed that was just then
like i fell for again i was like well we'll try doing that
again we'll try rune so it'll create true moons...how that
goes...
And it's definitely very exhausting.
I forgot how exhausting it is.
But I'm learning a lot.
I am learning a lot though.
I'm getting better as a player, I will say.
Eventually what will happen is their back line will go over
the way back.
I think I'm getting better as a player though, doing this.
So I appreciate learning.
But it definitely is very, very tight.
I mean, I just aggroed like that cause... I aggroed like
that because we could have killed Angula.
yeah but who's supposed to kill the angela he has triple
pocket by supports and in the shield loki land yes uh all
that you rely on right now is the fact that snake has hits
all headshots on this guy this guy has shield and who else
is shooting him yeah it was before they peeled but we almost
did kill him because i would have repositioned sooner but
can you stop by i thought we could have killed him yeah the
idea of going for this guy is just wrong in general in this
room it's not about the fact that you can kill him you can
always kill people who are misplaying right the fact that we
i think it's up to them whether this guy dies or not right
of course their backline can just pull afk rain afk go this
way and you guys will kill this guy of course that's the
idea but the general fight should be that you are able to
develop on the back i am actually and now you're so scared
just because you did 50 damage to the end so the rather than
the fact of wanting to kill the end i was so scared of the
penny mines and here the That's a big problem to our dive.
Now we want to commit top on and you see what it does.
This is great for us, right?
Oh my god, I forgot that other people...
It kind of needed us to walk a bit sooner.
I get hit.
Why did I get hit?
Oh, I got underlined.
I get why we didn't walk early.
We probably should have waited a bit.
Nice pickup.
keep committing I keep thinking we should probably call
because it's like once again the same position right?
We wait two seconds it doesn't harm us you know and I kind
of commit because it's like Phoenix right, Phoenix right we
should just like wait one or two seconds because obviously
we need to remember what our team has and what they don't
right now very important is to keep working backwards we
need to make sure that we wipe if we don't wipe right now
There's no reason on...
Bro, who is...
The voices!
There's generally no reason.
We need to just walk past them.
On the backline, everyone.
And try to wipe.
Now this is good.
They've lost Inezol away from the point.
So now we can focus on living because we're not killing Fru.
It's okay if we can't kill Fru.
Wait, how is he off of that?
Oh wait, that's 7 meter?
And I think this was a good fight overall.
Because it puts pressure on them.
Oh, wait, it is.
I still think the matchup is really good.
The next fight...
Hey, man.
Wait, he actually leaps.
Okay, I can actually listen.
I'm like hearing...
Oh, he's the Adam Res and then they retouch, I think.
Ah, he's so fucking...
I mean, it's fine.
You know, the next fight is okay.
Good part about this though, is by not playing wall, and
this is like a common thing, we at least have three fights.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking alive.
like 99 okay it's not and the enemy has 99 because it's only
one fight basically i'm so alive because it's a back and
forth or resource thing one damage or anything so it's
normal to have these own fights this invisible is maybe a
bit forced and maybe a bit too early because it doesn't
really get us much oh yeah i just remember like yeah i know
there was a call for me to invis or to engage so then i just
checked it yeah i see that but what i meant is in the sense
of you heard the bucket sound and you're not putting
pressure on the people on the point similar to how we want
to develop on their background here we need the individual
to do somewhat in this area so we're able to yeah clear the
point side right and and force a 1v5 against the back or be
able to develop into an area where you can create a few more
later these areas
yeah it happens right it's not like so Very important here
though.
Nice.
You need to shoot Angela.
This is like a situation, especially against her.
I'm gonna say like a weak shot.
Back shot, back shot, back shot, back shot, back shot.
Mistakes are punishable.
You need to call out mistakes.
But Angela is very deep.
He has very bad movement during the episode.
Everyone needs to shoot her.
I have two DPS that are not shooting.
This is unacceptable.
Especially if we play these tournaments.
if we want to have coordination there's part of calling
stuff out and too many voices too many and he wanted to this
was a situation where i think she needed to die duck right
but none of us shot him and once more we're in the position
where both of my dps have a high ground offside of the
resources that we want to play right regardless of how the
resource is distributed because this individual could also
improve right we could also maybe have went top and set that
would have maybe made it better because then we can force
down the high ground and maybe we we needed a dps to play
main with us and one day to flank right the guy with flake
should flank which should be the phoenix because you're very
hard to be contested and we can join you on the flank with
venom and with um yo it's vaude review i'm listening to the
review right now but i this is my jingle jingo so i can
focus on the vaude review because i was like i can't focus
i've got to play i've got video game get out of my head get
out of my because he wants to slap he needs to start the
back line right there's the there's our igl it's literally
our our take whatsoever i'm listening to the coaching right
now but i mean because you're so late to the fight you did
like 10 damage to the diet so you're better off clearing i'm
listening to the my coach giving us our igl slash coach
teaching us the game we have
so now you should shoot the angel on the flank when you're
trying to flank whereas if you were connected to the guys
earlier then you could spin him and we would actually have a
chance to pick so these are like old things like they're
literally those things in a 99-99 game where they can all
make a big difference.
We all need this.
Every single player, every single decision makes such a
large difference to the entire structure of the entire game.
Although, you know, here I also die.
It's very sad that I died.
I was marked and I hope for healing.
But the angela was more than he needed to develop.
And solely, once more, because we had no development on
Phoenix.
If we have developed them on Phoenix here, then Angela has
to make a decision to shoot you out or to shoot my backpack,
which is great for us.
Because we still have the interest here, so we should use
that advantage to be developed for an agent like this.
And of course, it's normal, right?
Next fight.
This fight was great for us.
Oh my God, he's never gonna miss.
Because we had a difference.
Oh my God, no.
It'd be out of here.
We have resources.
We have.
Where did my team go?
Because infinite range...
Where did he go?
We need a TP.
Raccoon, Luna, Shark, Jeff.
Those three characters have really good healing on range.
No other support character has.
Touch because we're just dying.
Point's still the same.
The idea with infinite range healing is that we create kill
boxes far away from the people that play the fight.
So let's say like, I'll have Bucky, can play the fight from
here with me where oh i should just die oh yeah i got it
it's very hard to contest for phoenix because our lunar can
help you to rewind this area same with our venom same all
right we need a phoenix mag lunar damage boost so phoenix
going high ground would have been really good there's no
drawback on phoenix going high ground because it plays with
the enemy's fear of dropping in the back line and sad back
line can't contest it they have no movement heroes that
can't contest you so by giving flake to phoenix they you
off-angling in their back it's a constant threat where our
venom gets to slam their hitbox their killbox where you can
stun the i think he's getting different guys i could have
started i think he's getting different guys it's just the
worst of the game this is the same thing we end up killing
here we end up winning the fight it's okay and now it's the
same situation We need to create pressure around this area.
There's no other way of doing it.
My position alone hinders that from walking up, that cost
them 10%.
This is a positional advantage that we need to outplay.
And it's the same thing with these.
They have even more.
Oh my god.
They don't have another encounter.
Surely he's not.
So flanking right now and going in the middle of the same
way as the most optimal way.
I don't have to die.
support is so strong and ranked because everyone just
mindlessly shoots down main because it's when everyone
focused on main all you do is you feed supporters and those
supporters can be invested to play out their brawl advantage
into a right because they have a brawl advantage so they
don't want to let them play it out now all the damage is
stacking in from the same angle so that tank can absorb the
damage from the same angle.
So they can make more leaders on the point.
Therefore, making our hit weaker because all the hit will
contain is being stealthed.
No.
Yo, why are we on close misses?
Go back to what we have.
Where we have the resources to angle because before you can
argue we had resources to angle in a different sense.
Like you shouldn't off-angle in this way, but you should
off-angle in this way when you stick in the raccoon unit,
right?
In the long range.
He hasn't mentioned anything about me.
now you you can actually off angle because you have fake
value and you can go behind right but without being punished
because they don't have cooldowns to punish the only one
that can punish you is the bucky by shifting up but you
should better be able to do it if I'm here too and then we
can play slow forever now you wanted us to follow up on the
group we did that snake case stamps backline I go for the
backline but he just landed so this is what I meant Doug
when I said it's very hard to follow up on on any group
because they just have good we need to reset for last night
we need to reset but what is guys for sure
i think that's another thing like you're saying last map
just like target targeting and you gotta be targeting people
you call it like that like that angela you said that that
venom on yig's guard and yeah i think some hooks here and
this is the situation i mean algo and there's really like
this is like obviously since you're learning if you want to
get better this is the position where you're just like
there's too many people in my team that are not supporting
this area if you're behind them right now with flaking
example because troop doesn't see the value in flaking you
so he flakes himself for the damage boosted you know the
damage boost him but like he wants to do damage right he
needs to follow our our hawk eyes get it because now you
phoenix also from main instead of from behind i can play
that character i can try to dip them so ultimate goal would
be once more to set up a pinch right where we have front
line pressure and the opportunity from backline pressure to
make the enemy supports forces decision same with the enemy
tanks amazing to go for right like we had the situation with
the enemy phoenix when terror was taking the high ground
guys who clears terror who clears terror two minutes it took
yeah yeah they're doing He's doing a VOD review.
And then, yeah, because he's coaching us.
Obviously, you can have counterplay, but in tournaments like
this, it's very strong.
Now we need to wait.
Here's Nake's, same thing.
You stay in too long.
The hit is gone.
I need to instantly go out.
There's nothing we can gain out of this.
So just need to go out.
We need to set up a new hit.
Wait the ult out.
And then, once the ult is out, what we can do is look at the
ult economy.
They have two good ults out.
I need to be marked more.
Invisal deep, win the fight.
strange i mean if we prepare for that right now yeah i'm
gonna go grab ash too no enemies no nothing and we tracked
that we knew what else they had since we always asked yeah
so these are all things that can lead into it so here's same
thing if we play slow now invisible deep but our indesult is
outside of us not creating pressure on the back line so the
problem with indesults like this is yeah it just gives us no
opportunities to play out our advantage Right, because we
need to, during the Inversal, we have a Brawl advantage.
What the?
How did our mag fucking fell down?
Because Delcom is better than Brawl.
They win the resource trades.
I know he like fell down, bro.
Against us shooting Frontline.
We win the resource trades.
Someone in the backline is contested, so we can overwhelm
the guy in front that gets usually...
What?
You need a backup second party.
Where was that?
Now we don't have that.
Because the Inversal is far away.
I was full HP!
it's okay we play out the fight we had a situation where
maybe we can kill energy here you know we hooked them need
to have proper target focused it's quite safe he doesn't die
you know you can argue yeah mechanics play a difference here
100 it's okay the root issue of the fight is still the the
entire plan that we had around the way we played the fact
that we didn't have peace no you took zero damage this fight
which is just not the uh which is the win condition with
roscoe right so it happens next fight that's great i got you
i got you just got uh i think you got hope you know i'm not
sure i don't know oh i just like i was dumb i should have
went around you should have went i didn't like all right
yeah i don't know i feel like it's like the my honest
opinion on this is always the same it should be like visual
right now when you when you play the game i'm so lost it's
it's the voices the most what's happening the voices are
talking to me
i i saved myself i saved myself we need to set up the guy i
saved myself control you if he walks the highfields.
By shooting you out and then you're going to start out a
little side off.
This is something as an opportunity that you can take.
And the same thing applies to my Phoenix.
My Phoenix and you could take the high ground here and you
would have infinite pressure behind.
There's no downside.
No one can control you.
Mag can't just blue attack on the head.
The hell doesn't happen.
That's the only thing you can do in 4k to counter it.
You know?
You kind of need to contact it.
Because otherwise you just lose the game.
How do you control full HP Phoenix behind it?
Paragones behind.
We just instantly lose.
I even started going up there, but I just went back to that.
These are small additions in game plan that can change the
entire fight.
You know?
Yeah, that is good to go that way.
It's okay.
You know, it happens.
We win the next fight.
The fight itself is good.
Here was the hook that you wanted to talk about.
Duck, we can look at it.
He's coming back.
For sure, a good hook.
It's on the back.
Everyone is like, we need to kill.
We need to kill.
We need to kill now.
We're rotating with her.
And our comp is to fade to die.
Who's supposed to kill him?
What the fuck?
Who's fucking killing the fuck?
The force land force is optimal.
It's huge.
But this guy had 500 HP.
Who is supposed to kill him?
Six times.
What more can we get out of this?
This is optimal.
We get everything we want out of this.
It eventually leads to...
God, I couldn't do anything.
I was getting fucking picked everywhere.
so this is great anyone even tried a cp we can't get more of
this we get big wall too optimally right we wait a bit this
is shameless where y'all go we need the flank you still have
like not developed any flank i literally get late you did
like five damage on the dude every fight for zero like
drawback right there's there's nothing yeah i'm holding my
held site for legit over two minutes this is something like
maybe three because once more we have the same position.
There is no drawback on you going top.
You can't be a contestant.
I should have called it too.
I have to call it off.
It's also very hard to micro everyone in between, but I
should be better at it for sure.
Overall, this land is good.
We force resources away, but I am so scared.
Oh, see that.
I did that.
Overall, it's great that you force stuff right it's that i
didn't mention me yet you also took that that's usually an
indicator too overall fine we get enough we get a neutral
fight venom is good puts pressure on the backline we
actually end up killing flu which was great you know i think
venom is one of the strongest rules in the game and very
under i g uh very good to captain is doing a bad review i
can't
Pay attention.
Next fight, same position.
This is a problem now.
They have Groodels.
Groodels is a very large win condition for them against our
Cork.
We need to have counterplay against that by putting our
pressure on the backline.
So that the Grood becomes isolated when he actually ends up
ulting.
So my backline doesn't die through the support.
What we do right now is kind of good.
We have Phoenix on the high ground.
We have me on the high ground.
And we obviously want to drop on them.
weeping he's not definitely he's just he's actually like
good night since you want to be able to see me from me since
i'm a more it's better to play all right i'll okay i'll do
like in the in future
calculate the situation what it's looking like and then yeah
start We want to calculate the situation before and then we
drop.
Yeah, I'll try a little.
Situation is good.
Loki could have died once more.
This is a mechanical issue.
And this is where aim actually better for both.
Oh, my.
And this guy will be good.
And if we create more situations like this.
Shoot penny out.
Shoot penny.
Look how much we force.
We force land.
Shoot penny.
Focus penny.
And it's up to us now how we play after.
This is my fault.
There we go.
Because we get to this side now.
Look Penny again.
Let's go out.
Obviously we should go out.
Kill Penny.
You should focus on him.
There you go.
Now kill him.
Kill him.
You stay in.
So you lose HP.
Push cart.
We need three.
Again.
Because going out now with 800 HP or 600 HP that you have
left.
And then hitting after right after would create more
potential.
I am here.
You also get hooked.
And you die.
We're going to walk with my rocket launcher.
This is like, but it's common, you know, so did Argo.
I mean, as hard as it sounds.
Argo went in.
Start.
It's good.
Now you're behind them.
Always focus on right.
Did they see that?
You should develop.
Push them away, guys.
Phoenix to the right.
And right-hand peek is so important in this game.
She's still here.
You see 25% on the left screen.
And you see 75% on the right screen.
and the weapon hits from the right side as well.
So there's no drawback on it.
Peaking from the left side only makes it harder for you to
flange and get out because he gets to headshot more than he
gets to headshot.
I'm going to walk up a little bit.
Phoenix right.
She's looking for a flank.
Position lost.
She's looking.
She's blanking.
We loon all.
If the loon all is maybe too early, you know, overall, we
obviously want to try to kill three of them.
It ends up happening.
We're good.
We can use invis to last fight.
Look, Phoenix.
Phoenix, free kill.
Phoenix, free kill above.
This is the invisible that is deep, somewhat deep, right?
It could still be a bit better.
I think we have to go now we have to go now we need to go
now.
I guess they were afraid of the Phoenix game Which is good.
This is what we want to force.
We want to force mistakes.
Now we should focus on living this Right That end up being
into the enemy team.
I don't know if you get picked or not Why did he swap?
You should probably ult out here I think I tried to my all
got cancelled Yeah, I don't even know what it got cancelled
by What if it can cancel invisible cancels bug you all
that's great I thought it looked like my grow coat.
Yeah, he's pro.
He's the pro.
Oh, it was not in this pool.
Oh, Phoenix stun.
Yeah, I won.
As far as I'm aware.
Yeah, that's me.
But then, I don't know what it can cancel by.
Yeah, I remember.
Okay, you're dead.
We can still win next situation now this is my problem i
need to have the development from my phoenix here because
you played not the right not the right not the left side now
it's harder for you to retake what the fuck he's so tiny oh
my god now you've been late to the hits you're also look at
how tiny is now they get to react there's no pressure right
now look at him and you hit at the same time snake is also
right now we have a serious chance of turning the fight what
do you there's so many opportunities that we can create for
ourselves to turn fights like this but because you show
yourself early and it's not deep enough because you can't go
as deep as you want now he gets to turn and now they get to
back away from you and to control you now he's coming and
now you're going back you see the synergy we are the same
way and that happens so many times i follow this daddy jeff
and which would be way stronger in this position or in most
positions so now snake has goes in pulls great force once
more same situation it's in our hands now we need to get out
and then after that we hit the phoenix with flank you go
into them they all die daddy who's my daddy where did he go
where did my daddy we call to live okay you know here's what
about comboing like what about comboing phoenix let them for
the glass fight no he disappeared my son if we see the
opportunity for it the problem is we didn't my son you know
it's okay and they also have it's not like it's on counter a
little guys our cycles are more important and the way in the
synergy around the neutral is way i lost him in ikea which
tiny mantis and there's a parent oh my god look at how he's
so tiny look at him very important is to go up further you
should listen to my call i say i touch at the edge so oh
yeah i just because you end up dying here my shield as well
it's just once again now our hit is just not less hard you
know obviously we want to hit it's also okay to give flip in
this position because it last fight in theory we can live
here yeah this is why i give flip right i touch until i give
flip and if we had full hp venom now with my engage here we
can turn the fight so we can also call now maybe we give him
lift and don't give it heights and then we innocent deep
invisible deep now and the only response is mac it's which
is very easy countable because all of us have either sought
or or a cooldown where we don't feed the mac oh they eat the
thing not the mag but kill the kill the backlight right if
we invisible deep here still fine incomplet not deep on the
backline so it's just not good enough we can put we can't
get anything out of this other than building more time to
reset another dive.
Meanwhile, Argo dies.
Question is, how does he die?
He's looking at it.
Okay, I just need Invis on Deeper.
You tried to touch, right?
Or whatever.
You walk in from the left side so you don't see what's
happening on the screen.
Alright, that's all I need to do.
Invis on Deeper.
You shoot the dude for zero damage.
Because no one puts a P pressure.
We can't get anything out of this.
The only thing we can gain is for the Invis to look away for
two seconds, which doesn't give us anything.
The only thing it does is It like forces away the chance of
your hit to be stronger, right?
Because obviously you want to go in, then shift in, right
click the floor and one shot them.
You try to touch with ult and now our ult economy is lost.
So now we can hit with the ult.
The invisible is the same, right?
It can also be deeper in the enemy team.
And then when Snake is still alive, because you could have
played to live, in their backline and they can win.
Now you guys see the infinite opportunities I meant.
We still are able to get a lot of it back though.
Even though Argo died, look at what happens.
We still have an opportunity to win because we kill Cooper,
which he kind of died because Gator just zombie walked
somewhere else on the map when he should have just played in
front to block the resources so his backline doesn't get
shot.
Now we chill, he bubbled it.
This is good.
the adam on flank flank luna and we push the invest and we
kill the invest
this is kind of unlucky dark that that happens to be honest
it's also unlucky that we die it's also double unlucky here
that we don't focus on living very important here once more
is to focus on living and in situations like this you should
always try to tp into the enemy team like deep cut the
healing to the enemy back cut the healing like the tp needs
to be over here what's happening on the screen over you this
is how i process my bot reviews obviously it's unlucky they
had adam but there was infinite situations where we could
have played better earlier where it would have given us much
better chances we have tp we're all back right their crude
actually ends up dying so this is was it all he got rose he
does end up dying you know now we should be able to wipe we
should like never like this fight here feels so sad to lose
because we had good resources now they're in result so we
should just respect the in result and live which we end up
doing and we get hooked and die very unlucky that crew gets
hooked same same kind of issue he had 92 old it was
preventable it's his mistake there for sure he shouldn't die
very important is now this is like a position all or nothing
kind of so we need to push inside of them you can tell that
but we don't really push that deep so i have to go out and
now doki get bird gets pushed uncontested and just dies
which she can't she can't do anything against yeah but like
there are so many situations where we needed my step was
like unavoidable so there's nothing to critique there but i
guess you get most of it there's like so many stuff was i
out of the line or was it okay i didn't mean to one it was
just like it's just how i always do it okay good we did it
yeah i'll be right back most of the blame was on our dps
let's go i think it should be too
my only critique which i should look deeper that was an
actual lecture well yeah i did it Anyone take notes?
Yeah, I take notes.
Of course.
What are you saying, Tristan?
Only minor criticisms.
We're all here to learn, we're all here to play.
There's no doubt.
If you don't want to participate in this, you're also not
forced to or anything.
It's a fun tournament at the end of the day.
Yay!
I want to get better, I want to get better.
Try and improve.
I mean, that's what we want, you know, we all want to get
better.
Did Krook seriously take a nap now?
I think so.
He said, wait.
He might have, yeah.
Wait, but then like he's the captain though.
No, this isn't a fourth one tournament.
This means everything to me.
It's for money.
Yeah.
This is everything.
It means everything?
It means everything.
Oh yeah, it means everything.
Oh yeah, I need to think we need a cop drop.
I like it.
I didn't cry guys that's that's a plus I didn't cry I got
constructive criticism I didn't cry that's a win wait it
should be that's a fucking win in my book I'm checking the
oh my god how many more okay wait what percentage rank game
now or not you already need to do something there's five
it's 5 30.
i'd imagine it starts soon when is the match tell you where
why you are around three started at 5 30 so it's been almost
two hours there's no way two hours for it for two games
isn't it of what no what what normally normally in my what
do you call me out for i prepared Now I didn't do that so
normally it goes a bit quicker.
I don't know.
Why did he call me out?
It's probably because of scheduling, you know, because like
some people some team started late like Who called me out
who was it?
I didn't notice two of them have like very similar voices I
would say Ago and snake have like really similar voices.
So I can't tell who called me up We saw me at the club.
What's wrong?
Don't fucking judge.
Robin's streaming.
It's been five hours.
Do you think we could even play against them?
I don't think so.
I mean, the only way it can happen is if they lose a match,
if they lose a match, then we can face against them.
or if the next thing would be if there's like four people or
five people five people with five one score and we have a
four I explained it earlier so bad at it let's say there's
five people with five one score then they can face the with
a 5-2 score in example by because one one guy can't face a
5-1 score yeah yeah it's an uneven number no we're not
against terror that was bait we're not against terror yes
I'm a nervous P again I'll be a boss the new knowledge we
gained terror would be would be cooked anyway I need to not
be I don't know I If you're so rushed to dive sometimes,
like I'm not on a clock.
Yeah, usually like normally with flanks and with off angles,
the best tip I can give is like actually looking behind to
see who's actually playing.
Yeah, who's ready for me?
Who's ready for my dive, my team?
Yeah.
Obviously you can create a situation where your team can be
easier to walk up.
That's what I like to do.
When my team is not ready in pro play, I like to like dive
in and instantly go out because it makes all the enemies
turn, which gives us time to set up the hip much better.
without me losing anything for it, you know?
This is like the secret trust me tech to winning worlds.
Yeah, I see, I see.
I'm back.
I don't finish my chicken nuggets.
Well, I finished it when we were fighting that diamond team.
Guys, do you think I can risk a rank game?
Guys, I'm gonna do it.
You know what?
I'll do a quick play game.
This quickly is bad.
I'm gonna do a quick play game.
I'm gonna death in.
And then no more voices, guys.
No more voices.
I need some jingle jangles right now.
I need some jingle jangles.
I need some stimulation to the brain.
Oh, but if I win a game right now, if I win a game right
now, I'd be Celestio.
I could join my Celestio brothers.
all right let's go I'm not oh I was gonna say I'm not
playing support well I guess I am I guess I am I don't care
Fuck you guys That's right I'll try solo here Let's go You
think you have That's red I'll try solo here I wanna play
hella Need a strategist Well You Oh wait He played king Well
Jokeshaw I'm playing hella Fuck this I already play
strategist This is hella time No more support jealous with
me Fuck it we all try solo heal I'm like the only one with
me and the tank is the only one with no lord Oh my god this
person of a scarlet lord icon Holy shit For the vibes Oh my
god it's everywhere It truly is What the fuck Hello, where's
my solo Helotron?
Don't worry, I'm fucking only one shooting.
Oh, she caught shit.
Oh my god, he's one.
Okay, I did it.
Yeah, an animated Lord Ahakai.
Bro, what the fuck they have triple support?
Okay, one team is vibing and one is definitely not vibing.
One team is definitely not vibing.
running triple support holy shit that's crazy triple support
here
bro that's crazy this isn't even rigged
oh my god what can i even kill you know what i'm cosping i'm
gonna cospe as mock you know how to play hot guy i'm
actually not a hot guy player i actually don't even know
like the util other than shoot both oh that's what it does
all right oh
my god he was so low though come on guys i'm practically
like You know what?
If you think about it, I'm technically like the widow.
Hawkeye is like another form of widow.
Are we actually gonna keep fighting this?
Because nope.
Hello.
At least we're quick playing.
Oh.
It's my turn.
I'm...
shit all right it's fine we're running okay now okay i'll
and then we'll do something for real yeah please don't yell
at me i'll cry i almost cried earlier please don't yell at
me oh my god we're running trooper
they're so lucky
I did it.
Hey, I got 2k.
Not 05.
Guys.
No longer 05.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he's actually one.
That's crazy.
Come on, show me.
Show me that hand.
Here we go.
Oh, fuck.
Wait, I'm actually doing...
Oh, I'm fine.
I'm actually doing shit.
Alright, I guess I should play an actual hero.
I know how to play.
Eh, fuck it.
They're going through it, might as well.
It's called a duty time.
What the fuck?
I keep forgetting.
Okay, maybe...
Maybe I should just play Hawkeye Wait, wait, wait, I'm
almost at 80 though.
I'm almost 80.
I'm John Rivals.
Oh, goodbye I am John Rivals
Really?
Don't worry the rare DPS stream I'm too scared to come up
here.
I fucking knew it fucking knew it.
God damn the one the one time like were they did it plan
this where is this teammate we're we're oh my god i waited
so long i actually waited so long that's crazy i waited so
long to go forward because i was like is anybody gonna go
forward I know you're in there.
Okay, it's time to go, though.
Yeah, that's fine.
Oh, my God.
You can't kill me.
I'm in this zone.
It worked, though.
What's fucking hilarious?
I don't...
Can't believe that worked.
What the fuck?
That worked?
there we go get out of here where are you
oh they're sick look you're crazy wait i love this
all right whoa oh okay it's fine i'm okay i'm okay watch
this
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa you think i'm gonna let you Fuck you
in particular Bro, bro, fuck the tree.
This is the only reason why I went with Punisher It was for
the fucking tree That tree is not playing that game no more
I'm not letting that tree play the game No Oh my god
headshots for days
Are you kidding me?
Please.
Oh my god.
I'm trying.
I really am.
Fuck this one tree.
Fuck this one tree in particular.
Like...
Fuck that one tree.
I'm not letting that tree play the game.
Oh, he soft dropped.
Stop, stop!
What's the point?
Bro!
Flynn's punishing!
There's no meaning no more!
Bro, that guy's fucking dead.
Worth it.
Fucking worth it.
too fuck everybody i literally made the fucking group swap
i don't even play Punisher that's the set five oh that's not
fine it's no longer fine
goodbye we got work talking out honestly It went better than
I expected.
Did not think that would work.
That's fine.
I got one, guys.
I don't think we're winning this, though.
Unless we do have Rocket Up.
With Rocket Up, I could just stand in my turret for it.
Oh.
It's pressing fire.
Suppressing fire!
Okay, it didn't work though.
Talking to that.
That worked out a lot better than I expected.
Look at that guy.
Yeah!
Ace!
Yeah, no, I don't understand either.
Shotgun jump!
dodges chaka jump dodges jeff up but when i jump really
really high it doesn't matter like but when i want to jump
really really high fuck me i guess yeah i'm gonna play dps i
know i'm so locked in guys i could have played a ranked game
guys that's it i'm checking the i'm checking the thing guys
i just need if i managed to get a game before seven hours,
we break our record.
We managed to do four games in six hours.
Our record is three games in seven hours.
If we can get a fourth game, then it'll be four games in six
hours.
Oh my god, please.
not go too crazy here i don't even know how many okay how
where do i check this what's the percentage right now for
how midline for one 75 okay no they're fucking with me it's
75 completed no there's no way i'm i'm checking this thing
right now
there's no way i'm checking right now brackets is it by
bracket oh yeah There we go.
Uh...
Is it pool one?
Are we pool one?
Open qualifier.
Is that it?
I can't tell.
It's 75% like...
Okay.
Guys, too many teams participated.
It's so many teams.
Who came back?
I don't even know who came back.
I'm doing it.
Round four.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Saved by the bell.
I was like, I'm ready to queue up another game right now.
Is it really?
Oh my god.
Round four.
X number.
Trust me.
i do yeah i remember playing the one on the ds i was
actually like a fire game whatsapp yeah you got what he's
the captain he needs to check us in oh wait this is starting
this is starting
oh man whatsapp my my phone number doesn't work right now oh
man this guy oh no he didn't didn't nap for a while
I'm alive.
Oh, nice.
Did you take your nap?
He declined.
Like a power nap.
More nap.
All right.
I know like all the enemy team or a lot of them.
Who is it?
Yeah.
Jelly peanut perk.
Ente blaze.
Oh, jelly peanut.
No way.
It's jelly peanut.
They lost their first game.
Yeah.
I don't know who they I don't know who the people they
played with or played against Ellie peanuts are a really
good penny
I don't recognize the people they lost against though though
oh my gosh our fourth game I'm so proud of us I can't wait
to sleep I'm back
you only slept four hours yeah our fourth game i can't
really sleep a lot i don't recognize any of the players
except for jelly peanut have you tried like magnesium should
i like the glycinate oh that one's like the like that helps
you relax your muscles i don't know if you're like stressed
or like if you're thinking a lot i feel like for me
melatonin doesn't help a lot I just think God, I did not
queue up a rank game.
My quick play game was, like, just in time, too.
I think the funniest...
Okay, wait, I need to know.
What's the rank?
Feach, my lord.
It's him, right?
No, it's him.
Oh, my God.
He went Venom in the end.
All right, Egbert.
Who did I bully?
Oh, wait, he's a Grandmaster player.
All right, it wasn't that much of a bully, guys.
He's, like, GM, too.
And I'm, like...
don't play deep i don't play dps and rivals but i still them
up right i still i still might have um i might have bullied
them a little on yeah wait these guys aren't wait what the
these guys aren't bad in quick play yeah how's terror
playing celestial plays again his luck legacy damn yeah like
there's a bunch of two teams that are 3-0.
Yeah, we got to pray.
Yeah, we just got bad RNG.
Yeah, we literally gotten lucky, yeah.
We need Terra and Energy to play each other.
Yeah.
I mean, they probably will.
There's eight rounds.
No, need them to play.
No, they'll go on the field, and it's fine.
It's better for us because we don't face them.
Yeah, we need them to not get each other and just win
everything.
No, we will beat them, though.
We progressively got it.
We've progressively got it.
we got better like every game against them i feel like yeah
like our first screen versus terror we got completely
stomped every game but we started getting better these guys
lost prestige who is this and i don't recognize i don't
recognize any of the names i'm making lobby oh we're we're
higher seed finally higher seed than them we did it we
We're almost there, guys.
I should make my waiting room.
I'm going to make my...
I still want to do the zombie.
Is your cough getting better?
I...
I don't know.
Guys, I...
It's like, alright.
I don't know.
I got an invite.
I do...
I want to play.
a zombie game.
Unless I move it for tomorrow.
I could move the zombie game tomorrow.
Yes.
I'm not always sick.
It happens like once or twice a year.
And it's just I have a really bad lingering cough.
My coughs are just...
My coughs always last forever.
That's like the worst part.
Yeah, we move it for tomorrow.
I may still have the tournament tomorrow.
But maybe it'd be shorter.
The other thing is jelly peanut.
He's a yes, a diamond.
He's diamond?
There's no jelly peanut, is there?
Wait, is that the same entate?
Oh, this is jelly peanut.
Wait, is that the same entate I got, like, banned on some
servers?
Or is that a different one?
I just know he was on a call with Kingsman after the thing.
Oh, yeah, that guy's like a I think he's a tick-tock guy.
He's like at the drama tick-tock, right?
Yeah, yeah, I think he is
It is the same game What are we missing we are missing?
Oh, trust.
Yeah Oh, there he is I think his mic stopped working again
No, I'm currently busy playing a Mario game apparently oh
that's on me oh my god and he stole the star it's over
oh my god oh my what drama oh and he was um he was like one
of the people that king's been called i think was he the one
that told kings he was the one that told kingsman like to
not make the video right is that was i don't know i've lost
track on the story
is that this or was that a different guy remember he was a
draw he's a drama marvel rivals uh tick tocker i know it's
so specific yeah it's oh yeah he's the just business guy
yeah it's just business gg he was the one that was like gg
go next don't make a video and then kingsman made a video
there was there's too many people involved now that i've
lost track i've literally lost track of the story because
there's too many people involved in it now
yeah i know it's so specific drama marvel rivals tick tocker
it's so specific i didn't even realize that's the thing like
we had enough drama for that
if i wouldn't just maybe i'll have a tick tock video make
made of me i don't think they even read what you said
i no but i've lost track of the story like of the
development of the story I'd be like every day something new
happens.
I was like, there's more to the story?
I would be like, I thought it was over.
I was just back, Vita, whatever.
Yeah.
What?
To the survey.
To what survey?
Trust me?
We don't have another band.
yeah i'm ready i'm ready all right get in go keep yeah oh
yeah i'm ready all right i'm good hell's haven okay ready
but i know that that is crazy honestly i'm just glad that
kingsman is getting like the support like for everything in
the end like apparently he made a he made a twitter account
just to drop more evidence it was crazy he literally made
like i was like whoa yeah but he made he got a lot of like
support from it i want to put on socks which is good i mean
which heroes will get my cosmic don't play with socks he
doesn't have to worry about like is expensive he doesn't
have to worry about like college tuition for a while too
which is good he focused because i saw that he was trying to
be a mechanical engineer so like that is so fucking
expensive especially if he's american magic and he tried to
like like the student loans and stuff like that for it so
i'm glad that like he's able to i'm glad he's able to i
don't know what you're like not worried about money for that
no i'm trolling wait what He doesn't play penny.
Am I trolling?
Yes, he does not.
No, I'm trolling.
I'm thinking of someone else.
What?
I bet.
Oh shit.
I was gonna say, I was like, I'm pretty sure Jelly is not a
penny player.
He plays mag and magic.
No, I was thinking of Jelly Moon.
No, I'm stupid.
Ignore me.
I was thinking of Jelly Moon.
Yeah.
I'm glad he was able to make a career in the end.
I saw he was like playing with like a lot of, he's like,
literally, He got invited to a bogey bash and just turn him
in right after.
Yeah, that's really good.
Surprised you don't have it.
I'm glad.
It's like the best sounding one.
They knew I'm an emerald trick.
No?
They know that.
Save Mac.
Mac's good.
I like Mac.
Magneto.
We go Groot Mac, I think.
No?
Okay.
Or Deadpool?
Matt is Groot Mac.
Grant.
group mech they've been they're probably been met this other
man yeah they've been nothing we go bucky triple group mech
uh soup okay i'm not the type who fades quietly into the
background soup
oh i'm so ready for my food later i'm just gonna watch i
don't know what i watch content or whatever what can i watch
on youtube or is there anything new to watch anime you like
yeah watch your watch anime yeah what's your favorite anime
episode there's a new hero
who i like to come make a kill so people don't like that one
yeah i don't know he said a new what episode at least it
finishes after one episode this is a new one season three of
jjk is actually peak so good man i need to watch it's so
good it's so good yeah i think it's the best episode like
one of the best episodes so far and the whole thing guys i
know i started this but we need to look in yeah we need luck
in luck in luck in last game last game and then we're
between all like friends and we can play mario together i'm
going to bed i'm pretty sure kirk is gonna pass out speed
boost auto-spawn could i be damage boosting you trust me
Bucky.
Yeah, always damage boost me and Bucky.
I feel like we're supposed to be careful.
Yeah, I care.
Yeah, care.
They might make a play here.
They're going to play Magic Strange.
Play on range.
They're on four, Emma.
Hella funny.
Just take all the map.
Take left side.
Walk out, walk out.
Just walk out.
Swing into them.
Two, one.
Wait out the soup bubble.
I'm shooting the Thor.
Shoot the Thor.
Can you play in front of me in this matchup, Snakes?
Walk forward on the Emma.
Kill the Emma.
I'll pull the Emma.
Nice kind of cook.
This is nothing.
I thought we were.
Good!
Walk forward.
Walk.
Keep walking.
I blow him.
Just kill them.
Just kill them all.
Nice.
No more, no more, no more.
Okay.
We just chill, we just chill.
Come back.
They have everything, right?
I don't think they should be able to build anything.
We can set it up neutral.
They don't have anything yet.
Yeah.
only win condition their only win condition is cloak and
punish old okay we need to cut we need to have invisible for
punish okay and invisible funny and trust me what a combo
yeah we don't need let me know when to all the crack okay
just try my mama yeah you can keep if you hook the forehand
or something to solo him i can i can like it like it in this
way it's fine regions.
One more.
Ready?
Three two one.
Look Emma!
Look Emma.
Look Emma, look Emma look Emma.
All one, all one.
Okay, you made Podchain.
Medicine Do you have medicine.
Medicil down.
I don't have it.
Don't have it yet.
I'm getting CC chain.
I'm altering now.
Where are they going?
Where they're going?
Cloak, Cloak, Cloak.
Break, break, break.
Break, break.
No, no, no, no, no.
I push.
Ste gonna Emma.
Steak Emma.
We need a snack as jelly peanut for the content!
I sliced them across the map.
I tried to go for an axe when I played.
Shoot them a lot.
They have nothing to walk with.
That's true, that's true.
They use every supply.
They won't be into them.
No, no, we just wait, we just wait.
Actually, we can walk in, but yeah, let's do it.
Can we walk?
Ready?
Three, three, one.
Emma, kill Emma.
Emma and four.
Emma one, Thor one, Thor one.
Honey one, honey one, honey one, honey one.
Nice.
Soldier.
Cosmic rays didn't make me who I am today.
My family did.
Yay.
30 seconds before you attack.
The silence is on the fields.
Rise.
Oh, you guys are all not saying anything.
I swear to you.
I say everyone.
I think everyone's just hella tired.
No, you guys are Americans.
You can't be.
Hello?
Americans.
I'm Canadian.
Trump, you're not gonna lie.
During the VOD review, I was in bed when my VOD review was
in bed.
Bro, Jesse was like, dog, you gotta do this.
Dog, you gotta do that.
Do we go top?
Do we go top or no?
I was like.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was a lot.
I'm not surprised.
But I just had to get a couple feet.
Did you process anything?
I processed everything.
I'm not kidding.
It's okay.
Where are they?
They're main.
With hella no.
Or hella Punisher, Moon Knight.
Triple, shoot him out.
Shoot him out.
You should take infinite damage.
I slept now.
Nice.
I'm boosted you.
So do you want me to stand in front of you or behind you?
No, you should be from.
Okay.
You can be pretty close to some of this.
I'm doing a lot of useful damage.
You kind of want to heal it at the same time.
Similar with Jeff.
I don't have one right off.
Just raid.
If they go top, can we match top?
Can we match top?
Yeah, yeah.
I can't, if you all, I'm here.
Wait, there's...
Just shoot the strange.
I got it.
I got the one point.
I slapped, I slapped them.
Oh my god, where is he?
I quit match.
You can just die now.
Boon Knights main!
I'm fine, I'm fine.
I couldn't do anything.
He's one though.
I kind of trod.
You can win, you can win, you can win.
Heap duck, heap, heap.
Lift,
lift, lift, just focus on living.
We're all coming back.
Yeah, just live, just live.
Alright, Mantis is coming back.
I'm 1 HP.
Yeah, I'm here, I'm here.
I have you.
I have care for you, I have care for you.
We help you.
I'm gonna die.
I'm here, I'm here.
Kill the globe, kill it through.
Three, two, one.
No, we can.
I'll hook, I'll hook, I'll hook.
Can we second ult?
I touched the point for a while.
I don't have it yet.
Hold up.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Ulting.
All ulted.
Kill it.
Two, one.
Press huge.
Press.
No, I want the kill.
Don't kill him, don't kill him, don't kill him.
I killed him with the hook.
Yeah.
They're on Spider-Man now.
They're on Strange.
Do you think they're TPing?
I'm gonna try to spawn camp the Moon Knight.
They're not TPing now.
Okay.
You can push into them.
They use Strange.
I double damage we see, Doug.
Truth is Strange.
The Strange is trolling.
Kill him.
Wait.
The Moon Knight, Moon Knight.
I got you.
Yeah, yeah.
All the way.
C9, C9, C9.
Someone touch.
I'm trying.
You have a doggie.
I got it.
Kill the Spider-Man, kill the Spider-Man.
He's not gonna boot me off now.
Shoot the Spider-Man, shoot the Spider-Man guys.
You can't do it.
Oh, they pointed the point out.
Muna, Muna, Muna, Muna, Muna, Muna.
Oh no.
I don't have a...
Do we have anything?
No, no, no, no, no.
I need it.
I got it.
I die.
I'm touching points still.
I need care.
I don't want to die.
Oh, I'm dying.
I'm dying.
I'm fine.
We can win.
If I walk up deep, I can ult them here.
I have set up.
We're on Spider-Man, careful.
They're gonna have Spider-Man in Strange soon.
I can ult them.
Ah, too.
I have like good ult anyways for them.
Do you want me to ult you here?
I mean, Doki are on the way back.
You're down three.
I'm walking up.
I'm not there quite, yeah.
I need five seconds.
Two, one.
We fixed.
We fixed everyone.
Oh, and I'm off the max.
I'm stupid.
Oh.
That's my word.
We need to move up.
We can walk here.
Play left side.
Oh, come back.
Come back.
Get out.
Skip space.
I'm going Angela.
I'm not.
Okay.
They're gonna have Spider-Man.
Here we go, top left.
Can we go top left?
Can we go top left and go deep in the soul to practice it?
Yeah.
I'm not back yet.
Okay.
I can go with Bucky.
They're gonna have a Spider-Man, by the way.
I'm just gonna copy in.
Hey, don't show.
Don't show.
Let him copy.
I'm here.
I can hit from behind.
Oh, they can.
I'm ready.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Strange one.
Strange all.
I have Nax, I have our Doki.
Can you go actually?
Yeah, yeah.
We gotta take it off the map.
It's okay.
Wonderful.
Shoot Strange, Gish.
I'm halting this.
That's good.
It's good.
Just wait.
Hela, Hela.
I damaged BC you, Doug.
Looked very strange.
Back yep.
Wait, come, come backside.
Okay, I have you.
Molina, moon, yellow.
Spider-Man, Spider-Man.
I poke him out.
Strange on point.
Strange half.
Strange low.
Strange in one too.
I should, Endless.
She's going to be.
Where is she?
Yeah, she's going to be here right side.
I see her, I see her, I see here.
Nice.
That's my bad.
I got to keep those commands when I was there.
You're good.
I knew that was going to happen when they're on Swidy.
I was like waiting.
All right.
One more game guys and then we're free.
If we win, if we win.
Not if we are going to.
I'm not going to be on Jelly Peanuts TikTok.
Nice damage.
Crook.
go with jenny
all right one more guys one more yeah that's the mentality
we're going in with i believe i believe in us it's been
going well so far
how many monitors do you have to give out a three one is for
a game the other one is for like discord no my third monitor
is for chat the vertical one and then the second one's for
like the obs and discord i see i think three was like you
the usual number for streamers yeah if you run a dc setup i
want to like he for but then like ram prices keep going up
yeah they won't be around because of ai
yeah before i started streaming like i wanted to do a dual
pc setup and i got everything to find out that uh my pc
wasn't like compatible with the oh yeah oh yeah you have to
make sure all that yeah that's what i'm hearing that's the
one thing i didn't check and i was like oh my i sat there
like after i like figured it out with everything all over
the floor and i'm like what is a capture card like why is
that matter for the well that's how the dual pc works
because you have to have a capture card to link to the other
pc yeah to click to the other pc oh yeah i legit had i had
like audio mixers and i had everything and then running a
dual pc setup is too expensive in germany the electric bill
is going up i am in germany um cooked maybe i can like Maybe
he can sit on the bike all day and like make my own
electricity.
Yeah, like a hamster.
I don't know.
Like solar powered panels.
Yeah, but they, in Germany, it's kind of like...
Oh, they banned Memphis.
Some.
Not enough sun, I think.
All right.
One more game!
Oh, oh, they forgot the pad.
or forget to protect it's not a scream okay oh my spread the
vibes oh my god yo i actually like that dan they might pull
it around they might have a really good widow
you'll need a top notch team to win this one venom deadpool
sure none of that i want to heal i think cap venom do i go
cloak or invis i think this is good this is quietly into the
background
cloak you don't get flake healing if you damage i feel like
i have all i feel like i just have all the swimsuit skins
i'm gonna get food chains the only skins i like uh we'll
probably play one game doesn't get overruled that'd be funny
is he actually like trying to yeah apparently that team
actually did get disqualified that they played against wait
really like overpowered team as well wait wait did it
because of the coach but like coaches are fine i don't know
because if that team is disqualified energies team should be
disqualified because they have two coaches yeah two coaches
yeah that's kind of crazy tier one coach because uh it's not
the spider-man fall it's a fun tournament yeah i don't
really care either that tier one coach plays like a strong
so it's okay let me know you guys are ready there's a hella
top right you guys ready for slam yeah yep i'm ready i'm
ready I can't I'm not I'm not ready.
There's a helicopter.
I got him grabbed.
Oh my god.
Look at that cloak get out get out get out We should we
should we should.
I am getting out.
I just got shit on my sweater.
I let no bird by the way Can we go on it again soon?
Okay.
All right, let me know Three, two One No, don't wait the
don't want wait the don't want those sports Can you give me
the uh, the flake so I can push back.
I need to get out I need to get out If he's one, he could
die.
He does.
Any more dead?
I pulled the mag back.
Spider-Man.
Oh my god, those are DD!
I believe.
Wish him away?
Thank you, thank you.
Spider-Man.
Spider-Man move.
I can't hit him.
Are they TP?
Maybe TP.
No, they don't get it, right?
They don't get it.
Oh, nice.
I'm up here.
Can we stagger or no?
I'm gonna spin here.
I'm spinning, I'm spinning, I'm spinning.
I'm on Hella.
Hella dead.
Invis, uh, cloak I mean.
He's going for TikTok.
Oh, you're going on TikTok.
No, I'm not!
I had a jump!
I'm alive.
Like, can we go like earlier before Yeah, maybe not.
They have wall now.
I can, you want me to ult this here?
They're in the room.
I can ult this.
Okay, here we go.
Come back, come back, come back, come back, come back.
Yeah, I'm out.
It's a good point, good point.
Yeah.
I have all that.
Can we go with mine in like three seconds?
Yeah, I can go.
Okay, three, two, one, one.
Oh.
Live it, live it.
No, okay.
We have throw in.
Invis though.
Invis one.
I could go in.
Nice.
I think I saved you.
Any care?
Ag, mag, mag, mag, mag.
All right, nice.
I'm going up.
I'm going up all the way.
I'm set up for the next one.
Jelly Peanut is back on good night.
So much for a maximum effort.
Everyone focused Jelly Peanut.
Yeah, he's on the left.
Main now.
Yeah, I'm ready to go.
I'm ready and ready.
Three, two, one.
Going in.
Doesn't have anything more.
Oh my.
Oh shit.
I mean, I guess that does work.
Now we got to do that against Terra's.
Yeah.
Can you give me a little bit of care?
We can go Moon Knight again.
Whoa.
I can swap with you.
a little bit.
I'm chilling.
Oh, I'm one.
I'm one.
Oh, I'm taking so much damage.
I bet I'm in.
Yeah, I can hit.
Two, one, one, up.
I'm going to get out of here with you, D.
I can go.
Shooting Mag.
Okay.
Mag's in one, guys.
Can we shoot Mag?
In this, in this, in this, in this, in this.
Mag is still well.
In Mag is one.
I got Mag.
Goodbye.
That is good.
score is three i feel like that wasn't coordinated though
yeah that was not coordinated because we didn't hide we get
poked out before that was my bad yeah we need to hide wait
and also he deserves to be passenger princess he's probably
against close you always bait engage snake case you bait
engage because you wait bait dome right against emma it's
the same too you go in you go instantly out to bait dome and
bait diamond so it's very good you know because then the
debate on the uh healing bubble right yeah yeah the healing
bubble the dome yeah right because then she doesn't have
that to defend herself she's she's very squishy and she
instantly has to just like try for healing you know
wait don't you don't want to practice yeah my bunny hop yeah
oh i thought we were running dive that's why yeah That's
cool.
30 seconds before you attract.
Yeah, right.
Very good.
Like, I like, like hard.
Is the Injus jump the same?
I thought they were on triple DPS.
It's just, you just, yeah, it's like, you just bind the,
bind scroll wheel.
It's the usual.
It's like apex bunny hop.
I want to see if the jump is the same.
Trust me, you don't, you know about like mine, like, three,
two, like for all the way.
Two, one.
I think it's the same mechanic.
I think it's the same.
Three, two, one.
What did you say?
Oh, they're lazy.
They reused it.
They're lazy.
I think if any develops are lazy, then...
No, I'm kidding.
I'm kidding.
They are very effective.
Yeah, they do.
It's okay.
I could go, Snake, if you want to go early.
Three, two, one.
Yep.
No worries.
Nice.
Kill the straight for it.
Kill the straight for it, yes.
Experience isolated.
getting out now yeah I think we'd be aggressive here still
yeah I'm gonna go on the right I pulled up I got it I got it
I got two I got two I got it might be luck I'll pull her
back I just must be how Tara felt nice I can't I can
upgrade.
I can stay close.
I can ult us too.
Oh, help Infus.
Help Infus.
Change us to our left, by the way.
I pulled him back.
Perfect.
I think you're high.
I mean, if you want to BM, I can.
I'm ulting in.
He's looking for Gurdl.
He's going to ult this.
I can feel it.
Yeah, Gurdl.
I'll bring it.
Kytus, Kytus, Kytus, Kytus, Kytus, Kytus.
Hit after, hit after.
Keep giving, keep giving.
I'm ready, I'm ready.
Yeah, we can go.
Ready?
Alright, it's having a three, two, one.
Get a ball grab.
Nice.
I guess it didn't help it.
I don't know, whatever.
That guy was in the Deadpool book, by the way, when you guys
told.
I'm gonna all hear.
You guys see me?
Oh my gosh, what is Crow?
planning what is he planning right now
shoot in this guys shoot in this
i'm with you kirk did they not know you're there oh oh i
slipped off you you're good bro are you fuck i think he's
i'm gonna pay him to you bro let's get him to point i'm with
you yo oh there's a moon that heading up oh wait he's dead i
heard a fist too strong oh goodbye everybody wait how did i
get him back he's a lot i don't think we have tp trust me
trust me i have to tp i have We should have, we should have,
I think.
Oh yeah, really?
Could you touch snake hits?
We can definitely do it.
Yeah, I'll touch.
Only 60 seconds left.
It counted to you.
You counted it down, don't worry.
It's canceled.
I'm waiting.
Damage was my E, buddy.
Three, two, one.
All one.
And they win.
Nice.
Good.
Hey, there's a strange here on our dog.
How does the new fly work on strange?
I haven't played strange ever.
Uh, it's like momentum.
Yeah, it carries momentum now.
So you can be hop a strange off.
Oh, boom,
boom, boom.
Oh, no.
Brother is dead.
Um, they're heading close.
They're heading up.
I'm out.
Actually, I'm out.
Oh, one, oh one.
Wolf, not passive.
Nice.
Nice one.
Back row, 360.
Yeah, GG's, we did it!
We did it!
GG, bit down.
It's pretty good.
Pretty good.
I actually do feel like we are getting better as a team too.
Yeah, our chemistry is getting better.
It's not like two coaching sessions we do a lot, you know,
but like they do something for sure.
They help me a lot actually.
They do.
Yeah.
I like the recent one.
I want him.
I think the one that you just gave.
Yeah.
We did it for over a year, so it's like normal, but yeah.
Gimme, gimme.
I need the time.
It's fine.
I want a better time.
Gotta take it slow.
Take it, take it to bed, you know, take a rest day.
Yeah, I had a lot of fun playing with you guys.
I'll see you tomorrow.
I'll see you all tomorrow Wait, do we have warm-up scream
again or or is it we go straight in?
Depends if you want or not.
I'll be down to do it.
I would be down.
I'll get terror again If you guys want.
Yeah, that would be good.
Okay, that would be good Back to LeBron James All right.
Good night guys Yeah, good night guys good night guys all
right all right so we either do zombies i'm happy we broke
our record guys four games in six hours last time we were in
a tournament well that's not true not last time okay the
longest was seven hours three games but we didn't break a
record we managed to avoid a record today seven hours four
games let's fucking go let's We are making progress.
Let's hope it is not another six hours for games.
Let's really hope.
I feel like I'm improving.
Do you guys think?
You guys, I think I'm improving, right?
Guys?
You guys think I'm getting better?
I hope so.
I was, like I said in the beginning, I was like super scared
and nervous because I feel like I wasn't doing so well and I
felt like I was shutting my team down.
But I felt like I was getting, yeah, I'm getting improving.
And also during VOD review, I wasn't a problem.
That's a plus.
I thought I was like, I felt really bad because I thought I
was like, I was letting Crook down as the support duo.
But during the VOD review, I wasn't the issue.
yeah yeah it was i wasn't i was not the main focus yeah it
was a very it was a very hard i know it's crazy it's
actually very crazy yeah and i have we're screaming a very
hard team we're screaming literally the hide uh the hydrogen
bomb team um yeah it's no no accountability let's go okay
some accountability i will say maybe some accountability
um but yeah okay either we go do zombies later after this or
okay zombies after this or we or we do or we push it for
tomorrow i'm gonna play zombies tomorrow zombies tomorrow
we'll we'll if we it's like if we get kicked out of the
tournament we play if we make it to the finals we play
zombies to celebrate uh maybe that's you know what yeah
zombies is our vibes game gotta start next room of evidence
for positive vibes instantly removed thank you super chat
sophia thinking thank you it was just i was just very um i
shouldn't i just shouldn't have read chat um like my my
teammates chat because i felt really down about it um um
because i was like i wanted to like look through like i was
looking through the vibes of my teammates just to see like
oh what can i do to play better because i wasn't you know i
wasn't streaming and then i saw like what like the chat was
saying about me and it like like during scrims and it like
really it like it like made me really sad it made me really
because i was like i i swear i'm trying i'm i i swear i'm
not playing for the vibes Yes, I'm swimming, I'm trying.
And, you know, they adopted me into their team.
And I felt really bad at first because I was just like, um,
yeah.
I was like, I was just like, I felt really bad because they
were, they, they could have picked a better, actual better
support player that plays the game every day.
But they picked me up instead.
So I felt, I was like, I'll try, I'll try my best.
Because I know you guys could have went with someone else.
I'm trying.
So I'm glad that, you know, by the end, with the end of it,
I was, I was slowly, I was improving every game.
I don't play this game every day.
I've been very busy.
I play this game, like, I would do like a couple of day
games, like every two to three days, but I haven't been
playing this game every day.
used to just because i've been like super duper busy uh
lately especially with like all the stuff going on like the
anniversary um the anniversary stuff and um um and other
future projects that i'm doing uh let's see yeah just the
super chat that you're saying but i'm glad i'll message
crook i'll be like what can i do what can i do to play
better for tomorrow tomorrow i can try and focus on that
today in rink see i'm showing crook that i am willing to
learn i'm actually too much like what can i do to improve
for tomorrow tomorrow see i'm showing incentive that I am a
good student I think he went to bed I don't think we're
gonna get a reply I I think he literally passed out already
um yeah with more confidence guys I have zero I don't know
if I have the confidence
bro literally passed out before um the pass out for that i
mean i can message trust me about it too see i see i'm a
good student i'm like uh uh i'll also message trust me as
well anyway guys uh we'll save zombies for tomorrow then
i'll make a waiting room and just be like zombies tomorrow
uh but anyway guys thank you all for cheering me on
everybody i really appreciate it guys um thank you everyone
for cheering me on it really does help me a lot i i feel
like i got more confident as a player as we uh as we went on
it is a very straight i mean like the matches um you know uh
the matches itself was uh was like you know it was just a
second match but tomorrow's gonna be even more difficult i
don't know if i should stream on twitch guys Do I stream it
on Twitch or YouTube for tomorrow?
Do you guys want to watch it on Twitch or YouTube?
I just can't multi-stream.
I can't multi-stream it.
Chat, that's the only problem.
Because if I multi-stream, I get like half the frames.
YouTube?
Okay, YouTube for consistency.
I will do YouTube.
I see more YouTube than Twitch.
All right, we'll do YouTube then for part two, day two.
I don't know if we have day three.
It's day three.
Twitch because if we don't make it I'll stream on Twitch
because I have to show up for the show match regardless of
what happens for my team um regardless of what happened for
my team like I do I do have to show up on day three because
I have a show match tomorrow um so yeah uh anyway guys y'all
for supporting me i really appreciate thank y'all for the
super chats uh the subscriptions sorry i was like wow but
whenever i swap between twitch and youtube i always get so i
was like stumble my words because i was like what is what uh
thank you for the thank you for the show subscriptions the
the i'll just say bitties the sorry my mind is so fried my
mind is like uh my mind is so fried right now
um yeah maybe it was a good call to to move zombies for too
much but i'm gonna fuck i'm gonna head out as long as
everybody say hydrate pause check get them around get that
blood flowing and if you stay up from me head to bed because
you deserve it i'll see you guys Bye!
Bye bye!